thank you
order a lot
the public order emergency commission is
now in session Albert
good morning bonjour
I see we have a different cast this
morning we're moving
geographically or figuratively I guess
and uh
to the different area of Ontario
okay and who is the commission Council
this morning
good morning commissioner good morning
uh the commission would like to call
Mayor Drew dilkins
and if you could identify yourself for
the Natalia Rodriguez commission Council
okay
well you swear on a religious document
or do you wish to affirm
thank you
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God I do thank
you
foreign
thank you
hey go ahead good morning mayor delkins
how are you good morning I'm well thank
you good nice to see you again as well
uh you had an interview with commission
Council on September 2nd of this year
you recall that yes
and uh we had an interview summary that
was made as a result of that interview
do you recall that yes yes and you've
had a chance to review that summary
correct and do you have any corrections
to make to that summary at this time
just a slight correction as it relates
to the statement regarding the cbsa and
the offer for tow trucks okay so let's
pull that up it's WTS six zeros19
foreign
to evidence that was on page five so
we'll go to page five of that
okay and it's uh the paragraph that says
Towing resources right there correct
okay so um what is it that you would
like to change with respect to that
paragraph So the the the correction
should be that cbsa did not offer tow
trucks to the Windsor Police Service or
the city the cbsa offered to help clear
the drivers and tow trucks that may be
available from the United States so it
wasn't that the cbsa had tow trucks
themselves that was offered okay so they
were facilitating the movement of tow
trucks and drivers over the border is
that correct okay perfect we'll make
that correction thank you
um and we'll have that witness summary
entered into evidence you also sworn
affidavit attaching two institutional
reports from the city of Windsor yes and
um we're going to bring well first of
all we'll bring the affidavit up it's
AFF
uh six zeros one three
[Music]
apologies council is there a prefix to
that number AFF
six zeros one three
foreign
do you recognize this as your affidavit
yes okay great and we'll go to the two
institutional reports then uh w-i-n dot
i r
seven zeros one
okay and if we can go down a little bit
okay and you recognize this as the
institutional report for the city of
Windsor correct do you have any
corrections to make to this
institutional report I would just make
uh one correction as it relates to this
is probably not material but for the
interest of being correct uh there's a
just there's a mention in there that the
city was formed in 1935 and it mentions
that amalgamation act Windsor actually
received City status in 1892. okay so
Windsor has been a city since 1892 but
it was Amalgamated in 1935. that's
correct okay thank you we'll make that
correction and it will be entered into
evidence and then if we can just have
this second institutional report win dot
ir 702
and this I believe is a timeline of key
events
and you recognize that correct yes I do
okay do you have any changes to make to
that institution report I do not okay
thank you we'll have those entered into
evidence along with your affidavit
so I understand you've been a mayor uh
the mayor of Windsor since uh 2014 is
that right that's correct
and my understanding is you've also been
the chair of the Windsor Police Services
Board since that time as well that's
correct and
um as mayor you are also part of the
community control group is that right
that's right and can you explain what
the community control group is the
community control control group is
effectively the members of our corporate
leadership team so the Commissioners and
the appropriate people needed to deal
with certain events and basically the
idea is if we have a significant event
we give information once to the whole
group and then provide a response where
everyone is on the same page and
understands what needs to be done before
we adjourn a meeting
and when you say Commissioners those are
the the kind of leads of the different
departments in the city yes it's it's
you know would be analogous in a
corporate setting to the vice president
right so it's the senior City leadership
team the city manager and all of the the
different department heads for each
department okay great and that includes
EMS and
um the heads of well I assume also
members of the WPS or at least one
member of the WPS would be there as well
if required yes yes okay thank you
and my understanding is the ccg was
activated during the blockade in Windsor
of this year is that right that's
correct and what kind of decisions would
be made at the ccg level
uh any sort of operational decision that
is required from a city perspective
um and and it could be traffic control
measures it could be the acquisition of
Public Works items perhaps Jersey
barriers
it could be procuring any sort of legal
resource that is needed it really runs
the gamut depending on what's required
in each situation and what's what's an
example of the kind of a decision that
was made for this particular event which
was the blockade uh well with respect to
the blockade everyone got together it
was very quickly determined that the
right incident command for this event
was a police response and so on the back
end we were providing Operational
Support to police and that was
procurement of Jersey barriers traffic
signal control signage
you know a whole host of different
inputs that would be required to manage
what police needed to deal with the
event and was there also an aspect that
dealt with us maintaining city services
and ensuring the impacts to the
residents and businesses was as little
as possible uh that's true so for from a
Transit perspective we want to make sure
that the transit routes that would have
crossed the area in question uh that
they can continue to be maintained in
some order that people could continue to
move throughout the city and so all of
those people were around the table
making sure that we were deploying the
right response to support police in this
endeavor okay thank you
and um so you kind of you wore Three
Hats in a sense uh during the event you
were the mayor of the city you were the
chair of the Windsor Police Services
Board and you were a member of the ccg
correct correct and so uh in your role
as ccg who was the who would have been
briefing you would that have been
um Chief lefort yeah Chief Steve lafared
is our fire chief and so he took uh
control of the ccg and was sort of the
uh I would say like the emergency
coordinator making sure that all of the
people were around the table and that
that the facilities were available and
he acted as the person in charge for
that group and as mayor would it have
been the CAO who briefed you
um
well I mean I received briefings from
the chief of police at the time from the
deputy chief Belair uh from the CAO from
City legal I mean there were a number of
inputs coming into me throughout the day
and certainly at ccg it was during the
ccg meetings it was a chance for us to
share information broadly so that
everyone was on the same page and that
we knew it was required and we were you
know for for lack of a better term
locked and loaded uh moving forward so
in many ways your three hats were kind
of together at the same time there
wasn't really a distinction between the
three rules that you were playing almost
none okay
um so I want to
familiarize the commissioner and and
others with Windsor and the geography of
Windsor and the Ambassador Bridge which
is the bridge in question
um because I think it provides some
context to what we're going to be
talking about in the next couple of
hours so I wanted to bring up
um the the map that was uh circulated
earlier
and so this is a map of uh Windsor
correct a portion of it yep portion of
it okay thank you and
um
we can see at the bottom there
the yeah that where the cursor is that
yellow
line that goes east to west is that the
401
uh yes the part that's marked 401 will
be the the portion that goes to the new
uh Gordie Howe Bridge
and then the portion south of where it
says eastero Expressway is basically
it's it's called The Herb gray Parkway
but it's a direct connection it
effectively is the 401 it links the 401
to through the city of Windsor to the uh
to the Future Gordie Howe bridge and
then of course traffic uh that bridge is
not open yet but traffic that is trying
to access the Ambassador Bridge has to
get off the 401 North of Easter Road
Expressway where they're getting on a
municipal road so they moved from a
provincial highway to Municipal Road so
maybe we can zoom in a little bit on the
Municipal Road so that would be the
yellow Road running North West is that
right correct okay and what's the name
of that road here on Church Road here on
Church Road okay and and so that's a
municipal road now within the boundaries
of the city correct that's correct
okay and so to get to the uh the bridge
we're gonna zoom in it's about five
kilometers is my understanding from the
401 to the bridge on Huron Church Road
is that right it might be somewhat less
than that you know say between just
around a little over three kilometers
okay fair enough and uh so let's zoom in
a little bit there
okay and so where would the entrance
then to the bridge be
so uh just to the
to the the left of where your cursor
your pointer is right there where that
Green Dot is yes uh traffic would
proceed North yeah uh and continue to
follow you follow the yellow line now
you're on to the basically the entrance
you know the approach to the bridge
okay and
um and so that's still within the city
and is that now
um is there any uh federal agencies that
are in that area that are in charge of
securing that area well
the response is a municipal response so
if there was an accident if there's some
form of criminality or something that
required police attention uh Windsor
Police would respond okay but you were
actually now getting on privately owned
property the Ambassador Bridge is owned
by
private Corporation and so
that private Corporation is
required to follow the provisions of the
international Bridges and tunnels act
which is federal legislation in Canada
and that the person the minister
responsible for administering that
legislation is the Minister of
Transportation okay and does cbsa have a
presence on this portion uh on the
entrance of the bridge yes so cbsa you
see the the red looks like a customs
officer a police officer that's where
cbsa has their staff okay great um and
so I wanted to to make the map 3D if we
if we can just to show the elevation
because uh the bridge actually starts
not at the
um at the river there but actually
further down uh in the in the actual
City so I just wanted to to show that if
we can zoom in a little bit so it looks
like
the bridge really starts
but we can see there now it's going
underneath uh Wyandotte Street is that
right
uh it goes It goes over wine that's
great yes right
um and so it looks like part of the
bridge
is actually going through the city
itself not over water is that right
correct
and the bridge itself I mean people
would refer to the bridge as the the
portion of the structure between the the
two largest pillars everything else is
the approach uh and so the approach to
you can see the the large pillar coming
out of the water there everything
leading up to that pillar is the
approach and you can see the the rise in
elevation as as Vehicles get on the
bridge uh and just north of where the
pointer is now that's the University of
Windsor campus it's directly adjacent to
uh to the Ambassador Bridge and they
have about 17 500 students that attend
that campus
and the other side looks to be quite
residential is that right that's correct
okay so if we can zoom back a little bit
Yeah and just move the move back
so
in order to then uh enter the bridge
drivers would come north on Huron Church
Road and they would enter what we call
is this called a plaza this area where
Vehicles would enter to go through
customs and go through the uh the border
so where the pointer is now you can see
if you stayed to the left on that
roadway that would be into the plaza
area pass the duty free and then onto
the bridge
and where that pointer was where the
number three is again if you stayed to
the left you're going to the bridge to
stay to the right that's how people a
majority of people I would submit get to
the University of Windsor each and every
day
so that is one way to get on the
Ambassador Bridge there is a second
entrance uh to the Ambassador Bridge and
that is sort of in the middle of the
screen where the yellow
dot is right there
there is an entrance point just down you
know 20 meters or 30 meters you can turn
in
and and access the bridge that way as
well
okay thank you and my understanding is
that the blockade occurred at the
intersection of Huron Church Road and
College Street is that correct that's
correct okay so let's go to that area
I believe that's where the green cursor
is is that right the Green Dot okay
thank you so
um so now with that in mind we can talk
a little bit about the blockade and how
it occurred having a better
understanding of the layout of the city
and where the bridge is in relation to
the rest of the city so thank you for
that
so you had mentioned that the Ambassador
Bridge is privately owned and that's on
both sides of the Border correct correct
um and
the southern end
the Canadian Port of Entry is as we saw
within the city of Windsor that's right
and my understanding is that there are a
few other points of Entry or there are
other areas to be able to get to the the
U.S side including a tunnel is that
right yes the city of Windsor and the
city of Detroit we respectively own our
own halves of the Windsor Detroit tunnel
we manage them together but ownership
rests with with each municipality and
what kind of vehicles pass through the
tunnel as opposed to through the bridge
why would one go over into the tunnel
versus the bridge the tunnel has the
tunnel is predominantly just vehicular
traffic Passenger cars uh
haulers Auto haulers can go in the
tunnel but there are weight and height
restrictions the tunnels 90 plus years
old so there are height and weight
restrictions in the tunnel so the vast
majority of truck traffic uses the
Ambassador Bridge passenger traffic uses
the tunnel okay
and my understanding is there's also a
ferry between Windsor and Detroit is
that right that's correct and the ferry
is used for hazardous Goods they cannot
cross through they cannot cross over the
Ambassador Bridge they're carrying
hazardous Goods
and um does any kind of just regular
traffic go also on the um the ferry or
is that exclusively limited to hazardous
Goods it's exclusive to Vehicles
carrying hazardous Goods okay and I
understand there's also a rail tunnel
that connects Windsor to Detroit is that
right there is and what kind of traffic
goes through the rail tunnel I'm not
sure in terms of the volume of traffic
but it's not it is not a double stack
tunnel so it limits the the type of
traffic that can go through train
traffic that can go through and it's a
generally commercial traffic yes
now according to the institutional
report that we saw earlier my
understanding is that there are over 2.6
million truck Crossings over the bridge
or there were in 2020 does that sound
about right that sounds about right
and this is about 28 of all of Canada's
truck Crossings
correct
and my understanding also is that the
bridge handles over 390 million dollars
of trade each day does that sound right
yeah so the numbers vary and and it
really you know the the estimate is
between 300 and 450 million depending on
the day depending on the season but that
you know any way you cut it it's
hundreds of millions of dollars a day so
between 3 and 450 is sort of the rule of
thumb
and the bridge also serves as an
important Corridor for travel for
Windsor residents is that right it does
and generally what kind of day-to-day
traffic in terms of residence is going
over the bridge well I I would say it's
there really are two kinds and so living
in Windsor we have the benefit of being
a a sort of that safe small City
Community in Canada and then people who
live in Windsor in our area often cross
for all of the amenities amenities that
you would find in a big city whether
that's sports or dining or or
entertainment you know all of that
exists in Detroit just 10 minutes away
but we also have about 6 000 people who
cross to go to work so people who live
in our community and cross to work in
the in the Greater Detroit area uh each
and every day and those are you know
everything from Engineers uh and a whole
host of healthcare professionals that
continue to cross even during the
pandemic
and now um you had mentioned that if
there was an accident on the bridge it
would be the Windsor Police Service who
would respond to that accident correct
if it's on the Canadian side yes yes
um now what happens if for example
someone's trying to cross unlawfully or
there's any another type of situation
that's not say an accident
uh Windsor Police from my understanding
would be the ones that would receive uh
the first call and provide the First
Response if there's other criminal type
of activity does the opp have any
jurisdiction anywhere in Windsor or the
bridge to your knowledge uh not to my
knowledge I would say that the opp is
responsible when we looked at the map uh
just a few minutes ago where the the 401
meets the Eco Expressway the opp is
responsible to patrol effectively the
401 which is which is in our area as
well right but is the 401 is outside of
the city limits is my understanding is
that right exactly okay
and does the RCMP have any jurisdiction
anywhere in Windsor or on the bridge
uh not to my knowledge they have a
presence in Windsor there's a Detachment
but I
I'm not aware that they have any sort of
operational
dealings with the Ambassador Bridge per
se okay now just uh going back to the
arrival of the uh of the Convoy that
that caused the blockade and to even go
further before that time my
understanding is that there were slow
role protests that happened at the end
of January is that correct correct and
were you aware of those at the time
I I really wasn't aware of them at the
time
um they really had no impact and and the
chief of the day hadn't mentioned that
to me uh and so I wasn't aware at the
time and these were uh convoys of trucks
going up and down Huron Church Road kind
of slowly in a slow manner is that your
understanding what that was correct uh
and as I I came to find out they weren't
blocking traffic so traffic to and from
the Ambassador Bridge was still able to
move okay thank you
now at the end of January were you aware
of the Convoy protest that was happening
in Ottawa yes
and did you have at that time any
information to suggest that those
protests might impact Windsor I had no
information myself and nothing was
passed to me at the end of January okay
so when were you first advised that
there was a potentially a risk
a blockade to the bridge
um and or that there was maybe a plan to
to blockade the bridge February the 4th
okay
so I'm going to take you to w-i-n
six zeros one zero
and this is an email dated February 4th
and if we go to this bottom of the first
page
yeah we can see the email is from
somebody at cbsa to Carolyn Brown and
some other individuals uh who's Carolyn
Brown Kellen Brown is a city employee
who's responsible for managing the
Windsor Detroit tunnel our half you're
half of the tunnel okay not the bridge
the tunnel correct right
and so she's saying
sorry uh Mr uh boazmir is saying to her
we have heard of additional slural
protests in and around here on church
and the Ambassador Bridge over the next
few days information on social media
also suggests that quote if we don't see
any change by Monday we will be shutting
down the Windsor border crossing
completely end quote while there is no
information that I have been made aware
of regarding protests at the tunnel if
any such blockade occurs at The
Ambassador Bridge we may see an increase
in passenger traffic and those
commercial vehicles that are able to
utilize the tunnel
okay so
um
were you made aware of this information
at the time uh not not from the folks uh
it on this email but I did receive a
call from the chief of police shortly
thereafter who told me about the slow
roll and and the police are monitoring
this slow roll through the city of
Windsor and at that time was there any
discussion about
um
potentially trying to prevent a blockade
from occurring
no what the chief told me Chief Mizuno
had said that that's when I found out
that it was already happening
in in the days prior to February the
fourth uh and that everyone had been
peaceful that there had been no blockage
of traffic to and from the Ambassador
Bridge and so what the chief told me is
that they were monitoring the situation
uh and she just wanted to let me know
okay and uh did the city do anything in
response to this information uh on on
this particular time uh I wouldn't say
on February the 4th
not not right away I mean what I did
when I found out I sent a text to
minister Mendocino just to let him know
that I had received this information so
that he was aware because we were
watching of course what was happening in
Ottawa and elsewhere around the country
and I just passed that up to uh to the
minister for his attention Okay so we'll
go to those text messages since you've
mentioned it w-i-n-402295
foreign
so these are your text messages to
minister Mendicino is that right yes and
so the blue is you and if we go down
there's some white
the white text is is him that's correct
okay and if we just go back up a little
bit
hi I know things are crazy for you
wanted you to know that police here are
prepping for the potential return of
truckers and other other malcontents
next week it sounds like they may be
attempting to block traffic to the
Ambassador Bridge so that's on February
4th as you mentioned uh it's it when it
came to your attention that there was a
risk of a blockade correct that's that's
correct and if we go down
he says thanks man let's try to connect
this let's go down a little bit more
this weekend stay safe okay so it sounds
like you knew him from before is that
right correct okay it's not the first
time you're texting him uh no okay and
he he mentions to connect that weekend
did you speak to him prior to the
blockade taking hold so this would be
Friday the 4th so either on the 5th or
the 6th I uh I I don't recall if we
spoke on the weekend
okay
um
now moving forward to February 6 my
understanding is that there was
um a risk of a blockade at another
location in Sarnia is that right yes and
were you aware of that at the time yes I
was and can you tell us a little bit
about what that was about where it was
and and what was the issue well we were
watching uh and the chief had called me
as well but we were also watching social
media and and traditional media as well
uh and saw that there was a a thread and
then a blockage matter around the Blue
Water Bridge
and that's in Sarnia yes
and um did do you know
um how long that lasted or when it got
resolved uh I I don't recall how long it
lasted but my my recollection as it was
ended pretty quick and did that raise
any concerns with respect to the
Ambassador Bridge and possible blockades
there yes it did
um
so let's move now to February 7th the
day the blockade actually happened
um can you just walk us through that day
what it was like for you when you found
out and uh and and what you did that day
well I'll say leading up to the seventh
there was lots of activity over the
weekend uh because you could feel the
temperature rising in terms of comments
on social media what was happening in
around in and around Sarnia we were
watching what was happening in Ottawa
and we know anyone who lives in Windsor
knows and appreciates how important the
Ambassador Bridge is not just for our
local and Regional economies but also
provincially and so over the weekend we
started making preparations to acquire
Jersey barriers at the request of police
I had made an effort to secure one of
our Transit Windsor buses to put on the
I would say the
the the other side of Customs on the
duty-free side of the tunnel just in
case there was a blockage at the bridge
and the tunnel because there were there
was the thought that you could have the
closure of both pieces of infrastructure
and we knew that we had to provide a
mechanism to move help move health care
workers who lived in Windsor and worked
in Detroit we had to be able to get them
through the tunnel even if their cars
could not get through the tunnel and so
we moved to Transit bus uh to the to the
the other side to the duty-free Plaza uh
in the tunnel and then there was there
was work being done to figure out how to
how to move that bus through because we
were still in this coveted restriction
period and there were arrived can and
all sorts of restrictions Crossing back
and forth through the international
border so work was going on on that
front as well and so everyone was
working very well together uh dealing
with whatever information we had and and
trying to provide and and prepare for uh
the eventual you know the eventuality in
the worst case scenario which would be
the closure of Huron Church Road leading
to the Ambassador Bridge and ultimately
the tunnel was not blocked is that right
correct okay so the the the bus was not
did not need to be used it wasn't used
but we made all preparations just in
case because it was imperative that we
had access for healthcare workers to get
through to the United States
okay so there was a sense that um the
temperature was increasing as you say
um and then on the seventh
what what happened on that day well on
the seventh we opened our Emergency
Operations Center so that is at one of
our Fire Halls the chief opened the EOC
uh there was a meeting
say nine or ten o'clock in the morning
that day at the EOC or of the ccg I
should say and everything was sort of
laid out here's what we have police were
on that call everyone was briefed on the
information that was available at the
time and you know everyone was on the
same page and so preparations were being
made if it if it got worse
and was there any discussion about
um doing any kind of actions to prevent
a blockade from taking hold because it
sounds like there was an anticipation
that this could happen it hadn't yet
happened was there any discussion about
trying to prevent it from happening
there were some efforts by OPP as I was
made aware up the 401 outside the
boundaries of the city of Windsor to try
and divert truck traffic that may be on
the way but I think it's fair to say
that if you know the city of Windsor and
anyone who lives in our city because of
the distance from say isiro Expressway
the end of the 401 to the Ambassador
Bridge and we're talking
three kilometers each way the number of
businesses the number of homes the
hotels that are built up that require
direct access to Huron Church Road it
would be for all intents and purposes
practically impossible uh to to
guarantee with any certainty that you
could provide a route for trucks and and
without having huge disruption to the
community not just the business
Community but also the people who live
on the west side of the city
right because here on Church Road does
serve as an access point between the
east side of the city and the west side
it seems to cut right through the city
is that right it bisects right through
and so you can imagine the Ambassador
Bridge when it was built you know 90
years ago that the road Huron Church
Road was effectively a road with Farms
on either side back then and over time
there are still homes whose driveways
require access to Huron Church Road but
over time that's changed and so again
you have hotels many many hotels and
motels you have lots of businesses and
you have a whole community in fact the
the western side of Huron Church Road is
the oldest one of the oldest communities
in Ontario going back to the the mid
1700s it's called sandwich town at the
time uh and so there is a it's a lot of
history in that area and a lot of people
live there uh not just students that go
to the University of Windsor but a whole
host of folks I mean there's probably 25
000 people who live on the other side of
Huron Church Road the west side right
and so there was a ccg meeting in the
morning and then uh what happened after
that
uh everyone was just making plans doing
the best they could do to support police
as they tried to mobilize everything
that they required to to provide a
support it was it was very obvious that
if something happened here it was a
police response that would be that would
be required
and do you know at what point uh the
blockade the Slow Roll became a blockade
and the blockade took hold I don't
remember the exact time
okay
to
um an email it may help w-i-n-402223
so this is another email if we go down
from cbsa to Miss Brown
and this is in the morning open source
information states that a convoy will
meet up in Comber Ontario between 9 and
10 this morning and start heading for
the Ambassador Bridge at 10. info also
states that they will only be going to
the bridge and the tunnel will be left
open for emergencies and emergency
vehicles
so this would have been
10 a.m or at 9 44 in any event the
bridge was still not blocked did you
receive this information was this passed
on to you uh I don't recall if that was
passed on to me or not okay you know I I
say that and I'll tell you I was talking
to the chief of police or the deputy
chief probably five times a day yeah and
direct connection with our city manager
and the department heads so there was
there was no lack of sharing of
information in Windsor we were we were
all pretty much on the same page and
aware of of what was going on and trying
to develop and devise a response and
especially try to help police as they
needed and so I'll take you to
w-i-n-6098
and this is another update from cbsa to
Miss Brown and if we go down
go down
so
um actually let's go down all the way
let's keep going
there it is uh so Mr boazmir says I have
been advised at all Lanes of the bridge
are closed and negotiations have halted
protesters have advised that they are
staying put and not moving they appear
to be setting up a camp of sorts both
lanes to and from the bridge are at a
standstill so this is now at 7 18 p.m so
do you recall hearing it sometime in the
evening that the that the blockade had
taken hold yes
okay thank you
um and
if I can take you to w i n four
zeros2204
now this is the
um the ccg meeting that you had
mentioned that it happened on February
7th in the morning
looks like this was the first kind of
blockade specific or Convoy specific ccg
meeting that took place is that right
that's correct
and if we go down
let's keep going to the next page
uh yeah we'll keep going
see no let's go up a little bit more
yeah okay good yeah so I'm looking at
um the part that says we do have a
comprehensive plan okay yeah so at the
bottom there Deputy Bel Air can you tell
us who Deputy Bel Air is uh he is a
deputy police chief in the city of
Windsor responsible for operations okay
and you already mentioned Chief Mizuno
who's the chief of police right
at the time yes at the time and so
Deputy Belair says okay we do have a
more comprehensive plan and some
fallback and negotiation strategies
there is freedom of movement and we do
live in a democracy if it is an
aggressive keep going down
uh public demonstration we have
incremental steps to take place as we
have done our legal homework
um do you recall what the discussion was
around this point what Chief Belair was
trying to express here
uh you know my sentiment at the time was
that they were doing everything they
could to to speak with the protesters to
try and find some way to allow a slow
roll to continue if that's what folks
wanted to do but to prevent a permanent
shutdown if you're on Church Road
and
my understanding is that in this meeting
the Police Service explained it had a
plan in place if the protests worsened
um and that
in the meeting preparations were
discussed such as Jersey barriers and
mobilizing uh Towing resources is that
right that's correct
and
um can you explain a little bit the
city's
a role in securing Jersey barriers
uh I'm not sure exactly who did it but
there was requests made and so likely it
would have been our public works
department sourcing whatever we had
internally as a city and then where we
were deficient in the numbers required
reaching out to adjacent municipalities
and trying to procure the Jersey
barriers that police had asked for and
my understanding is that the Ministry of
Transportation of Ontario ultimately did
provide a significant number of Jersey
barriers does that Accord with your
recollection certainly at the end of
this incident it we wouldn't have been
able to do it without them we needed
their help to secure
three kilometers of Jersey barriers in
each Direction so a total of six
kilometers of Jersey barriers
understanding as the city was not did
not secure towing capacity or was not
able to secure towing capacity is that
right we have a police have a contract
with a company
which is quite standard and they provide
towing services and so uh they have they
had capacity but there was you know also
there were threats being made against
the company and the owners of the
company that if they participated and
towed cars
there was all sorts of things going on
to sort of attack the company and their
reputation online giving them negative
reviews and and
doing a number of things that happened
ultimately so yes they were they are our
contractor they were Cooperative uh but
if the expectation is that they could
have helped move all of the vehicles
that were there including some of the
heavy trucks I don't think they would
have had it would have taken a long time
uh or they wouldn't have had all of the
resources required we would have needed
additional support if any attempt was
made to go in and and move everyone in
any timely manner so they didn't refuse
to provide services it's just they were
one company and couldn't do all of it
essentially I'm not aware that they
refused to provide services okay but you
are aware that they receive some kind of
negative
um
enough I guess uh repercussions as a
result of assisting that's correct
and my understanding is that originally
both the lane the North and the
southbound lane of the um of the bridge
was blockaded and then at some point one
of the lanes opened up do you have a
sense for uh for the kind of the
movement of the of the blockade and the
uh the different points of Entry I I
think police would be better positioned
to answer that but the briefings that I
received from the chief at the time is
that the ongoing negotiations they were
trying to get a lane open for emergency
purposes
uh and so they were at one time
successful in doing that and then that
ended very very quickly and part of the
the issue that we experienced
collectively in Windsor is that this was
a leaderless movement you know there was
no one speaking for the group uh who
could guarantee the behavior of the
other members uh and so police will know
better the timing in terms of you know
the ebb and flow of what they were able
to achieve but the briefings I received
from Chief Mizuno was that at one time
they did have a lane open but that that
that
agreement dissolved very quickly and my
understanding too is that the access
from why ended Road was open at one time
and then that also became blockaded over
time correct
and when you say a leaderless movement
is this information you receive from the
police or how did you come to that
conclusion yes that's information I
received from police okay
now on the seventh which is the day of
the blockade I understand you had a
discussion with the solicitor general
Jones is that correct in or around the
seventh it was the seventh or the eighth
okay and um and she asked what Windsor
needed to respond to the blockade
she did and so
um obviously the solicitor general had
responsibility for the OPP at the time
uh and I wanted to make sure that she
was informed of what was going on on the
ground but my question to the chief of
police was Chief what do you need how
many officers do you need because she
told me she does not have enough human
resources to end the situation that had
developed in Windsor so my response my
question to her is what do you need tell
me what you need and I'll help amplify
whatever you need you know up the up the
chain with the folks that I speak to uh
and so she said I need 100 officers
and so I Amplified that with the
solicitor general uh I I Amplified that
with the premier I Amplified that with
Minister Mendocino
uh and then there were conversations
later in the evening on the 8th with my
chief of staff uh and other Chiefs of
Staff at the for sure the federal level
and they asked for that request in
writing and so the chief in her own
right was already working through her
channels uh and so I asked her I told
her that we're getting the request to
put this in writing can you please do
that uh and she did that the next day
and so we received the letter on the 9th
uh and we sent that she sent that letter
to asking for 100 officers to the
commissioner of the opp and the
commissioner of the RCMP and then we
forwarded those letters as well to to
the folks that we were talking to okay
so if I understand correctly you it
started with a discussion between you
and the chief you asked her what she
needed she told you 100 you then went to
solicitor general Jones and to minister
Mendocino and said we need 100 officers
and they came back and said please put
that in writing and then you went back
to the Chief and told her put it in
writing and on the ninth these letters
went out is that a fair summary correct
okay so when you spoke to the solicitor
general on the seventh that would have
been to tell her the request for a
hundred and is that when she told you I
needed in writing no uh she never told
me she needed in writing and so I I
spoke with a solicitor general just
because I wanted her to be aware of what
was happening on the ground uh and make
sure that she was informed of what was
going on down here
and the same with Minister Mendocino
just here's the temperature and the
tenor on the ground here's what we're
seeing just so they had a you know sort
of situational awareness I would call it
and so they didn't ask for it in writing
it was through their staff really at the
federal level through staff at the
federal level who said can you please
put the request in writing and that was
on the evening of the 8th and then I
sent a message to the chief saying
they're asking for this in writing and
she had one of her her deputies or
superintendents put that in writing and
she sent it off in letter form to the
commissioner of the RCMP and the
commissioner of the opp and on February
8th that was your chief of staff that
participated in that staff meeting is
that right that's correct okay
uh and do you do you recall anything
else noteworthy from that discussion
with the solicitor general at that time
on the seventh uh no she was just she
was obviously very concerned very
interested uh very much wanting to help
and you know I we agreed just to stay in
touch and make sure that we were
informing one another of important
things related to the matter
and in terms of your discussion with
Minister menachino that same day was it
similar kind of tenor is that
essentially the same type of discussion
exactly okay
thank you
now on February 8th there was also a
meeting of the Windsor Police Services
Board correct that's correct
and
um
that was an in-camera meeting is my
understanding do you recall that meeting
yes so I'll take you to the minutes of
that meeting w-i-n40199
foreign
if we go down
oh sorry I think this was actually your
request to call the meeting yes so you
called this meeting as chair correct
Sarah Savvy houdin is our our board uh
assistant and so I had asked her to call
a meeting of the board I think I did it
if you went down even further I think I
asked around noon on the 8th
so and the the minutes of that meeting
are actually at w-i-n
402174
okay there we go so it was on February 8
at 7 pm
and we can see the chief was there uh
two Deputy Chiefs you were there as well
uh some counselors were there and others
and if we go down
to believe it's there we go uh Chief
Mizuno provided an update to the WPS
board on the recent situation regarding
the Ambassador Bridge blockade
WPS was notified last week of the
potential for this protest to take place
in Windsor
and then if we go to the end of that
page WPS has requested assistance should
we need it from Chatham police and
LaSalle police our top concerns are
Public Safety and S and de-escalation
what was the board's role with respect
to securing resources from other local
police forces
the board took no role in that directly
the board and I think you see in the
minutes was do you you know Chief do you
have the resources required to deal with
the situation what do you need from us
if you don't have the resources what do
you need us to authorize in terms of
budget or you know whatever was in our
purview to assist with the chief
providing the response that was required
and did the uh did the WPS request any
assistance from the board at this
meeting
no okay
um
and if we go down
keep going uh Chief Mizuno there in the
middle says WPS officers are doing a
fantastic job lessons have been learned
from Ottawa and from our own past
experiences and external assistance has
been requested
um do you know what the chief meant from
when she says lessons have been learned
from Ottawa do you know what those
lessons are
in my conversations with the chief the
largest Lesson Learned was not to let
this grow don't let bouncy castles and
hot tubs and sort of those types of
amenities come to the streets on Huron
Church Road and allow this to grow so
make sure that we're dealing with this
um you know as quickly and swiftly and
professionally in a way that I guess she
said provides for Public Safety and
de-escalates but don't you know lessons
from Ottawa don't allow this uh to grow
there may have been others that were on
our mind but that's one that she
mentioned to me and are you aware
whether there were actions taken to
contain it so that it wouldn't grow
uh police did take action with respect
to Jersey barriers and so they they
cordoned off certain streets and they
had
control of certain areas that I I think
you know made made think made their life
a little easier and was able to prevent
the situation from getting larger
and
um in terms of the request for a hundred
officers do you have a sense or did the
board have a sense for how those uh that
number was was conceived no idea uh it
was simply a request of the chief what
do you need recognizing that they had
already on the weekend I say of the the
fourth fifth sixth leading up to this
already put a request in for some public
liaison officers from the opp and so
they were she was already doing what was
required to ask for resources that we
may not have had that would have helped
provide for what she's saying here
de-escalation Public Safety it was only
when it when it was finally cemented the
situation finally cemented itself and it
became a permanent blockade she had told
me I don't have everything I need we
won't be able to resolve this with the
human resources that we have inside the
Windsor Police Service we're going to
need additional help to which my
question was what do you need how many
officers do you need you tell me and I
will help amplify that you know at the
political level level so that they are
aware of what our request is and of
course the expectation is that she was
going to do what she needed to do
through the opp and the proper Channel
operationally on her side right and and
in terms of an operational plan did the
board ever see how those officers were
going to be used no okay
did the board ever request to see an
operational plan no and I think that
would be somewhat unusual for at least
for our board we wouldn't get into that
level of detail uh and there was none
was presented and none was asked for
okay
and are you aware whether those
resources requested were ultimately
provided
uh I I think it's fair to say more uh
than what was requested was actually
provided and so my understanding you
know at the sort of in the final
analysis is that uh we asked for a
hundred one may look at the fact that
the chief wrote one letter to the RCMP
and one letter to the opp and may say
well in fact you asked for 200 even if
you look at 200 as you know if you look
at it from that perspective and you say
we asked for 200 it's my understanding
that we had at least 500 officers attend
to deal with the situation and when you
say you were amplifying the request
politically what was the response that
you were getting from the federal
government and from the provincial
government
a desire and willingness to help there
were great lines of communication with
Sylvia Jones great lines of
communication with the Premier Minister
Mendicino was excellent and a great
phone call with the Prime Minister that
I had that you know he was very
understanding and of course living
through the situation here in the Ottawa
had a perspective on what we were
dealing with and and wanted to help so
all lines of communication were open and
and it was it was back and forth so it
was very good
and um
did the board take any specific actions
to support the WPS during this time
no that the board asked the chief what
do you need from us and her her comment
effectively was we we have everything we
need or it's being worked on at this
point there was no Direction required
from the board that wasn't already being
worked on so it was the board's
understanding on February 8th that the
only thing preventing the blockade from
being dismantled was the uh the influx
of resources there was a plan in place
and it was just they were just waiting
for the resources correct okay
um did the board adopt any policies uh
pursuant to section 31 of the police
services act with respect to either the
slow roll or the blockade no
did the board ever direct the police
chief uh in any way as contemplated in
the police services act no
and who was advising the board on on
these issues on legal issues and
interpretations of the ACT Etc
uh we didn't have legal counsel in these
meetings and so you'll see we had the
entire in this particular meeting we had
the entire board we had the chief deputy
chief Belair at the time uh was there we
had our Provincial Police liaison person
from the solicitor General's office uh
there as well Dave Tilley and so it it
it never got to a point where the board
felt like or asked a question that
couldn't be answered or was unsatisfied
in some way so the board felt satisfied
at the end of this meeting that they had
asked the appropriate questions of our
chief and were supporting her in every
way that she asked
now are you aware of whether the WPS had
any Communications with protesters or
blockade organizers
the chief did tell me that they
continued that police continued to to
talk to protesters again I go back to
you know opening one lane for a period
of time that that was through a
negotiation and every day the Chief told
me that they continue to talk they
continue to have discussion and dialogue
um
it just you know ultimately didn't
didn't change much did you have any
discussions with protesters or
organizers no
um
do you have a sense for whether the
protesters were local to Windsor whether
they were coming from the outside
whether they were coming from Ottawa do
you have a sense for who who these
people were you know I asked the
question uh because clearly police were
gathering Intelligence on license plates
and you know
scanning social media and doing the work
that they needed to do and I asked the
question on whether or not these were
you know the generally local folks or
were they folks coming you know from
elsewhere and there were a fair number
of local folks as I was told that were
part of the the demonstrating group but
I was also told by the chief that there
were a fair number of folks who weren't
even from Essex County that had come in
from elsewhere to participate in this
um now on February 9th you said to
reporters that arresting the
demonstrators opposed to pandemic Health
measures and towing their vehicles could
lead to violence and because you said
some of them were willing to die for it
do you recall saying that I do and how
did you reach that assessment that they
were willing to die for it well there
was a there was a TV report that was
also reported on the front page of The
Windsor Star uh where and it was very
early on in the protest that one of the
protesters had said outright that they
were this is a cause that they were
willing to die for uh and there was a
you know the reports to me was that
there was a very high temperature on the
ground amongst the protesters
uh they were very aggressive in their
language and in their posture and it was
that type of comment willing to die for
the cause that caused police to take a
more measured approach in in into the
way that they dealt with the situation
uh no one need to talk no one needed to
die on the streets of Windsor or
elsewhere protesting vaccine mandates or
whatever the protests ultimately was
about uh and so everyone took a pause no
one wanted to see a repeat you know that
was one thing the chief had told me that
there was a concern about what had
happened in Toronto at the G20 and so
you know members of the public in
Windsor were saying why don't you just
go in there and end this like it didn't
seem like
it wasn't something that it was an issue
that the police couldn't resolve quickly
uh to the average person
yeah and so
the public uh was feeling you know the
energy that they wanted to see something
happen and at the same time you know
police are saying this is not you know a
typical protest that you would see on a
Sunday afternoon on the on the on the
front lawn at City Hall
and so they were being very measured
they were being very cautious they did
not want to see a recreation of the
events that happened in Toronto and uh
and so they were taking a lot of
precaution
and do you have a sense for how many
vehicles or number of protesters were
involved it it seemed to ebb and flow uh
and so sometimes at night more would
come out as as I'm told the party
atmosphere sort of ramped up uh and it
could be 200 at one point uh you know
down to 75. that's right are you
referring to protesters or Vehicles
protesters sorry was that your question
yes okay protesters and vehicles yeah
and vehicles I I I'll leave it to
deputy chief Crowley to answer that I'm
not exactly sure how many vehicles
ultimately were there
okay
and so
um so then is it fair to say that bylaw
was not uh ticketing and towing they
were not enforcing because of the
reasons you mentioned in terms of
escalating yeah we we would never with
the temperature on the ground and the
statements folks were making we would
never send our bylaw officers in uh to
and for enforce Municipal bylaws in fact
you know there was a report to me that
we had a our parking enforcement is
outsourced to the Commissioners and a
commissioner did respond February 8th or
9th went in to issue some tickets and
and was swarmed and put in a situation
that was she felt was very dangerous uh
or that they felt was very dangerous and
actually had to be escorted to their car
by police and and leave you know and
folks were spitting on the car as the
commissioner left and so the the
temperature was too hot to think that
you were going to send Municipal bylaw
officers in there without police without
police accompany them and so at the end
of the day
thought was that negotiation would be
the the best way forward and again no
one need to die or get hurt and this
type of protest let's find a sensible
way through and get everyone to move on
so we can get the The Bridge open and
the economy moving again right and are
you aware of any other incidences of
threats or or violence with respect to
the blockade
aside from the one you just mentioned
uh well related to the blockade besides
the one at my house well maybe tell us
about that one well one of the one of
the folks involved threatened to I think
it was to bomb my house or to do
something like that and so you know we
woke up and all of a sudden there are
two or three police cars around our
house for several weeks because of the
the temperature on the ground and what
people were posting on social media and
the comments that were being made became
a very direct threat to me and my family
and so that in itself was concerning but
it was just it was it was the
the nature and sort of the spirit of the
protest it was unlike anything I've ever
seen and I've lived my whole life in the
city of Windsor it's unlike anything
I've ever seen during that time uh and
the the posture and the language was you
know it was it was almost as if
folks wanted some sort of Brawl on the
streets you know they were hoping police
would engage in that way so they could
have some sort of you know Brawl on the
streets if I can describe it that way
and I know police weren't interested in
that as the mayor I wasn't interested in
that as chair of the police board I
wasn't interested in that we were
interested in finding a way through this
that was sensible that was practical but
ultimately that that you know opened the
road leading to the Ambassador Bridge
because it is such a vital
economic piece of economic
infrastructure not just for Windsor
Essex County but for the entire Province
and and respectfully for the nation we
had to get that roadway open
and are you aware of any other
individuals who receive threats anyone
within city council anyone within
um in any other kind of prominent
position I know counselor Fabio costante
who represents the west side of the city
uh on both sides frankly of of Huron
Church Road and there was a comment made
that they would protest at his law
office he's a lawyer and he has a law
office in Sandwich town and so there was
a
comment made that they would be going
there to protest at the law office
did that materialize not that I'm aware
of okay
um
so I I want to go back to the
um request for resources if I can for a
minute uh can I take you to win401623
and these are the letters that Chief
Mizuno sent
I believe this one is to the minister of
emergency preparedness
there we go to minister Blair and that's
on February 9.
and I just want to go down
yeah here we go so it says Windsor
Police Service is requesting a minimum
of 100 police officers be dispatched to
the city of Windsor to bolster current
and potentially future requirements
and if we go down just want to see the
signature yep Pamela Mizuno chief of
police thank you
so that's the letter that she sent to
minister Blair yes and if we go to
win401648
foreign
so this is now also dated February 9
addressed to The Honorable Sylvia Jones
solicitor general and if we go down
I believe so this one is also requesting
100 police officers I believe it's the
same letter
um the letters were also asking the
second paragraph marked police vehicles
and tow trucks including heavy tows for
large transport vehicles and if we go
down
it's also from Chief Mizuno now you had
mentioned that your understanding was
that the requests were made to the RCMP
and the opp are you aware of other
letters that were sent uh to the com to
the commissioners of the opp and RCMP no
okay so these would be the the requests
the letters that were sent the those are
the letters that I'm aware of okay the
chief I know was having conversations
with her colleagues that I wasn't you
know that I wasn't party to uh but this
is this is what we were asked for to put
it in writing uh and that's what she did
and she sent it off from her office to
to minister Blair's office and to
minister Jones's office
February 9 that same day your Chief of
Staff scheduled a meeting between you
and the office of the solicitor general
do you recall that I know we had a
discussion on the 7th or the 8th and now
it looks like there's another one on the
ninth
um what was the purpose of that
discussion it was just an update
and so
you know I was just trying to keep
everyone updated
everything requested at that time or
offered in terms of assistance nothing
nothing more than 100 officers that we
had asked for okay and if we can go to
win
four zeros one five eight three
foreign
so this is now text messages between you
and Premier Doug Ford is that right
correct and so the dark uh is is you
speaking and then the light colored text
is uh Premier Ford is that right that's
correct okay
and uh it looks like he is asking you to
call him on February 9.
did you have a call with him on February
9. I did and what was the discussion on
that call uh obviously he was receiving
I shouldn't say Obviously but he was
receiving phone calls uh from businesses
as well who were concerned about the
blockade at The Ambassador Bridge I give
him sort of a situational briefing on
what we had going on down here and
you know that we had asked for 100
officers so it was a I think a fairly
quick phone call just a couple of
minutes and you know he was
stressing to me the importance of the
Ambassador Bridge and that we have to
find a way to get this open and I
certainly agreed with him and understood
that as well did he make any offers of
Assistance or anything of that nature no
I had told the premier that we asked for
100 officers and that that OPP already
had some resources on the ground PLT
liaison teams that were already here so
I told him that and told him about the
hundred officer request and then he
asked for Minister mendocino's phone
number which I texted to him and now
this is two days before
um The Province declared a provincial
state of emergency did that come up in
your discussions with him never no so he
didn't ask you whether you wanted that
or whether you needed that or anything
to that effect no okay
um what about the emergencies act the
federal emergencies Act was that ever
discussed with the premier never
the next day on February 10 you spoke to
the media and said that additional
resources were being deployed by the OPP
and that the premier and solicitor
general were responding rapidly to your
call for support was that accurate at
the time
uh I'm sorry can you can you ask it was
on February 10 you told reporters that
this request was being uh actioned very
quickly and that uh the opp was being
deployed and that the premier and
solicitor general were responding
rapidly to your request for resources I
I believe that to be true yes and do you
have a sense for when uh it says their
OPP resources started to arrive so by
the 10th you were receiving or the city
was receiving OPP resources
yes we had we had some resources cars
that you could see OPP cars along the
the Huron Church Road
um and the chief told me that there were
PLT units that were already here
negotiating uh and then she did tell me
that public order units were also
starting to arrive because my
understanding is that the Windsor Police
Service did not have at the time a PLT
unit or a PLU unit is that correct
that's correct so they were coming in
from other the opp was providing those
is that right yes OPP RCMP okay
do you have a sense for when our RCMP
officers arrived in Windsor I don't
exactly no
did the board have any role in swearing
our CMP officers in no do you know how
that was done or who did that I just was
aware that that was an issue uh and I'm
not sure the mechanics behind the scenes
on on you know how that was resolved
action an injunction that was sought and
granted with respect to the blockade
correct correct and um how did this idea
come about who who was the initiator of
this well I I was uh and on February the
9th you know in the in sort of the mid
to late afternoon I'd had a conversation
with our Commissioner of Legal Services
Shelby ask and Hager you know about the
prospect of an injunction
and
she wanted to think through it and make
sure she understood the best way to to
move forward with that idea uh and then
on the 10th in the morning we had to
move quickly if we were going to make
that happen and so I I said we need to
do this uh and and the reason for doing
this was there were multiple reasons
what people need to appreciate is that
not just the temperature on the ground
of the protesters but the temperature of
the general public to this protest was
amplifying as well and I could not as
mayor I could not as chair of the
Windsor Police Services Board direct
police operations and tell the chief or
the police Administration how to move
forward and when to move forward I had
no clear line of sight on how many
resources were coming here I knew there
you know I'm getting dribs and dribs and
drabs of of you know yes some folks are
on Route well are they on route from
Alberta are they on road from
Newfoundland are they coming from
Aurelia I have no sense of the timing
and so the public temperature to this
protest was also growing rapidly to the
point where you had Facebook groups
being set up where people wanted to go
out and undertake sort of vigilante type
Justice on the streets to remove these
protesters themselves
and it was
as it relates to you know the pandemic
that we'd all lived through in Windsor
we had lived through the same thing that
many others have lived through the stops
and the starts of businesses people not
getting paid for a period of time and
going through that that frustration and
friction as we've all dealt with at the
pandemic collectively and so just when
we were at a point where there seemed to
be uh you know light on the horizon this
was seen to be very how do I say it
assaultive to many people in Windsor
that this was a small group of people a
relatively small group of people who are
now going to jeopardize their employment
and so you had like I said Facebook
groups that were starting where people
were suggesting and and Union leadership
suggesting they were going to they were
prepared to help move the protesters
themselves uh and take action themselves
and so part of the reason for applying
for the injunction
was to send a signal to the public that
I'm doing everything that the city is
doing everything that city council is
doing everything we can
from our side of the table
to try and resolve this issue it was it
was really the only positive step I
could think of taking uh that would that
would be helpful in terms of a signal to
the public before I did this I did talk
to the Chief and said would this be
helpful to you and she said listen it
won't hurt
and so on the morning of the 10th very
early we activated legal teams to start
putting
the materials together trying to see if
we could get a scheduled appointment in
court to present the the application and
I worked with our Commissioner of legal
services and our city manager and all of
the right people on the city Side to to
see that move forward very quickly and
so you know the conversation really was
first thing in the morning seven or
eight o'clock in the morning and by two
o'clock we were we were appearing in
front of Justice morwitz uh to have this
have this discussion
right so I'll
um and I would just say yeah so good one
part was the public letting the public
know we're doing everything we can the
other thing was putting you know another
arrow in the quiver for police it was
another Tool uh that they could use with
respect to saying you are now in
violation if we were successful in
getting the injunction that you were in
violation of this injunction and it was
another arrow in their quiver
and um so city council adopted a
resolution that an injunction be sought
right correct and this was on February
10. that's right
um so you were able to call a meeting
that quickly to get everybody together
from the ninth when you kind of
conceived this uh to the 10th that's
right
um and it seems like the police was on
board with the injunction they thought
it would be it wouldn't hurt in any
event wouldn't hurt
um and so ultimately as you say the
injunction became effective at 7 pm on
February 11 is my understanding is that
right that's correct
and
um
why was the city an intervener in that
application and not the main applicant
do you know I I think through our
discussions uh before we proceeded we
talked about who was most impacted you
know and how could we tell the story
here about who was impacted and it was
clear in the first 60 Minutes of Huron
Church Road being blocked our phone rang
at the mayor's office from our largest
employer Chrysler now stalantis to say
what's going on at the Ambassador Bridge
you know there are 5 000 people directly
who work in that facility making
Chrysler pacificas and minivans uh that
rely on smooth and efficient border
crossings because the whole industry the
whole Auto industry works on a
just-in-time basis there's no parts
being stored on site they are brought in
and that bridge is moving and the
material is moving across that bridge uh
every hour of every day
and so it's it's you know for
perspective the the average part that
goes into a car that rolls off the
assembly line at the end of the the
manufacturing process that was those
parts across the border on average six
to seven times back and forth Detroit
back to Windsor you know as they
continue to be you know upgraded and
built and So within the first 60 Minutes
they called and said what's going on at
the Ambassador Bridge and so we knew
that the apma the automotive parts
manufacturers Association the cvma the
Canadian vehicle manufacturers
Association uh were impacted
dramatically by the activity at the
bridge and so they were certainly you
know good parties to put forward the the
request and then we were we took the
role we played the role that we played I
think appropriately
and so my understanding is the Attorney
General of Ontario was also an
intervener in that application that's
correct and how did they become involved
and what was the coordination uh with
them like I'm I'm not sure okay who took
the lead on the injunction from the
city's side uh Shelby asking Hager who's
our Commissioner of Legal Services okay
so she would have known she would have
had the the coordination with the
attorney general is that right she would
be the one in the best position to
answer your question okay fair enough
um so as we said on February 11 at 7 pm
the injunction uh came into effect it
was extended then on February 18. is
that right that's correct and what if
anything did it change on the ground
what impact did it have if any well I I
I think that once the injunction became
effective that it sent a signal to the
public that this has now from from the
public watching from the outside that we
have done all that we can do and again
it gave another tool to police to go in
and and they did when the police went in
and actually had to arrest people those
folks were were charged with violating
uh the terms of the injunction and so it
sent a signal but I think you know I
would like to think that from a a
protester's perspective it also meant
that the protesters had their day in
court had the opportunity to present
their position uh to Justice morowitz
chief justice morowitz and have a
conversation in court through the
established legal structures that we
have in place all parties had a chance
to do that and and chief justice more
what's ultimately made his decision that
was favorable uh to Grant the injunction
but everybody had an opportunity in fact
our application on February 10th was
delayed and heard on February 11 to
ensure that all parties including the
protesters were given notice so that
they could participate
police went out and plastered every
telephone pole the Jersey barriers with
copies of the order we had to set up a
website we promoted it on social media
certainly it was Amplified in every
major media source and on for every
social media channel that I saw if you
could just slow down for the
interpreters thank you
uh that
there were great efforts made to make
sure that all parties who had an
interest in this application had an
opportunity to have their day in court
and the city in fact assisted to
distribute these pamphlets once the
injunction was granted to give notice of
the injunction is that right correct
so would you say there was adequate
notice given about the injunction to
those in the in the blockade into in the
protest area absolutely
did it have the effect of
um
having people leave did anybody leave as
a result of the injunction or was it
simply that then they were charged with
violating the injunction once the arrest
took place
you know the reports I wasn't on the
ground but the reports that came back to
me is that uh many of the protesters
were looking at this as uh
you know
another another
court order another law another thing
that just you know was dispensable they
could violate it it was no big deal it
was just words on a paper
and so I'm not sure that it had on the
face of it I'm not sure that it had the
effect of having people say oh there's a
court order I'm going to leave now I
think it just you know
gave them the protesters another thing
to to Rally behind saying nothing's
going to make us leave
now was there any discussion with the
Windsor Police Service about whether
they had the resources at that time to
enforce the injunction and whether that
was a concern at all
well uh I think it's fair to say as we
got to that was a Friday uh the 11th
as we got to the Friday all the
communication from the chief to myself
was that we had major resources that
were here on the ground and the plans
were uh devised and being you know
sorted out with the help of the opp
commander and our own incident
commanders everyone was working through
how to
how to affect a resolution to this
blockade
so fair to say that the injunction and
the resources were coming at the same
time exactly
so uh there was also a board meeting a
special in-camera board meeting on
February 11th do you recall that yes so
that was the second uh board meeting
with respect to this blockade and I'm
going to take you to the minutes
w-i-n402173
foreign
if we go down
if we keep going down
okay and uh yeah keep it going down a
little bit
there's a part where you ask a question
I'm just trying to find that keep going
down
okay let's go back to the first page
oh there it is uh chair mayor dilkins is
there anything required from WPS from
the board Chief Mizuno no other
resources required at this time we
initiated OPP resources Wednesday
additional resources are flowing in RCMP
have come to town as well and are
helping so this lines up with what
you're telling me by the 11th of
February it sounds like
resources have been mobilized they're
starting to come in and there's no real
concern over resources anymore correct
and um
if we go down a little bit more
so Chief Mizuno there says
um
if and when we take action we will be
well positioned with resources to
support that state of emergency does
help and gives us additional Tools in
terms of future protests now this is on
February 11 I assume she's referring to
the provincial state of emergency that's
correct and do you have a sense for what
those tools were that the provincial
state of emergency could assist with I
don't recall
the entire list but I knew that there
were significant financial penalties and
the province through their emergency
action also sent a very strong signal
that if you continue to participate in
these protests that at these locations
or border crossings that you could lose
if you were a truck driver your
commercial vehicle operating license
uh and you could also lose your driving
license if you were you know just not a
truck driver
and so those are those are pretty
significant penalties that I think sent
a signal
to any reasonable or sensible person to
say we better think long and hard about
wanting to continue the protest at this
location because the the the you know
the the disincentive is huge right and
and um
do you have any sense for whether that
provincial state of emergency
um encouraged protesters to leave the
site
I think that that provincial emergency
you know when protest when the police
were ready to move
uh and they did the next day and
ultimately cleared up two days after
this meeting that you had compliance
when the Jersey barriers were were
moved when the police put their line in
place and they started you know moving
forward with their line and they got to
the point where their vehicles there the
vast majority of people ultimately left
um now I want to go back to to your
discussions with the minister of Public
Safety sorry Minister Mendicino at win
402295 and these are the text messages
that we had seen before
if you can go to page three
so you say I told Premier I spoke to you
and he asked for your number I get the
sense he is going to follow Alberta and
Saskatchewan what did you mean by that
I you know the premier I think
appropriately was
feeling
the temperature across the province was
seeing these protests probably in Ottawa
but certainly in Windsor as as
you know an outlet for some who wanted
some of the restrictions uh to be lifted
and you know Alberta and Saskatchewan
had moved to start lifting some of the
restrictions and my sense from the
premier is that he wanted to find a
pathway to get back to normal you know
as soon as it made sense as well
and did you have a sense that that was
because of the protests across Ontario
no not necessarily I think I think my my
sense from the conversation is that
again he was he had his finger on the
pulse of the people in Ontario and was
watching of course what was happening
across the country as well and was was
feeling you know some of the uh
frustration that we were all feeling
with respect to the lockdowns
recognizing that you know it was January
of 2022 where we were in a lockdown as
well provincial lockdown so the premier
sensibly was was echoing some of the
sentiments and looking at this as you
know a percentage of the population who
was protesting because they felt most
aggrieved by this
and if we go to page nine
go down
you say
I'm told our police support is going to
be good I think protesters are looking
to make show of things so in terms of
the police support going to be good was
that from your discussions with Chief
Mizuno yes
um well I should say Chief Mizuno and
deputy chief at the time Belair okay
thank you
um
and my understanding is you um
texted once the injunction was granted
you texted the minister as well as
Deputy Premier Jones and the premier to
let them know that the injunction had
been granted correct okay and if we go
to page 12 of this document
okay and he says do you think it will
end today and you're saying I'm thinking
it will so what was your sense on
February 12th of where things were at in
terms of resources and a plan to to move
forward to to clear the blockade that
that everything was in place that the
resources were in Windsor that the plan
had been devised and in fact on the 12th
the police started their operation they
put out the line with public order units
and all of the equipment behind them and
they started to to move forward on the
12th to deal with the situation on the
ground and in the text above you
mentioned the congregation from Harvest
Bible Church my understanding is they
had something to do with
um continuing the blockade at some point
on the 12th can you explain that
situation
so that the picture above my words I
think is a link or a screenshot from the
the pastor at the time I'm not sure if
he still is but
um
as the police started to move forward
and
you know make advances on on the 12th
there was a a call put out by the pastor
at this church to ask for folks to come
down and support the protesters and very
quickly which what might have been you
know 100 to 200 people turned into 600
people including parents with kids and
strollers uh like it was it was almost
unbelievable how fast that situation
grew in terms of the number of people
but seeing the police action I mean it
was it was disheartening to see the
police action and them making advances
and then to see parents bringing their
kids down to that situation and that's
exactly what happened uh which is
largely why it wasn't resolved that
particular day on Saturday it took until
Sunday for the situation to be resolved
I see so the police started moving in on
the 12th and weren't able to because now
the the number of protesters grew in
size well and I think
someone in the police structure probably
several people said this would be you
know the most sensible thing here is to
wait because at some point these kids
are going to get cold it's February
they're going to get cold they're going
to get tired they're going to get hungry
and they're gonna you know they're gonna
leave so we're not gonna move forward
with uh the policing posture they had in
place when you had a lot of young kids
there they were they were being very
wise in their approach and saying let's
let's do this at a different time when
it makes more sense
and if we go to page 12 of this
oh we are on page 12 okay keep going
down please
um keep going down
okay so you say it will end today
fingers crossed police have full control
of the area now and this is now on the
13th correct yes uh good Bridge reopen
today if so it will be later once Jersey
barriers Etc are removed there is still
some activity in the plaza at
I can't really read that to come see in
here to come see and hear on Church
police just got permission from owner to
trespass these people stay tuned okay
keep me posted headed into meetings with
the PM
and if we go to page 18
so this is now 3 40 p.m on the 13 and he
says about to head into meeting with PM
any critical updates
and you say small flare up a block from
here on Church a few arrests made
simultaneously working to get here on
Church open
25 to 30 male contents on scene keep
going down
update about 25 arrests now police
hoping to reopen Bridge tonight trying
to secure 1100 Jersey barriers
failing which one side of Huron church
will reopen and operate for two-way
traffic like a construction zone
and if we go down
and then it looks like then on the 13th
that's when
um the the bridge
reopened is my unders or the blockade
was cleared on the 13th right correct
and then on the following day
um
he asks how's it going this am on the
14th in the morning smooth so far and
then you say are you guys taking some
legislative action re-emergencies Act
and then he says we'll call you this
afternoon to the extent you can be
supportive of any additional authorities
that gets Windsor the resources you need
to keep the Bridge open people safe that
would be great so I want to ask you
about that exchange
um
what what gave you the sense that there
was some uh consideration of the
emergencies act being considered at that
time I had seen a report and I don't
know which media Source CTV or CBC had
had or Globe and Mail had made some uh
post that I saw that that
proposed that that may be in the works
and so I it just caused me to send him
the question and he said he would call
you about that and he didn't respond
over text but he said he would call you
and did you have a discussion I don't
know we did not oh you didn't okay
uh and then what did you understand him
to mean when he says to the extent you
can be supportive of any additional
authorities
well I I think you know I
we all know that that act has never been
used before and we all know that it's a
it's a serious act uh and requires this
type of thing to happen afterwards which
is extraordinary
uh and so if they were going to move
forward with that I think he's saying
you know if you could express the way I
took that is if you could express what
was happening on the ground that would
help justify this that would be helpful
to us and I think it's really really
important you know to to reflect on that
statement but also use that statement
based on what we were seeing on the
ground in Windsor and so there may have
been some great relief
there was great relief to a lot of
people in Windsor on the 13th once the
the the folks were moved all of a sudden
you know in lightning speed 1100 Jersey
barriers were replaced six kilometers of
Jersey barriers creating a direct
pipeline uh from the 401 to the
Ambassador Bridge
but the the piece that needs to be
explained here is the heightened state
of alert that was in place by police in
the community and the city with respect
to sort of some sort of recidivism that
may happen as a result of this blockade
being moved and it's the type of
behavior that's happened throughout the
pandemic where you have members of the
public and Windsor saying you know
there's a protest we're all supposed to
be masked and meters apart from one
another and there's a protest and 100
people down you know by our Great
Canadian flag at the waterfront why
aren't police doing anything why is that
behavior being allowed to continue and
it's hard to explain to people that if
you move 100 people out and take action
against these hundred sort of law
Breakers or rule Breakers that you could
have
three thousand the next weekend you know
you become the rallying cry for this and
so that was the thought in place here
from a police perspective conversations
that we certainly had amongst many of
the senior staff and myself at the city
is you know this action needs to be
resolved this action needs to be taken
to resolve the situation on the ground
uh but what happens after they're gone
and so the number of police that were
sent to the city of Windsor to move the
protesters out was one thing but a
significant number of police resources
remained in order to make sure that this
didn't flare up again uh and so from an
emergency act perspective you know
anything that would send a signal to
people contemplating coming to Windsor
to to start this over again I thought
from my chair was extremely helpful to
send a signal you had the city declared
an emergency The Province declared an
emergency and then the federal
government declared an emergency and I
think that sent
ought to have sent a signal to a lot of
people that this is a serious matter and
will not be allowed to happen again
now on that point the city of Windsor
actually declared a municipal state of
emergency after the province did is that
right correct and um and it was on I
believe on the 14th is that right that's
correct so uh maybe just explain uh why
the municipal state of emergency was
called after the blockade had already
been cleared and not not prior to that
yes thank you for asking that question
so uh what happened is we had had a
council meeting prior to me signing off
on the Declaration of Emergency on the
14th one of the concerns that Council
had generally was there was a a portion
of the resolution in front of council
that provided a wide latitude to the
city manager to do a number of things
that Council didn't feel comfortable
giving sort of carte blanche to the city
manager at that particular time and
we're talking about acquiring resources
moving Transit routes like the city
operational type stuff uh that I said
well don't worry if you have a concern
with that let's not get held up with
that I'll declare the emergency which
then would wrap that Authority up in me
to me
and anything that's required with
respect to dealing with
this this uh direct pipeline that's been
created I'll have the ability to deal
with uh and so we I signed it on the
14th and I I
you know ended it 10 days later
right so that allowed us just and I
don't even think there was much that
came out of that in terms of you know
needing to be dealt with operationally
everyone just sort of figured it out and
and we did what we had to do I think we
I think I may have given free transit to
people who started on the west side of
Huron Church to be able to get to the
the other side because the the
disruption was big there were a few
things like that but nothing material I
would say uh was was used was done by me
with respect to that emergency power
right and as you had mentioned the
injunction was really a signal to the
public that the city was doing
everything it could why couldn't uh the
state of emergency also be a signal even
if measures wouldn't necessarily be used
or there wasn't much additional powers
that could be gained from it wouldn't it
be a signal to the public that the city
was doing everything it could
uh do you mean why didn't I sign the
Declaration of emergency prior to the
14th yes well I you know I I felt like
there that wasn't
going to provide anything new that I
needed at the time so we didn't have
like police were telling me what they
needed I was trying to amplify their
requests from a city perspective with
respect to Public Works and Jersey
barriers and all the things that we had
to mobilize no one came to me saying we
can't do this or they're charging us 10
times the amount nothing nothing would
have benefited I can't see the situation
becoming better because I signed it at
that particular time
what happened on the 14th though when
everyone woke up and they saw this this
tunnel from the 401 to the Ambassador
Bridge in both directions if you live in
Windsor you know that that was like a
major major thing all cross traffic was
blocked uh bus routes were rerouted
there were going to be impacts on
business many businesses over 200
businesses that were you know impacted
as a result of that particular action
and again that wasn't something that was
my decision I was a police decision to
put these Jersey barriers in place and
create a safe pipeline to and from the
bridge and so I anticipated that there
would be some requirement to deal very
very quickly on the municipal side with
the stuff that we deal with
operationally that that tool would have
given me the benefit of acting quickly
and so that's why I did it on the 14th
as opposed to doing it earlier because I
didn't see the need to do it earlier and
so the purpose then was to
um
uh to get some sort of financial
compensation for the businesses that
were that were prevented from getting
um business because of the the Jersey
barriers that were blocking East-West
traffic I just knew not necessarily I
knew that that what had been done
was a was going to have some form of
material impact on a variety of
different operations and businesses a
material impact on the way people live
their lives on either side of Huron
Church Road and what I wanted it wasn't
so much at that time sending a signal to
the public it was just saying okay
Council if you feel uncomfortable giving
the city manager that Authority I'll
take that Authority Under the
emergencies act and be able to deal with
anything very very quickly and again in
10 days once there once the situation
stabilized and normalized I I signed off
and said there's no longer a municipal
emergency and how long were those Jersey
barriers in place along here on Church
Road weeks
several weeks I can't remember the exact
date when they were finally removed
there was a an incremental for for a
couple of weeks they were there and it
was it was a direct Pipeline and you had
hundreds of police on duty making sure
that if trucks stopped uh that they were
acting very quickly to have folks move
on
um but incrementally and over time you
saw
certain Jersey barriers removed at
certain intersections so people could
cross here on Church Road and then
police maintained a uh you know I would
say a height and state of Readiness at
those locations just in case there was a
flare-up
and um
what was your understanding of the
potential of another blockade taking
hold after the original one was cleared
this this is the important Point again
that there was the thought and the chief
expresses to me and deputy chief Belair
at the time expressed to me that they
were quite concerned that something
would happen you know that there would
be
Behavior where folks would come back and
they didn't know when they didn't know
how many
and there were resources police
resources deployed along the 401 outside
of the city of Windsor to sort of
monitor this type of activity there were
resources
allocated to scan social media and some
of the the likely sites to sort of
gather intelligence on that front as
well but the thought was that they were
coming back and there were some attempts
there were some attempts that police
intercepted as I'm as I'm aware of
um
and my understanding is that there was
also the concern that once Ottawa was
cleared that those protesters would come
to Windsor correct and what can you tell
us about that
again just monitoring what was happening
up in Ottawa knowing that there was a
high level of frustration amongst that
that protester group
that you know if they were looking to
continue that type of protesting
activity
it's it's it's one thing to do it in
Ottawa at the seat of the federal
government it's another thing to do it
at the busiest border crossing between
our two countries that has a significant
impact on the lives of tens of thousands
of Canadians not just people in my
community
people all across this province that
rely on smooth and efficient border
crossings for their livelihoods who've
been impacted you know over a couple
years with the pandemic and so
you know there was I think we all knew
that if you wanted to have the biggest
impact
uh the biggest impact economically would
be in Windsor leading up to the
Ambassador Bridge
and if I can take you to win 50972
okay
feet
now this is um
February 16 so a few days after the
blockade has been cleared
and this is a a briefing I believe uh
this these were some remarks that you
gave is that correct that's correct
and
if you go down
going
so they're the bolded section there you
say let me be clear this remains a
national security situation that
prevents us from Simply reopening Huron
Church Road to regular traffic at this
time what did you mean by National
Security situation well I I I I I would
add even National you know Economic
Security situation you know the amount
of trade that crosses at The Ambassador
Bridge is material it's material for our
Province material for our nation and so
every day that that bridge is is closed
it has a huge impact on the lives of
tens of thousands of Canadians who rely
on
smooth and efficient border crossings
for their livelihoods and so National
Security situation we we had the
deployment of three kilometers of Jersey
barriers in each Direction
I didn't make that decision that was a
police decision using the intelligence
that they had
and all the tools and information they
had at their disposal in order to find a
way the best way forward to get access
to the Ambassador Bridge from the 401 so
that this bridge was open that the
economy was moving once again and that
they could maintain control of what I
would argue is a piece of infrastructure
that is in our National Economic
interest it is it is a very material
critical piece of national
infrastructure that just doesn't happen
to be that happens to be owned by a
private interest
um did you have any discussions with
Minister Mendocino or anybody else at
the federal government about the risk of
um another another blockade after uh the
the one on the 14th was cleared
uh I probably did you know there were
check-ins Minister Mendocino was very
good at checking in saying how are
things going today he did that many days
in a row uh and to the extent I had
information from police where there was
something worth reporting I sent that
back to him so that he had situational
awareness of of what we were dealing
with on the ground
uh Minister Mendocino is someone who
went he lived in Windsor he went to law
school at the University of Windsor so
he also knows the area uh and once you
have a perspective of What It's Like on
the ground it's easier to have a
conversation he knows the impact of of
what happened on Huron Church Road
without me even having to to discuss it
with him he just intuitively knows that
because he's from he had experience in
the area
and so yeah we went back and forth and
he was very good at checking in just
asking for an update and trying to
gather information for for his uh for
his perspective so in terms of
continuing threats uh to to the
Ambassador Bridge you're getting that
information from the chief of police or
the Deputy Chief of Police you're not
getting any information uh from any
federal entities giving you kind of
intelligence or information that's
correct okay
um and to your knowledge were any of the
Federal Emergency powers ever used to
prevent further blockades
I'm not aware
um
now on March 17 uh you wrote to
ministers Mendocino and Blair and to the
solicitor general
explaining some issues that you believed
had been brought to light by these
blockades do you recall that
was just the letter asking to have a uh
you know a sit down and try and figure
out the path forward yes yes and so what
were some of those concerns that that
you had at the time well it this is a
the Ambassador Bridge in the city of
Windsor is a unique circumstance so you
have as I said the Ambassador Bridge the
busiest commercial border crossing
between the United States and Canada
which is privately owned uh that sits at
one end of a municipal roadway and three
kilometers on the other end is a
provincial Highway
and so you know the 401 is a is a is a
roadway where there are no traffic
lights it's
sort of barrier-free but as soon as you
get off onto Huron Church Road you're on
that Municipal Road which falls under
the responsibility and authority of the
city of Windsor and the Windsor Police
Service you have six or seven traffic
lights so track says they make their way
from the 401 to the Ambassador Bridge
have to go through those series of
Municipal traffic lights and it is a
unique situation that you have
you know provincial Highway at one end a
municipal roadway linking what I would
suggest is sort of important Federal
infrastructure and so my request to them
to the other levels of government was we
need to sit down and figure this out
we need to figure out in the event that
something like this were to happen again
how do we respond and you know sort of
pull the template off the shelf that the
response is seamless that it's not
um you know a day or two here trying to
figure out how many folks we need
and who's going to do what and who
should take the lead and then ultimately
who's paying for it you know so the city
of Windsor is has carried all of the
water we're paying all of the bills 5.3
million dollars for the for the
execution of this this particular police
action which was absolutely necessary
but I would submit is completely unfair
that the city of Windsor is is
shouldering those costs it was not a
typical Municipal policing matter in
fact it was a National Economic
emergency
uh and we responded appropriately The
Windsor Police did a great job the opp
did a great job the RCMP they all worked
very well together but we need to figure
this out moving forward because the
Ambassador Bridge is not going away our
Municipal Road's not going away and the
401 is not going away so what does this
look like in the future and that was my
my request to them is to sit down and
try and figure out how we do this
together in the future to eliminate any
uh sort of delays that might be inherent
in the way we we moved
in February and have you had a new
response back no
um
so can you give us a sense for the
impact of the blockade uh specifically
on the auto sector uh in Windsor well it
was you know almost immediate again
within the first hour our largest
employer called saying what's going on
uh the very next day on February the 8th
they suspended some of their
manufacturing operations and and it was
intermittent during the week of the
blockade we also had Parts suppliers
that basically stopped producing Parts
because they had nowhere to send them
and they don't stockpile large quantity
of parts and you know there was a there
was a huge huge impact in the auto
sector but don't forget even on in Essex
County you know city of Windsor is is
plus or minus 230 000 people if we take
the neighboring County and we're part of
that County just not part of their
government it's about 450 000 people
total in that area we have the largest
Greenhouse operation in North America
second in the world next to Holland and
so a full 80 of all greenhouses in
Canada are in Essex County and so the
produce that is that is produced in
those facilities that operate 24 7 365
the vast majority of it is exported to
the United States through the Ambassador
Bridge
and so the regional impact which we
cannot discount was material it was
Major uh and you know having folks idled
having plants idled is not good just for
our economy it also had an impact on the
U.S side because of the integration of
our supply chains and so that's why we
had folks from the United States you
know senior leaders in the United States
calling for an end to this as well and
trying to push for a resolution because
it was impacting their economy too and
what discussions did you have then with
counterparts or others in the U.S
I you know I spoke with Folks at
Homeland Security but more from a a an
operational perspective at the bridge so
the port director at the bridge uh and I
spoke with the mayor of Detroit you know
once during the blockade uh just to sort
of you know touch base because I was
getting a lot of media questions about
whether I'd spoken to the mayor of
Detroit and and I knew there really
wasn't a whole lot that he could do but
I wanted to touch base with him so
um you know we were trying to resolve
this situation there wasn't a lot that
that I think could be provided from the
U.S at one point we we did have an
overture from the governor of Michigan's
office uh to provide tow trucks I think
she made a comment to the media and then
folks brought that to our attention uh
and when we reached out and had a
conversation with her Chief of Staff it
really wasn't that the state of Michigan
had tow trucks they just offered to
facilitate an introduction to tow truck
companies that may be able to provide
the support
I see any other discussions with um with
with U.S folks no
okay
um so I want to take you to win401628
and these are remarks that you gave uh
now we're going back in time on February
9.
um but you said at the bottom of sorry
the top of page two
foreign
if Canada becomes known as a difficult
jurisdiction to do business with to move
Goods in and out for example then Supply
chains will evolve and reconfigure to
remove this element of risk and avoid
Windsor Essex
um what were you basing that information
on
well
I think everyone is aware now so I can
contextualize this a little differently
than I could at the time
uh everyone is aware now that the city
of Windsor was successful in landing a
five billion dollar investment uh from
LG a joint venture from LG and
stellantis and so they're building the
first Canadian electric vehicle battery
manufacturing facility in the city of
Windsor all of that discussion all of
that work uh and the pre-planning was
well underway during uh the the protest
in February it just hadn't been
announced publicly and so in fact the
the
CEO of stalantis global
went to Canada during this time to have
a meeting with senior officials
and so this was me sending a signal to
the extent that any of those folks were
watching that we understand that this
has to end that we understand that you
have a choice in terms of where you
locate these facilities and that we're
doing all we can to try and move folks
on
and that sort of plays into the whole
injunction piece as well that it it it's
the public-facing part of it that was
important as was it important to make
sure police had another tool that they
could use but I wanted to make sure that
with respect to the folks you know early
on here we're in the very early part of
sort of rolling out all of the pieces
back in February for this major major
investment I wanted to make sure that
they knew very clearly that we were very
taking this situation very seriously and
applying all resources that we could
from Municipal perspective to get this
situation resolved reflecting on the
fact that you know did I think that the
first Ford factory in in Canada 1904 I
didn't think a hundred year 120 year
relationship was going to be eviscerated
because of a seven-day event but at this
particular time it was critical that I
sent that signal and had them have me
acknowledge that this is an important
issue that needs to be resolved because
it it they were asking right and so were
you concerned to some extent that the
the image or the um the viability of
Windsor as a city to invest in might
might be compromised by this 100 because
this investment that I'm talking about
uh we are we are fortunate we worked
very hard to get this investment uh but
there were options up the 401 in in
Ontario and there were lots of options
across the border in the state of
Michigan Ohio Indiana and Kentucky and
so I was determined on behalf of the
city to make sure that that landed here
and we were at a very fragile Point uh
in in the process that this could have
been derailed this you know if they had
looked at this and taken a perspective
that we don't want this hassle it's just
easier to do business in the United
States this is the type of event that
could have derailed this major
investment for for Canada for Ontario
and certainly for the city of Windsor
um and in terms of impacts on residents
what impacts did the blockade have on on
the cities on city services social
services medical services Transportation
what can you give us a sense well major
and so I let me mention several uh when
this all started EMS had to move an
ambulance to the other side of Huron
Church they had to make sure that they
could cover that part of the city our
fire chief moved and deployed fire
resources there's a fire station
literally 100 meters from where the
protesters were protesting but it's on
the east side of Huron Church they moved
a truck to the West Side to make sure
that they could provide that they could
get there and provide service to the
west side of the city the transit routes
were disrupted the the natural flow of
people back and forth and having here on
Church Road closed was significant
because there are no grocery stores on
one side on the west side of Huron
Church they're all on the east side and
a lot of folks have to take the bus they
they don't have their own car on the
other side of the west side of Huron
church and so they require the city
system to be able to move around
and live their daily lives the
University of Windsor the University of
Windsor is directly adjacent to Huron
Church directly adjacent to the
Ambassador Bridge the primary road that
people in the city of Windsor would use
to get to the University of Windsor is
Huron Church Road
so 17 500 students that attend the
University of Windsor you have a high
school that was actually in the protest
Zone Assumption High School it's been
there for probably a hundred years and
so that that school was directly
impacted by the the protest activity
and I mean just those are just those are
several but the impact was was material
during the protest and then even after
the protest because of the deployment of
the Jersey barriers along here on Church
Road had a direct impact to the hotels
the motels the businesses the small
businesses large businesses grocery
stores you name it they were impacted
including the high school including the
University of Windsor because everyone
had to find another way around
um and you had mentioned that the cost
of the city was over five million
dollars correct correct and most of that
I understand was for the Windsor Police
Service is that right it really is a mix
and we certainly have welcomed any audit
of those expenses some police services
sent us a bill uh some police services
didn't but we had to pay for the Jersey
barriers we had to pay for overtime
there was a whole list of expenses that
made up the 5.3 million dollars that you
know we are we are carrying that cost at
this particular time right because in
addition to OPP and RCMP there were
several local police forces that came to
assist correct correct and so public
order units I know some were deployed
from other parts of Ontario but we
contracted directly with the city of
London uh they have trained resources
they have a standard contract that they
sent to us I signed immediately but that
the provision of that service was two
hundred thousand dollars plus or minus
uh we had to feed people
you know but the chief asked for 100
officers I'm told that 500 showed up
well they may not have charged us some
of the services may not have charged us
for uh for the the salary and benefit
costs but we still had to
put some of those Folks up in hotels we
still had to feed them we had to move
them around there were direct costs
which we would welcome any other level
of government to audit but at the end of
the day it's the residents in the city
of Windsor who have who have carried the
full share of those costs today
and just to be clear the the blockade on
was cleared and the bridge reopened
before the emergencies Act was invoked
is that right uh
on the 14th so the 13th around midnight
into the 14th I think the Bridge opened
around midnight on the 14th so the
emergencies act came was invoked
sometime on the 14th so yes the answer
to your question is yes okay great so
none of the measures in the emergencies
act were used to clear the blockade
since it came after correct correct okay
thank you those are my questions for you
thanks okay so uh I think this is
probably a good time for the morning
break so we'll take 15 minutes and then
come back to continue
okay the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
foreign
thank you
foreign
thank you
order a lot
foreign
[Music]
ready to go yes sir okay so now if I
could call on the Democracy fund to go
first
foreign
Mr commissioner good morning mayor my
name is Antoine Dai I'm full of citizens
for Freedom group representing the
peaceful protesters in Windsor Ontario
first of all mayor congratulations on
your recent re-election
um I understand we heard earlier that
you've been the mayor and the chair of
the Police Services Board since 2014 but
you also served prior to that in the
capacity as a city councilor is that
correct correct and when did that start
uh December 2006.
and so since your tenure of December
2006 would you agree that you have got
some significant influence and
connections within the city of Windsor
and in our central point of contact for
organizations such as the University of
Windsor the the businesses in the area
and that you wield quite a bit of
political influence uh I I would say
that as mayor certainly you're in touch
with a lot of different people in the
community businesses residents and and
institutions as well
and so in just in terms of the division
of the powers because I understand you
do wear several hats one being again the
chair of the Police Services Board
um
in Your Capacity as chair you said that
it is not
the board's responsibility to direct the
activities of the police is that correct
correct we don't direct police
operations
would you say that you you influence
what tactics and methods they may use
no
and when it comes to requests for
resources is that usually something that
comes from the police to and that
request is made to the Police Services
Board or or is the Police Services Board
itself making requests for resources and
things like that from the city we go
through an annual budgeting exercise so
the chief presents a budget to the board
we go back and forth until we land on
something that ultimately gets approved
by the board which is then sent to city
council I will sorry I'll speak slower a
budget approved by the Windsor Police
Services Board is then sent to Windsor
city council for approval uh and the
chief would lay out in the budget
document what is needed for each
department if something extraordinary
happens if there's a an expenditure or a
request outside of the normal budgeting
process the chief would then make a
request to the Windsor Police Services
Board and the board would make whatever
decision they felt appropriate
understood and in your capacity is Mayor
as well I presume that you also had
regular communication over the last
couple years leading up to the pandemic
to the protests with the Windsor Essex
County health unit and the chief medical
office of health of the region is that
correct
I
frequent yes not daily but there have
been more there has been more contact
during the pandemic between my office
and the health unit than any other time
that I can recall
and would you say that over the last two
years that there was in that increased
communication is that typically the city
seeking guidance from The Windsor Essex
County Health Unit or is it that you
know these decisions are being made
together in a collaborative fashion
what's that relationship between you and
the chief medical officer of health of
the area uh they have very distinct uh
roles as spelled out in legislation and
so there are often times because none of
us have ever lived through a pandemic uh
before or at least most of us haven't
there are times where during the
pandemic we've tried to sort out a
course of action with the health unit to
have a better understanding of where the
medical officer of Health May land on a
certain topic But ultimately my
experience with the medical officer of
health is they may give you an
impression or some guidance or some you
know opinion but ultimately they left it
to the city to make every decision so
would it be fair then to say that
typically the recommendations because we
saw a number of section 22 orders issued
by the health unit that were the subject
to some of the protests that led up to
the demonstration at the bridge would it
be fair to say that the the
recommendations of the medical officers
is is the medical advice and that the
actions of the city council in terms of
the bylaws and the orders that are being
passed are more of the the political
aspect of that
uh well the medical officer of Health
independently makes any orders that that
he makes it's it's not dependent on us
in any way uh and then of course city
council passes bylaws resolution and
policy which is our normal governance
role I understood and just in terms of
that community control group so am I
correct that this community is a
community controller corporate control
group community control and the
community control group they met during
the week of February 11th on a daily
basis 9 30 every morning is that correct
I don't know if it was every day but we
met very frequently and and did you
attend all of those meetings personally
whether remotely or in person or or did
you rely on others to communicate and
relay to you the information that that
was discussed during those meetings I'd
have to look at the the minutes
themselves for each day I attended
several but there may have been a time
where I didn't attend and if I did
intend attend my chief of staff Andrew
telazewski would have attended and so I
presume then that the days that you did
not attend those those briefings about
the bridge you had other priorities to
attend to at the time
correct
and
I guess you you you had an understanding
that you know whether it's your Chief of
Staff or the police services or whoever
else attending those meetings was in
control of that situation and and that
your immediate attention on that was not
required is that correct well the the
ccg does a good job at providing one
source of information to multiple people
so we're on the same page but it's not
exclusive and so I may have had on any
given day not may have probably more
than five conversations every day with
the chief of police about the activity
that was happening in Windsor related to
the freedom Convoy and so
it didn't mean if I didn't wasn't in
that particular meeting that there was
an absence of information because there
was great communication throughout the
city great communication
intergovernmentally at the time and for
the duration of the of the uh the
protest okay and and when you speak of
the
the duration of the protests is it fair
to say that as mayor of Windsor part of
your role and responsibility is not only
to represent the majority of of citizens
that elect you but also the minority
opinion
I I represented the city of Windsor and
so certainly I absolutely represent the
people in the city of Windsor and so
would it be fair to say that part of
your role and responsibility then is to
attend to those minority uh those
minority opinions and views or at least
to take them under consideration
particularly when there's active
protests in the city
of course you would you would consider
what's being said on social media you
would try to understand the perspective
and and as we did here trying to find a
resolution
trying to get get this thing over with
so we could open the the route to the
border crossing right and and I
understand that you testified earlier
that you at no point in time actually
went down and spoke with the protesters
at The Ambassador Bridge protest is that
correct correct
um
in in terms of the leadership were you
aware that many of those attendees had
also been protesting on almost a weekly
basis since 2020 down at the Great
Canadian flag no
you were not
as mayor are you typically informed by
somebody within the the city's apparatus
of the protests that are happening
uh only if it was exceptional so for
example if there was a protest on the
lawn of City Hall today between four and
five uh I may never be given notice of
that I may walk out and see the protest
but it's not normal that for sort of a
general protest which probably happens
every week in some form uh that that the
mayor's office would get notice of that
okay so you say that you didn't receive
notice of you know the anywhere between
25 to 50 people that gathered almost on
a regular basis every weekend down at
the flag you say you you were not aware
of those oh oh I was notified of
frequent protests at the flag but I
think your question was was I aware that
people who were at the protest at the
flag were also part of the protests of
the freedom Convoy I can't create that
connection okay and and in the
information that you received about
those weekly protests leading up to the
Ambassador Bridge
were you able to identify any of the
organizers or the leaders of those
protests
yes
and did you at any point communicate the
names or identities of those leaders to
the Windsor Police Service or anybody
else within the city I I didn't have to
because the the police were attending
those functions independently
and so you saw the interaction with the
protesters or at least the leaders of
those protests is more of a policing
matter than a than a political matter
well the the and I don't know if it was
weekly I don't think it was weekly
protests at the flag but
you know going back to when they started
the protests at the flag with respect to
covid restrictions uh there were points
where the the the Gatherings were
illegal
they were contrary to provincial
legislation at a minimum uh and so
police were there because you again had
illegal activity but you also had
members of the public who were saying
why aren't you guys doing anything about
that why are you letting this illegal
activity happen when we have to follow
the rules We are following the rules and
clearly this behavior is not following
the rules it's illegal why are you not
taking action right would you agree with
me that over the course of the two years
those protests were building there were
many changes to the legislation and
there was different times where perhaps
the number of people allowed at one of
those protests was within the bounds of
Law and other times uh you know that
there could be further restrictions in
terms of the number of people that could
gather
um and that that was a fluid situation
and that not all of those protests were
legal I I don't know because I wasn't
receiving a debrief after every time
folks gathered at the flag to protest
covet restriction so I I can't help you
with an answer there because I just
don't know okay
is it fair to say that in the protests
leading up to the Ambassador Bridge
there were multiple occasions where
there were there was a far bigger
turnout of protesters and demonstrators
that ever appeared at the bridge
um I'm aware of uh I forget the Fella's
name but he he had some notoriety online
and came to Windsor a couple of times
and that seemed to generate more
activity at the flag when he came
uh Chris somebody or anything but I
can't remember his full name but anyway
this this person when he came to Windsor
and there was at least two occasions
that I'm aware of more people seemed to
gather on those two occasions over two
years
and did I hear you correctly earlier
that
your understanding of the composition of
the protesters is that many of those at
the bridge were locals
and it was not all from Out of Towners
and and to the extent there were people
from out of town a lot of them were
coming from Toronto and other places in
Southwestern Ontario rather than Ottawa
yeah so my my understanding was a it was
about 50 50 from the chief okay
so then as your role as part of the ccg
would you say that part of your
responsibility was communicating with
the other branches of government whether
it was I think we saw some text messages
earlier with Minister Mendocino uh with
the solicitor general in the province so
one of your key responsibilities was
being that spoke on the Wheel to these
other government agencies is that
correct and our local members as well
members of provincial Parliament and
Parliament and so can you just explain
who who is Brian Massey he's the the NDP
Member of Parliament for Windsor West
which is the area where Huron Church
Road and the Ambassador Bridge was
located and did you have much
correspondence or Communications with
him during the the Ambassador well
during the time leading up to the
investor uh protest uh leading up I mean
I'm in frequent contact with him uh
about that particular issue I don't
recall any conversations specifically
about the protests that were going on
um but when it happened I did have
communication with him once it it set
hold in Windsor okay
um can we just pull up a document here
when four zeros one six five nine
so Samara we heard earlier that you said
you know the the traffic at The
Ambassador Bridge is a particular
economic importance that every hour of
every day there's goods and services
Crossing that border and that in in your
opinion
um a significant Interruption to those
products and services flowing across the
border
is is of economic importance did I did I
hear you correctly on that correct
and
I believe Mr Massey if we can scroll
down here on this letter appears to be
date of February 9th
to many of the other Federal ministers
if we scroll down
and if we look at the top of the second
paragraph there it says that traffic
disruptions along the road Corridor to
the Ambassador Bridge are not uncommon
dude do you have any idea of what Mr
Massey's referring to here
uh I I don't I mean I unless he's
talking about just sort of General
construction that happens on Huron
Church Road which is you know a
requirement on any road uh I'm not aware
of any major disruptions okay
so I understand that in your capacities
mayor you may not hear about every
protest that's going on in Windsor but
do you recall a protest in March 20th of
2019 I think this was during your tenure
where a gentleman named Eddie Haddad is
that name familiar to you yes and and
who is Eddie Eddie is a windsor resident
recently ran for city council and has
run several times in the past and
do you share my understanding that he's
also currently the chair of the Liberal
Party of Canada in the Southwest
Division
I I don't know if he holds that position
and did you ever receive any indication
that he was also the chair of the Essex
Federal liberal writing Association I
have no idea if he is or not do you
recall hearing a statement from him on
March 20th of 2019 in relation to a
protest dealing with funding for the
University that apparently led to a
temporary blockage of the Ambassador
Bridge in Windsor and Mr Haddad's quote
saying that we're going to continue to
shut down the bridge at every protest we
do until they reverse the cuts
do you recall that no
so in addition to construction do you
recall any other interruptions to the
flow of goods and services across the
border at The Ambassador Bridge
over what period of time uh well let's
say most recently is it true that on
October 3rd of 2022 both the Ambassador
Bridge and the Windsor Tunnel were shut
down for the for a marathon
yep that happens every year it happens
every year and is it your understanding
that as part of that planning both the
bridge and the tunnel were completely
shut down to to Commercial and
pedestrian traffic for a period of time
correct
it's the free Detroit Free Press
Marathon that happens every year so it's
very well defined very well prescribed
and and the entire community on both
sides of the Border knows it's going to
happen right and we're also aware of
a cbsa strike and protest in support of
that over some wages or the fact that
they had been working without a contract
that clo that caused a major slowdowns
and disruptions at the bridge
in August of 2021 as I understand it I I
wasn't aware of any major disruptions at
the bridge but
so would it be fair to say then that
that this particular protest that
happened in February of 2022 was not the
first protest that impacted
the free flow of goods across the border
at the bridge
well I I would say it was the most
unique and caused a complete shutdown of
traffic to the Ambassador Bridge the
others that you're trying to compare to
are are very distinct and different and
and different but also insignificant to
the point that you you don't recall that
as a major event is that correct exactly
okay
foreign
that for example the Detroit Marathon
that happens every year it's well
planned it's well thought out so all
parties kind of have noticed that this
is happening
um which would you agree with me that
the the primary concern perhaps from the
city's perspective as to this particular
protest in February of 2022 was the
uncertainty in terms of how long it
might last and you know whether or not
the city or the province or even the
federal government had the resources to
to handle that type of demonstration
yeah we we didn't know whether the Slow
Roll was ever going to become permanent
that wasn't we weren't certain on that
uh and how long was it going to last it
was a complete closure the other ones
were very time limited for very discreet
events uh and this was something that
you know there was no known end date
and and when you say it was a complete
closure
are you aware of of briefings through
that ccg group where various times there
was certainly at least one lane open or
two-lane open to allow traffic and at
least emergency vehicle access well
again I think I mentioned that this
morning that that there were times when
the chief told me that they've regained
control of one lane and they thought
they were talking to someone who had
Authority as a group leader to make sure
that they could have emergency access
through one lane but then that quickly
did not last because one person one
party was never empowered to speak for
the other parties and they decided to to
sort of block that lane and that was
part of the problem here that this was
in many ways a leaderless movement where
you know there was no one specific to
talk to and no one responsible for the
outcome of the entire group I understand
and and you spoke earlier too about
um you know constructions and other
delays and and the importance of the
just-in-time delivery system for many of
the auto parts manufacturers locally
would you agree with me that
a Slowdown or a significant slowdown
whether to construction or otherwise
would also have an impact albeit not not
as severe but it certainly has an
economic impact on the auto parts
manufacturers not necessarily and so as
long as one lane is open in each
Direction and vehicles can move uh that
that works I mean we could we could work
with that over a short period of time to
continue Commerce back and forth and let
health care workers get to work that can
continue as long as one lane was open
and that is what police were trying to
do from the very beginning was find a
way to keep one lane open allowing the
protests to continue the Slow Roll
protests to continue but allowing one
lane in each direction to be open so
Commerce could continue right and so the
traffic disruptions but the Border still
open when we pull up poe.cff
we'll do the seven zeros one
we just scroll down here just notice the
date that it's May 13 2019.
and is this an accurate representation
of Huron Church line here what are we
looking at in terms of the nearest cross
street where those where those traffic
lights are
uh I would have to have you tell me that
answer I'm not sure okay would it be
fair to say that this is close to the
Ambassador Plaza and that we're looking
at roughly two to three hundred meters
maybe a kilometer away from the mouth of
the bridge yep that's correct okay and
would you agree that this type of
traffic and slowdown Is Not Unusual
along that main Corridor in your
experience since 2006.
uh I would say that there is because of
the number of trucks that use here on
Church Road there is always the need for
some form of repair Rehabilitation or
construction along that road we receive
money from the provincial government
under a program called connecting links
which is designed to fund repair and
renewal of roads that are municipally
owned but really serve a greater purpose
like here on Church Road and so this is
an example of construction where traffic
is continuing to move in both directions
and there's construction happening today
on that road that would look much the
same where it's it's disruptive but it
does not stop international trade and so
you would agree with me then that this
picture here in terms of the the delays
in the traffic is also emblematic and
similar to the current state of the
bridge since let's say the beginning of
the summer
yeah there is ongoing construction on
another portion of Huron Church Road
which would look similar to this as well
I understood
I'd like to briefly touch on sort of who
knew what when within the ccg
you had indicated earlier that that you
were made aware of of some some
demonstrations in Sarnia and and that
there were the slow rolls happening in
Windsor but am I correct in saying that
Chief Mizuno was not terribly worried
about the slow rolls that were happening
at the end of January that was no
particular cause for concern yeah she
expressed to me that those were peaceful
that the vehicles continued to move and
international trade continued to move as
well all right and and we also made
aware
that the opp had shut down the highway
Junction at Highway 402 in an attempt to
block either the west or eastbound
traffic and and to control that
situation on or about February 6th
uh I I don't recall can we put up
document when
six zeros four one
foreign
if we can scroll down
and so this email I understand came from
Joe to Deckard do you know who he is
nope
um but would you agree with me that if
we scroll up here that this was sent to
a city of Windsor employee Carolyn Brown
looks that way yes and so you were never
advised as to the contents of this email
or this particular update that the opp
had shut down highway 402
yeah I don't recall seeing that email
all right if we scroll down a little bit
further there
that the opp in fact shut down the
highway and that no traffic was able to
go westbound to the U.S through Sarnia
due to police action
is that a fair assessment of the content
of this email I think it speaks for
itself understood
and so if we could pull up Windsor
documents zero zero zero six zeros and
three nine
and who is Andrew Ray that's me okay
and so were you informed then by Stephen
lafoury and Stephen lafores The Windsor
chief of fire is that correct
correct and he also sits on the ccg
yes and so he notified you about the
protest at Blue Water Bridge he was
informed at the four by emo that the 402
is now closed and it was closed by OPP
and not by a blockade is that were you
made aware of this this fact on February
6 around three in the afternoon I it
looks like that email was sent to me but
I don't recall reading it okay
and I think later in this document too
that they say that they are trying to
block off the Ambassador Bridge or at
least threatening to do so
is that further down in this email
oh we can scroll up a little bit
there's concern based on some limited
intelligence the Convoy will be or is
heading to Windsor today earlier Intel
indicated that the bridge was going to
be targeted on Monday so it would be
fair to say that on February 7th you had
some intelligence that there may be an
action at The Ambassador Bridge I think
it was even earlier than that
and so I wasn't too concerned about I
mean I was interested in the Blue Water
Bridge but that that's not within my my
scope of responsibility uh but I think
if you know as soon as February 4th came
when the chief told me
and she actually elevated the fact that
there was a slow roll protest uh we
started making arrangements that weekend
I think I mentioned this morning with
respect to Jersey barriers we started
making arrangements with respect to
moving the tunnel bus I initiated that
action trying to get the tunnel bus on
the on the duty-free side so that we
would have a way to get health care
workers through the tunnel in the event
that there was a blockade at the tunnel
as well uh and so we we didn't I mean we
we started that particular weekend
making arrangements uh not knowing if
the Slow Roll blockade or protest would
ever become a full block cape
okay and then if uh
so so after you were made aware of the
potential action in Windsor you
basically left it to the Windsor Police
Service to implement the plan and to
deal with the possibility of of a
blockade is that correct well again they
had a role to play with respect to
actions at The Ambassador Bridge I was
looking at other things as well again
the tunnel bus issue and making sure
that you know the chief had the
resources she needed as things developed
uh making sure that they could respond
very quickly because we were watching
what was happening in Ottawa we were
watching what was happening across the
country and we collectively wanted to
make sure that we were
finding best practices so as not to see
that type of behavior happen in Windsor
as well understood can we pull up
Windsor uh win four zeros two one seven
four
I believe these are the in-camera
meeting minutes from February 8 2022 at
7 pm do you recall being in attendance
at this meeting yes sir
and if we scroll down here I believe
it's on page two
scroll down a little further I think
there's a quote there that says that at
any point we can extend the circle of
control
do we see that here
absolutely closer to the bottom of the
page
perfect so that's Deputy Blair saying
that at any point we can extend the
circle of control what did you
understand that to mean
uh that if this escalated they could
they could expand the area in which they
were going to provide enforcement and
and did you have any understanding in
terms of what was within the circle of
control on February 8th at 7 pm no
I mean I just assumed it would have been
here in Church Road but I I was never
given a plan that delineated the the
boundary okay and I believe somewhere in
here Chief Mizuno says as well that we
are ready to ask should we need
assistance and that the amount of
assistance will be dictated by what
happens in the coming days you recall
hearing Miss Mizuno or chief Mizuno
saying that
yep I believe that to be accurate
perfect if we could just pull up your
witness statement you said earlier no
changes needed to be made I believe this
is WTS 5019
I believe in that document you said you
you weren't sure where the number 100
came from referring to the request for
additional officers
well I know where it came from it came
from the chief to me but I I never asked
her to sort of explain to me how she
came up with a hundred I simply asked
her what do you need to help get this
situation resolved
she got back to me and said I need 100
officers okay if we could pull up
um document when four zeros two three
zero six at Pages 10 and 11.
I've been fairly liberal but uh you're
now well over your time so you're gonna
have to write I thought we had 45
minutes here today
uh no you have 25 minutes okay
um I'll pick things up then
okay if we look at page 10
and we scroll down
on the right side is that is the the
text messages that are darker is that
you to miss uh to the chief that's
correct
and there that you indicate that we need
to make an official request to the
province and feds for the hundred
officers that's correct
so uh could you help me reconcile that
was was the request for 100 officers or
or the estimate of 100 officers did that
come from you or did that come from the
chief 100 it came from the chief uh is
that February the 8th uh if we can see
foreign
that's correct and so February the 8th
the chief had told me she needed a
hundred officers which I Amplified up to
the provincial and federal governments
what happened in the evening of February
the 8th my chief of staff Andrew
talazewski had a meeting with uh Chiefs
of Staff at the federal level of
government who asked that we put the
request in writing okay because then
told me that we need to put it in
writing I sent it to the chief saying we
need to put this in writing so your
testimony is that the request for 100
officers came directly from the the
chief of police and it was not at your
direction correct okay can we pull up uh
Windsor document
402295 I believe these are text messages
between the mayor and minister medicino
foreign
so if I've got the timeline correct here
so February 8th at 7 pm during the
in-camera meeting Chief Mizuno says we
are ready to ask for assistance should
we need it
then later in that evening you text her
and it appears to say probably about 100
officers if we're looking at here
page four
so on Wednesday the following evening
then
it appears that Minister minichino was
under the assumption that the the police
Chiefs that would be Chief Mizuno
uh told the opp commission that they're
not requesting additional enforcement
resources and you said that that was
inaccurate
I I said wrong
because that's completely contrary to
the conversation that I had had with the
chief and that we had discussed with the
board
if we scroll down a little further here
you had indicated earlier correcting
your statement that cbsa went to offer
tow trucks support to Windsor and then
the local police was saying that that
wasn't necessary is that correct or that
that's right that's Mr minuccino's text
to me right and so what I said was that
we were offered tow truck support but it
was and what cbsa offered to do is to
find the pathway to allow tow trucks and
tow truck drivers into Canada which may
not normally be admissible sort of as a
matter of right they did they agreed to
work with us if we needed to bring in
U.S based tow trucks to find the pathway
to get them through the border so that
they could be of assistance okay and so
would it be fair to say then that that
the two parts of this conversation we
saw you having with Minister medicino Mr
Minister manicino was incorrect about
whether or not the chief Mizuno had
requested resources and was also
incorrect as to the the type of
assistance that was offered by cbsa I
think what happened when I received that
message from Minister Mendicino and my
response was wrong I called the chief
immediately to make sure I understand
what understood what was going on the
chief explained to me that in the
conversation that she had had with
commissioner karig that at that precise
Moment In Time
they weren't asking for any more because
officers were coming in and she didn't
know how many officers were coming in I
understood okay and
it was also your understanding then that
there was a plan in place as early as
February 10th to dismantle this protest
is that correct
well I I knew that officers were coming
in I did not know the chief could not
tell me how many officers were coming
and nor was I aware of how long it would
take to resolve the issue
okay can we pull up WPS I believe that's
I'm going to have to stop you you're now
well over your time
so if you could wrap up please okay
there's some latitude just to show a
couple pictures here to make sure we're
on the same page in terms of what the
enforcement action did look like on the
February 13th
if we could pull up cff
nine
oops
sorry council is that uh is there
another digit after the nine
uh not according to this note here
okay we can we can skip that one and
look at uh
cff000260 instead
hmm
and so those officers there is that
you're not saying those are Windsor
police officers or those OPP I I can't
tell from the flash on their arm
does not look like a windsor flash
though
what about cff000261
those appear to be officers on the roof
do you know if those are Windsor Police
or is that OPP I can't tell
yeah and
you think that you weren't sure exactly
what time on uh either the 13th or the
14th that the bridge of being cleared
completely
do you recall reading a report from
again I believe this is chief of fire
Stephen lafaray that the blockade is
clear and that all needs have been met
and said 9 52 p.m on February 13th
yeah I do recall the the
you know the bridge had been the the
roadway had been cleared earlier than
the Bridge opened and so they had to get
the barriers in place once the people
were moved out and the vehicles were
moved out they had to get the barriers
in place before they could open the
bridge and then of course they had to
make sure that the area was Secure
uh as secure as it could be but there
was a heightened state of of alert on
that particular day and for weeks
afterwards understood and just in terms
of the the intention of some of those
protesters there uh I understand that
you referred to what happened to the
Ambassador Bridge almost as a Last of
the Mohicans moment and that when asked
to clarify you indicated that some
people there were willing to die for
that cause would you agree based on some
of your your observations that in the
evenings at least it was a party
atmosphere that the vast majority of
protesters there were not willing to be
shot in the streets to maintain that
protest and that it was by and large
absolutely peaceful well I
respecter but thank you um that was a
compound question uh that my friend has
asked I think it's an unfair question to
the mayor and he hasn't provided any of
these statements for him to see I I
object to that question
okay I'll move on there and and just to
clarify so Chief Pam Mizuno she is no
longer the chief of police in Windsor
she announced her sudden retirement on
March 22nd is that correct she has
retired yes
foreign
next is the government of Canada
uh good morning mayor dilkins uh
commissioner David shiroki for the
government of Canada
so in your evidence in Chief through the
commission Council you'd indicated the
city had supported an interim injunction
that was granted on the 11th of February
I'd like to pull up the reasons for that
internal injunction which I think can be
found in a number of places but at Ott
four zeros
7333 and as that's uh being pulled up
um you'd indicated in your evidence in
Chief that there were concerns about
vigilantism leading up to enforcement
and that was a factor that went into
seeking the injunction is that correct
absolutely where were these concerns
coming from uh social media for sure a
Facebook group had been set up we had
local labor leadership that was
being very vocal about Gathering a group
of people and going down there and
ending this blockade
and so it was it was a theme that uh I
would suggest had a head of steam fairly
early on because everyone appreciated
the impact of what was going on here
and were you aware of any organized
efforts either through that social media
or through announcements Through
official groups well I'm I'm aware that
there was a discussion with police that
had people lower the temperature people
who were purporting to want to do that
to lower the temperature and just let us
resolve this in a peaceful way and so we
have the document open which are the
reasons that were for the injunction
granted on the 11th of February and
specifically I'd like to go to page nine
and in particular paragraph 46 of the
decision
and so paraphrasing a bit the court
finds that there's no question that the
blockade had caused and would continue
to cause irreparable harm to Windsor
um
would you agree that the harm that's
being discussed here by the court and in
fact the harm that the city of Windsor
was talking about in supporting this
injunction was the harm caused by a
continuous blockade and not temporary
increases in traffic
100 percent that the harm was economic
harm to a lot of people in the community
and uh is it your understanding that uh
roughly around midnight either the night
of the 13th or the 14th the the blockade
was cleared and the bridge reopened to
traffic correct and with respect to the
timing of that enforcement and your
evidence in Chief Feud indicated that
there was a delay in enforcement due to
the arrival of children of the protest
correct
what were you hearing from police about
the impact of the presence of children
at the protest
I what I heard uh from the chief is they
were going to stand down on the Saturday
night resume enforcement on Sunday uh
you know there were people live
streaming on social media from the area
so I watched some of that as well and
media was there reporting and you saw
the numbers of protesters swell
dramatically
uh and it was all of a sudden you saw
kids in strollers you saw young kids and
it was I would submit in direct relation
to uh the sort of call to support by the
pastor in that one particular Church
all right and um sort of in a similar
vein I'd like to take uh the witness to
uh win four zeros2238 please
and while that's coming up you'd
indicated the city had asked for an
extension of the interim injunction and
that this was an indefinite extension is
that correct that's correct
um and and the document that we're
pulling up again are the Court's reasons
for granting that in different
indefinite extension to the injunction
if we could go to page eight uh in
specific paragraph 47.
and at the bottom there I think it's a
Roman numeral four
the court found that the city of Windsor
had established a continued threat of a
new blockade
and with respect to again the the
evidence and the submissions were being
brought to the court to extend the same
Junction is is that the concern was it a
either a continued blockade or a
re-emergence of the blockade yes more
more a re-emergence uh I mean at the
time obviously it was it was to try and
have everyone move on but again I think
it's I've said this several times the
the heightened state of alert that
everyone was under that police were
under following the removal of the
protesters in their vehicles I've never
seen that in my city in the past and so
there was a strong concern that this
would happen again which would put us on
a cycle of having you know another week
of trying to move people out and
mobilizing resources from across the
province and across the country and so
uh the city provided a number of
affidavits in support of this injunction
extension and I believe the application
record from the city is at win five
zeros 925 and I I won't ask that that be
brought up it's a very long document I
just would like to uh refer to it uh
that there was evidence provided that
that spoke to this continued risk of a
blockade re-emerging
um and so
a document that I would like pulled up
is w-i-n-50803
I'll just wait for that to come up
uh Mr Mayor what are we looking at here
in terms of geographically within
Windsor uh the yellow line is here on
Church Road and the X's are
intersections that access here in Church
Road if we could scroll down briefly
so there's an indication there are no
local traffic Beyond this point and
that's the period you spoke of sort of a
tunnel I know there's a literal tunnel
but the tunnel leading down here on
Church Road to the Ambassador Bridge
that's the area you're speaking of
that's correct once you pass that red
bar where it says no local traffic you
you basically had to get on the
Ambassador Bridge and if I told you that
this was a map of the traffic uh
structure on the 16th of February would
that sound about right too that's
correct so this was a closure of a major
Municipal Road in Windsor wasn't it yes
and it impacted residents and nearby
homes and neighborhoods massively and
you'd indicated uh the specific
neighborhood of Sandwich town as being
to the west of Huron Church Road that's
correct and there were no access to
groceries for the residents of Sandwich
town as a result of the blockade and
then the subsequent closure of the road
they they had to take a very long road
to get to the same grocery store that
they would normally get to and so the
city had to provide alternative bus
services to those residents so that they
could go about their lives and we did
yes
and you would agree with me that the
city and the police would not choose to
continue to limit access by residents to
Huron Church Road unless it believed
there was a real risk that a
demonstration could return correct
and I know you said that you were
uncertain on the date at which point
these traffic closures stopped but you
would agree with me that the measures to
prevent the re-establishment of a
blockade remained in a place after the
23rd of February yes
so a commission Council took you to win
five zeros 972
and I'd actually like that to be brought
up please
and I'll take you to a a similar portion
where you refer to uh it remaining a
national security situation
uh if we could scroll down there's
bolded text there it is
um and so this is the situation that
again it says here prevented reopening
Huron Church Road and that's the closure
we were just looking at on that map
yes
if we could go to page three
um and so it says here we cannot ignore
these ongoing threats because of the
inconvenience that's being caused along
Huron Church Road uh with respect to
these ongoing threats can you speak a
little bit about I know you said the
information was coming from police but
what were you hearing during that time
period there were for several weeks
um I mean immediately once the Jersey
bearers were put in and access to the
bridge was was made available uh there
was a high state of alert for police
there was still a huge police presence
along here on Church Road uh and there
was a a strong concern expressed to me
by Chief Mizuno that there is a concern
that this could flare up again
and that lasted for several weeks it
lasted in fact you know until the
situation was dealt with in Ottawa and
the thought was that when Ottawa uh the
protests in Ottawa was disband that
folks would get in their trucks and come
back to Windsor and so this lasted for
quite some time and so you referred in
this statement to it being a national
security situation did you see the
events in Windsor as being connected
ideologically or otherwise to other
events happening nationally
yeah I mean certainly you know watching
what happened in the U.S where there
were Freedom convoys in the U.S and and
that happened in several cities uh that
was concerning seeing what happened in
Ottawa that was concerning knowing the
money that was being reported with
respect to flows from
those the give send go or whatever it's
called GoFundMe uh that that was
concerning uh and so there were lots
there was no shortage of concern uh and
this was in my mind and and will remain
until I'm long gone a National Economic
emergency and that is a direct there's a
direct correlation to a National
Economic emergency and I would submit to
a national security issue and this is
exactly what this was and with respect
to the specific topic of security were
you aware of the arrests that took place
in Coots Alberta on the 14th of February
yes sir how did you become aware of
those uh through traditional media and
what's your understanding of those
events uh that that police were able to
intercept a group of people who had
weapons that intended to do harm uh to
others and they were part of the protest
in Coots Alberta and acknowledging of
course that Coots is quite
geographically distant from Windsor
Ontario
reading that with respect to again to
talking about security were there any
concerns that were raised in your mind
at that time
you know I would say that what from my
impression what I saw happen in Coots
was the type of behavior that police
were posturing for here the type of
behavior they thought may play out here
and I think that played out in the
posture that they presented in the way
that they handled themselves in Windsor
and so the Coots situation happened
after the fact but there was that level
of temperature on the ground where
police in Windsor were quite concerned
and that did not want to inflame the
situation they were taking every
opportunity to de-escalate a highly
charged situation
and so you said both in your
evidence-in-chief and in your witness
statement your understanding or belief
that the invocation of the emergencies
act sent a signal that the federal
government was taking the blockade
situation seriously
I agree with that and that it may have
discouraged the re-establishment of the
blockades particularly with respect to
the Ambassador Bridge I agree with that
fully that's is that still your view yes
sir
moving on to economic issues
[Music]
um
I'd like to take the witness to
ssm.can five zeros 495 underscore Rel
and in particular page two
and while that's coming up
um
actually we'll start on page one just so
we can identify the document
now this is likely not something you've
seen this is a background or Report with
respect to the impact of the roadblock
hate on the Ambassador Bridge that I
believe is printed paired uh by finance
Canada so if we move to page two
uh the reason I'm bringing this up if we
scroll down
now there's a discussion here about uh
both the exports and I think the exports
have been well covered in your evidence
uh what's your understanding about the
items or Goods they're imported from the
United States into Windsor
I I don't know that I have a a discrete
I don't know that I have discrete
knowledge on the Imports versus the
exports and I would just say that with
respect to the trade that we see
regionally in our community or at least
locally in my city uh there is I go back
to the the the the parts that cross the
border
six to seven times before they're put
into a vehicle that rolls off the
assembly line it speaks to the tightly
integrated Supply chains that we have in
Windsor and Detroit which are where
respectively our own Auto capitals of
our countries and so going back to the
report in the the last paragraph that's
on the the screen there it speaks to
Canada importing uh four billion dollars
worth of pharmaceutical products and 2.4
billion dollars in medical equipment
that go through the Ambassador Bridge
and that was in 2021 is that a figure
that would be surprising to you no I
believe that
uh you also mentioned the bridges impact
regionally uh would you agree with me
that the Imports that come in through
the bridge don't stay in Ontario
in their entirety in their entirety no
and that it's part of a national supply
chain 100 agree with that statement uh
I'd like to now take the witness to win
four zeros1628
and this is a statement that my friend
uh for commission Council took you uh to
earlier uh that was delivered on the 9th
of February
and if we could
scroll down to I believe the top of the
second page
so it's the statement here again that if
Canada becomes known as a difficult
jurisdiction to do business with to move
Goods in and out for example then Supply
chains will evolve and reconfigure to
remove this element of risk and avoid
Windsor Essex and was that your concern
at the time with respect to Canada or
Windsor specifically's reputation as a
place to do business it was part of the
concerns for the reason that I mentioned
and they actually play out and part of
the conversation the readout which has
been submitted uh in terms of documents
my readout with my conversation with the
Prime Minister where I even raised the
issue of of the battery Factory in that
conversation with him and so there is no
doubt that we
must tread very lightly with respect to
these types of incidents as they relate
to our competitive position not just as
a city of Windsor but provincially and
nationally because we are competing
against
Michigan Ohio Indiana Kentucky Tennessee
for these types of Investments and
you've seen big automakers make
investments in those States and we knew
that we were fourth and goal to quote a
football term on Landing this battery
Factory and so I needed to make sure
that the signal was sent to those who
would be interested in this that we we
take this very seriously and we're going
to resolve this very seriously and very
quickly
um
acknowledging that I'm just at my 15
minutes if I could just briefly take the
witness to one more document and wrap up
would that be acceptable no thank you go
ahead it's a PB dot c a n dot uh sorry
yeah dot six zeros23 underscore Rel uh
and while that's coming up I'll provide
some context this is another document
that you may not have seen it's a
February 10th email chain between
employees of the Canadian embassy in
Washington DC and the Consulate General
in Detroit and specifically I'd like to
go to page two
these are a series of tweets uh from a
U.S representative uh slotkin who I
understand is the Congressional uh 8th
Congressional District representative in
Michigan
um and I I if the commissioner will
allow I'd like to give the witness some
time to read there's a series of tweets
that go down the page so if you could
take a look and and let the clerk know
when you can
scroll a bit further you can keep
scrolling
it's the upside of a tweet is at least
they can be read quick yeah
just underscores those statements
underscore my explanation and so you
would understand these statements to be
a a political representative from the
U.S saying that we would need to move
manufacturing to the U.S as a result of
incidents like the blockade at The
Ambassador but that's absolutely correct
um
and my friend with commission Council
took you to some text that you had with
Premier Ford in the interest of time I
won't ask they be brought up again but
do you recall him texting you that he
had every major company all over him yes
do you understand what he meant by that
state absolutely I do and what was your
understanding of that statement that
this was not just companies in Windsor
or companies in Essex County that this
this bridge and this border crossing has
it's of provincial and National
significance so when it's blocked he
gets phone calls from major
manufacturers all the way up the 401 at
the risk of pushing my luck Mr
commissioner if I should have two more
questions
go ahead thank you very much
um you would agree with me that a
blockade of the Ambassador Bridge would
be more economically damaging than
blocking the Detroit Windsor Tunnel yes
and that an experienced truck driver
would know that they could not use the
tunnel correct those are all my
questions thank you very much for that
Indulgence sir thank you
next to the Convoy organizers
foreign
good afternoon good afternoon uh for the
record Brennan Miller I appears Council
for Freedom Corp which represents the
protesters that were in Ottawa in
January and February of 2022 uh good
afternoon sir again and uh thank you for
appearing here today my first question
is is prior to you taking on your
current office or former office
uh what did you do in as a job prior I'm
a lawyer as well you're a lawyer as well
yes sir and I take it you didn't ever
work a national security law did you no
sir all right and so it's fair to say
you're not a national security expert
and you don't have background on what
constitutes a National Security
emergency is that fair
I I would say that I've never practiced
national security law but there are some
things on the face of it uh that present
themselves and I think would be obvious
to everyone could be related to National
Security right and when it comes to
National Security I take it you rely a
lot on law enforcement is that correct
with respect to providing you
information correct right and in your
capacity of course municipally that's
primarily going to be your Municipal
Police Force and the opp
mostly Municipal Place mostly Municipal
that's right and can you agree if you
said you have some of an understanding
of national security so you're familiar
with uh the Canadian Security
intelligence service yes sir and what's
your understanding of what they do
well they have their own act and and
certainly I'm sure it's well spelled out
in the act that if you brought it up we
could go through it but yeah but you
agree with me that there's the the
federal intelligence service sort of the
Canadian equivalent to the CIA is that
fair yes okay and so the intelligence
they gather with respects to threats to
the security of Canada can you agree
with me that they would probably have
the best information
I think there's certainly a good source
I think RCMP would also be a great
source as well from a policing
perspective and okay uh could we please
bring up uh document I've sent an email
about it arising from my friend's cross
uh
t-s dot
nsc.can.001.000206 underscore Rel
underscore zero zero zero one
Jennifer King for the city of Windsor
commissioner we received an email it
appears from my friend Mr Miller
less than 15 minutes ago with three
documents that he if I can assist I'm
only referring to the one
in any event we had no notice
documents its contrary to the rules we
haven't had any notice that they intend
to put this to mayor dilkins
okay Mr Miller at the document the first
time yes and it only arose from
cross-examination from my friend as I
made clear in my email not from the city
of Windsor not from the commission but
from my friend with the federal
government which made it relevant okay
well let's see what the document is and
if there's a problem uh either if the
witness needs time or if counsels for
Windsor has uh an objection we can we
can deal with it now sir this is a
document from the Canadian Security
intelligence Service summarizing uh what
it is they discussed with cabinet
regarding threats to National Security
and if we could just scroll down to page
five please
okay so I just want you to see that so
on that document there on February or
February 3rd sees this assessed there is
no uh indicators that known imves and I
take it you know what that is uh actors
were planning to engage in violence
and then if you scroll down to the other
bullet points it states on February 13th
cesus advised that the implementation of
the EA would likely Galvanize uh the
anti-government narrative within the
Convoy and further radicalize of some
towards violence referring to the
increase in violent rhetoric following
the Declaration of the state of
emergency in the province of Ontario
furthermore species advised the
announcement thank you furthermore cesus
advised that the invocation of the EA by
the federal government would likely lead
to the dispersing of the Convoy within
Ottawa but would likely increase the
number of Canadians who hold extreme
anti-government views and push some
towards the belief that violence is the
only solution to what they perceived as
a broken system and government following
the invocation of the EA thesis brief
cabinet and reiterated the potential for
the EA to increase anti-government views
and violent ideologies including in
those not yet radicalized now can you
agree with me that you would never want
to
do anything that could create further
radicalization of extremists within the
city of Windsor is that fair I'm going
to Egypt object to this question on this
dog and object to this document being
put to them withdrawn I'm done thank you
sir
okay
next is the
city of Ottawa you can get started if
you'd like and we'll
seems to always happen that the city of
Ottawa to be at lunchtime
uh good afternoon mayor my name is Anne
tardief I'm one of the lawyers for the
city of Ottawa
um you mentioned in your testimony and I
think in your witness summary that you
had calls with both the solicitor
general as Sylvia Jones for Ontario and
the federal minister of Public Safety
Minister Mendocino correct correct and
you were requesting additional police
sources and I should say that you were
amplifying the request that your Chief
had alerted you to Fair that's correct
thank you and you mentioned that the
federal government in particular was
very supportive
so is so is Minister Jones both were
very supportive and I take it that staff
if I understood you correctly staff at
the federal level ask that your request
or the request for additional resources
be put in writing is that correct that's
correct and we saw the letters that
Chief Mizuno sent uh further to that
request to both the provincial and the
federal government right that's right
and I take it they were sent more or
less at the same time Fair that's true
and it's fair to say then that no one at
the federal government said to you
you've got to go to the province first
you're not following proper protocol or
anything of that nature well they they
didn't say don't send me the letter but
you know there was a conversation that
the order of operations is Municipal to
provincial provincial to Federal uh but
you know the nature of what was
happening here and the nature was going
on across the country we knew I think a
a sensible person would know that there
are resource there's Limited resources
and they're being drawn to assist in
different areas that from my chair and
my perspective and I think it's fair to
say from Chief mizuno's perspective we
didn't care whether it was the opp or
the RCMP that arrived we just needed
more boots on the ground to help resolve
the issue
perfect thanks very much if I could
bring up
w-i-n-50410
and while this is coming up merits an
email exchange between Jason Raynor am I
pronouncing that correctly that yes you
are thank you at the city of Windsor and
chief lafare who I understand is the
fire chief in Windsor and was also the
chair if I understood correctly of the
ccg that's true
and if we scroll down to the bottom
there's the email from Mr Raynor to the
entire corporate leadership team uh
including of course uh Chief lafoury uh
and he's advising uh that the injunction
has been granted and will come into
effect at 7 pm tonight which is Friday
February 11th correct that's that's
correct and if we could scroll down Mr
Clerk
he says but these advances may have the
effect of quote unquote ratcheting up
the protesters and their supporters we
will be watching closely to see what
developments happen over the next uh 24
hours and it goes on from there so this
concern about ratcheting up the
protesters with the issue in Civic
injunction was something I take it that
the the city was aware of on the 11th
well the city was but the the chief when
I told her when I asked her you know
we're going to apply for an injunction
do you think this would be helpful that
was never a conversation or concern that
she expressed me from a policing
perspective so our fire chief saying
that I'm not sure where he you know
where he he he put that where he got
that from to think of putting that in an
email
but clearly you know we weren't looking
to ratchet things up we were looking to
resolve things in a sensible way
and I take it then your Chief reassured
you that that was not a concern or not
one that she had at heart she never
expressed to me a concern about and Drew
a correlation between an injunction and
the the thought that we would be
ratcheting up or escalating the
situation
okay thanks very much
um I understand and
um we've heard already in your testimony
that there was an original uh injunction
time limited for 10 days obtained on
February 11th and that the city then
moved to obtain an indefinite extension
of that injunction correct that's
correct and this will be the the last
document I'll ask Mr clerk to put up and
it is
w-i-n-50921 Mayor this is the
um factum or the legal argument uh well
you're a lawyer the factum because I can
use that word that the city of Ottawa if
we scroll down just a little bit the
city of Windsor pardon me filed uh in
support of uh the order seeking the
order for an indefinite extension of the
injunction if we just scroll down you'll
see it there factum of the intervening
party the corporation in the city of
Windsor and if we could go to paragraph
two Mr Clerk
before I take you through this
um you've given ample evidence already
about the concern that the city had
about the possible Resurgence of uh a
blockade at the bridge if the injunction
were to expire correct yes and I just
wanted to to draw this out this is the
argument beforth by the city of winter
and it says the amounts in the days
since the February 11th order was made
have reinforced the ongoing need for the
injunction since the February 11th order
came into effect at 7 pm on February 11
2022 it's paragraph sub paragraph a
protesters defied the February 11th
order with numbers increasing and
peaking at between 600 and 800
individuals during the evening of
Saturday at February 12
2022 and I take it that was information
the city obtained from from police yes
okay and that was information that
formed part of the city's decision then
to seek a continuation of that
injunction
yes
uh thanks very much mayor those are my
questions
okay so I think this is an appropriate
time to take the lunch break so we'll
take an hour and come back to continue
the
the questioning
the commission is in recess for one hour
foreign
order a lot
[Music]
the commission has reconvened Lecom
okay next
up I believe is the Windsor Police
Service
thank you Mr commissioner I'm Tom McRae
for the Windsor Police Service we have
no questions for mayor dilkins and give
our time if we may to the city of
Windsor thank you okay
former Chief slowly
thank you commissioner
mayor dilkins good afternoon I'm Tom
Curry for former Chief slowly the Ottawa
Police Service and I just have a few
questions
for you if I can
have you assist the commissioner
um
first things first
unprecedented in your
experience both in politics and as a
resident of Windsor that's correct
and
um
I think you told the commissioner it was
unlike anything you have ever seen in
the roles that you've played
including as the chair of the Police
Services Board that is correct
um
all the way down to the death threats
against you and presumably other other
members of your
Council or the administration of the
city is that true I I there were threats
to Fire Bomb my house I was my some of
the folks put my home address online
people were driving by my house and the
police were there so you know there was
there was that threat directly the other
threats were to protest and and I'm not
aware of any other death threats to
members of council right and that's a
first
an unpleasant first for you as well
yeah I think it's you know I I live with
my wife and two kids so it's unpleasant
to have someone threatened to come and
Fire by my house
in Chief slowly has told the
the commissioner that this that the
events in Ottawa
represented a paradigm shift
in in protest as we have understood it
in Canada
now do you share that view
well I can speak just from my
perspective in the city of Windsor and
again I would I would reiterate that
this was different than almost anything
else I can recall seeing in my entire
time in the city certainly my entire
time as an elected official in the city
of Windsor and it was the the
temperature and the tenor and the
the aggressive nature of the actors that
certainly
um caused everyone to respond in a
different way and be far more calculated
and and uh concerned about the approach
and I I believe it's also true that this
is the first time that the Ambassador
Bridge
um or other critical infrastructure in
Canada I suppose has been used
to by protesters the first time it's
ever been closed by a protest first of
all is that true that is not true there
was a protest back in the early 90s but
there was an injunction granted very
very quickly to re-establish the the
route to the Ambassador Bridge so it did
not last for a very long time okay got
it
yeah first time I suppose also as the
chair of the Police Services Board that
you have seen the Windsor Police Service
unable to mount a police response with
their own resources correct and that led
you to as you have told us that led you
to engage with your provincial and
federal and Municipal Partners along
with Chief Mizuno
to get the resources that you needed
right that's right and I think you also
told the commissioner that there were no
impediments raised by the provincial or
federal your provincial or federal
counterparts
at the political level
um
to the to the uh obtaining of those
resources
you put your hand up and said we need
help and they came to your Aid is that
fair yeah that's fair I I think they
were responding to the best of their
ability Chief Mizuno did tell me that
someone in the mechanism of or in the
the group of folks she was working with
the mechanism of the police order that
they had to figure out how to allocate
resources in Ontario because we were not
the only place experiencing a protest
like this at the time of the protest in
Windsor the blockage on the 7th of
February of course Ottawa was had by
then been
choose the word but I'll use the the
Occupy language it had been occupied by
protesters for several days by that time
you knew that that's correct and were
you told or do you recall being told by
the minister I'm now referring to the
solicitor general
or the federal Minister that Windsor was
the provincial and federal priority for
the opp and RCMP no all right you you
did not know that that Windsor by the
seventh or soon after the seventh was
identified by those Partners as the as
their priority no one said that to me
but you know because of the significant
economic damage that was being caused a
reasonable person would say they need to
fix this quick understood it and you've
you told us I think you told the
commissioner that these events in
Windsor affected tens of thousands of of
Canadians it would be it would not be an
exaggeration to say it it affected many
more than that uh uh given the given the
uh the economics that you described is
that fair it's probably hundreds of
thousands if we're being completely
honest uh you you as the chair of the
Police Service Board just a couple of
questions about that you
um whether whether as the chair of the
Police Services Board as or as mayor am
I right that you made public statements
to provide information to the residents
in Windsor and to the wider audience
about the need for resources that you
had requested not specifically we did
not go out and say we need a hundred
officers but we did amplify the police
request for additional officers so that
the public knew that the city that
police that we were in harmony working
together and we needed additional
support right I saw I tell me if if my
memory is right but I thought I saw that
on on one in one of No Doubt many
interviews that you were giving at the
time I think it was to A CTV reporter
that you did identify the number that
had been requested at the earliest date
I think being a hundred is it possible
you mentioned that if I made that
mistake it was corrected very quickly
and it was not made twice okay
understood
um and and as well am I right from the
record that you held your police you
decided as the chair of the Police
Services Board to maintain those
meetings that you had with Chief Mizuno
and her staff in camera
that the police board meetings yes
that's correct okay
um
now can I just ask you
um
please to look with us at
uh one of those Police Services Board
meetings that you you showed my
colleagues
um and that is uh for the registrar
Windsor
w-i-n2173 these are minutes I think
mayor of uh uh of the police services
board meeting
just while that's coming up can I just
ask you also
it it it seemed both listening to you
and looking at the record
that you made a conscious effort
to have your counsel and the Police
Services Board speaking with one voice
very early on my chief of staff Andrew
telesewski sent a message to city
council asking that any request for
media interviews any public comments any
desired to post on social media that we
really speak with a unified voice so
that there was Clarity and no confusion
and and I must give the city council
immense credit for doing that they were
very we worked very well in harmony
together and am I right for and again
for the commissioner's purposes as he
considers recommendations
um
you faced enormous public pressure
didn't you yes to act
and the Police Service
um experienced enormous public pressure
to act
that's true and do you agree with me
that it was important and it would be
important in the future for municipal
leaders like you
and Police Service Board chairs like you
uh to to to be disciplined about
speaking with one voice and to have
matters dealt with in camera
uh that was extremely helpful it was
extremely helpful on with communication
to the public that they had one source
of contact that we weren't
um stepping on each other in terms of
messaging and as a city councilor
there's a great desire to respond to
every complaint that's coming in from
residents and we were all receiving them
uh and so by sticking together like we
did I think it was actually good for the
public that they had cohesive
communication that it was checked and
many times uh the public comments where
we had
uh public press conferences those
comments that I delivered were reviewed
by the chief of police and and her team
uh so that there was no there were no
surprises when we delivered a message
understood and am I right that the other
thing that you did was
um you became the The Voice
of the unified Council Police Services
Board and the city's response you were
the spokesperson
spokesperson for the city right and uh
did in that role did you take did you
take some of the pressure away from the
police service having to deal with those
matters uh themselves or the chief
herself
uh probably I mean the the most
important point was that they were
focused on the police operation and the
communication to the public even as
enunciated in our our ccg and you know
duties and responsibilities it's the
mayor's responsibility to communicate
with members of council members of the
public members of media and so we just
follow the rules that were were spelled
out and it worked very well thank you
and while we're on recommendations that
you mentioned to the commissioner that
you had penned a letter to the to your
federal and provincial counterparts uh
concerning the expenses that Windsor has
borne as a consequence of the of the
blockade
and so far no reply but would you say
that for in terms of recommendations
from what you have gone through that
what would be
worth considering is is a coordinated
effort by all three levels of government
to deal with these kinds of events in
the future were they to arise again
including down to cost sharing
absolutely these things should be
spelled out so especially the use the
Ambassador Bridge is the perfect example
where you have Federal responsibility
Municipal roadway and Municipal
responsibility and then connecting to a
provincial Highway where there's
provincial responsibility these types of
things
ought to be worked out I'll slower slow
down these things should be worked out
in advance most importantly who's doing
who's paying for what because at the end
of the day we've we are shouldering a
big expense on the backs of the
residents in the city of Windsor to deal
with what I call a National Economic
emergency understood
and then may I just get your help with
this what is on the uh on the screen now
2173 thank you Mr registrar is the the
in-camera meeting of the Police Services
Board February 11th so this is just
shortly before the operation uh began on
the next day the 12th is that true
that's correct and chief Mizuno is there
you're there just scroll down if you
don't mind I just wanted to have you uh
help us with uh you you asked
um
if there was anything required Chief
Mizuno said no resources are are flowing
what are the outcomes and so on just
scroll down it's just a page two that I
wanted to stop there please Chief Mizuno
when asked about specifics said the
situation is still fluid we are working
on our operational plans and continue to
review
as new information such as this becomes
available the goal is to reinstate
traffic on the bridge
a counselor asked a question about the
injunction and forced being enforced and
she said we are actively working
on our plan I won't take you through the
rest of it but do I have it that
Chief Mizuno
did not ever provide the Police Services
Board with details of the operational
plan which was as of the 11th still
being actively worked on that's correct
and is it true also that the absence of
that finalized plan to be presented to
the Police Services Board or to anyone
did not impair or delay the the delivery
of resources from your policing Partners
at the provincial and federal level
that's true we the board was never
waiting on the plan to be presented to
us for some sort of receipt for
information or approval we knew what the
point was does the chief have the
resources to implement whatever plan is
being prepared and that was the question
asked by the board understood then just
two two more things very quickly to have
your your help with please could I
please show the mayor WPS
uh lots of zeros 522 Mr registrar please
this is a situational update uh mayor
dillkins and I just want to get your
help for the commissioner in terms of
the status of these
uh the circumstances in which you found
yourself
as of the eighth this is at 14 30 hours
you knew that these situational reports
were being prepared
uh and you would be briefed by the chief
or her deputies I I was not privy to
this I didn't know that there were these
particular reports but the chief would
share with me the things she thought I
needed to know right I just want to tell
me whether you learned this information
in any of the briefings that there were
50 to 60 vehicles at that time so this
is the afternoon on the 8th
um and their described there
and this last sentence of that first
paragraph one group is willing to work
with police and open some lanes while
the other is very oppositional and
refuses to give up any ground propensity
for violence is possible Windsor Police
attempted to tow a vehicle drivers
exited their vehicles with Tire irons
and threatened to assault the tow truck
drivers
officers blocked off traffic points
leading to the demonstration
um
and then just scrolling down
there was a the
you see the concern of the police is if
they start to allow traffic into the
area of the one they've described there
is a potential for many additional
supporters to join the demonstration
does that is that the tenor of the
briefings that you were getting in and
around that time yep that's true
including the the risk the actual risk
that that there was a violent act uh
threatened against tow truck operators
with protesters using Tire irons from
that specifically that specific incident
was relayed to me directly by the chief
and that happened in the parking lot of
the of the high school I think you told
the commissioner no negotiations
um were successful in any material way
to resolve this protest not in any
lasting way right
were you made aware that the solicitor
general herself wrote a letter
to the protesters or proposed to to
negotiate with them and they refused
that invitation as well
I only became aware of that in reviewing
some of the documents for this
commission right I was unaware at the
time okay fair enough I won't take you
to the commissioner just for your
reference that's
wps1454 letter from the solicitor
general mayor dilkins thank you I don't
have any additional questions thank you
commissioner okay thank you
uh Ottawa Police Service
thank you
good afternoon mayor delkins my name is
David mitchikovski and I'm counsel for
the Ottawa Police Service good afternoon
the um protest in Windsor began or the
blockade I should say began on February
7th and was cleared on February 13th is
that correct that's correct and
geographically the area where the
blockade was I understand was a
significantly smaller footprint than in
Ottawa is that fair from my
understanding that's true and so the
total number of trucks when
um
at its highest was I think you said 200
I I would rely on deputy chief
Crowley for that information I know the
it the number of protesters ebbed and
flowed and there were 200 at one time
but in terms of the number of trucks I'd
hate to Hazard I guess because the
police were tracking that with more
Precision sure I seem to recall that it
was about a hundred or so but we can
verify that with the deputy chief
um
the um
Convoy reached Ottawa
on January 28th I believe and I
understand that the city of Windsor
learns some important lessons based on
what had occurred in Ottawa is that fair
that's that's fair
and that was because it was an
unprecedented situation for which
neither the city of Windsor nor the
Windsor Police could be prepared but
um given what they learned in Ottawa
there were some things that they thought
they could adapt is that right it's true
that there were lessons learned that
they were trying to employ in Windsor
that were happening in Ottawa sure and
so one of them
um was and you mentioned it to my friend
Mr Curry if we could just pull up um
w-i-n-400152
at page two please
there's an email from uh Andrew uh at uh
18 uh further down please
uh you'll see
um the uh counselor uh costante
counselor costanti is a municipal
counselor
and um actually if you scroll down a
little bit further you'll see the
beginning of the of the chain
um
and so what I take and you can scroll
through this if you need to
um what I take from this is the point
that you made with Mr Curry is that it
was important that the city be uh United
with the police in terms of their
response
correct absolutely and
um that everybody from the city speak
with one voice that the counselors not
all be saying different things that's
right that's correct and um uh I see
from that email chain that in fact uh
councilor costanti did comply with that
request correct yes that's correct and
the concern was that that was not what
had been occurred in Ottawa correct
that's what Mr telazewski put in the
email yes and I believe
um the opp Also may have uh talked about
the need for everybody to speak with one
voice correct I believe that's true as
well
um and um
there's another example uh I'll just uh
call it up it's
w-i-n-40 1091
and so if you scroll down to the bottom
of it
um you'll see that a constituent if you
just scroll uh it was a constituent
writing to and if you could scroll up
please a constituent writing to the
counselors and complaining that Windsor
Police were doing the same as Ottawa and
surrendering control uh to the
protesters and you'll see the response
above that
was really uh two-fold uh which was
um firstly Council can't direct the
police and the second point was to tell
the constituents that they're
misinformed when they think that the
police are not doing anything correct
that's correct and it's important for
the city to be supporting the police and
because sometimes the public doesn't see
what the police is doing and why they
are doing or not doing taking certain
enforcement actions is that your
understanding that's that's true
and another useful lesson you indicated
you learned uh from Otto was was not to
publicly announce the number of officers
uh requested and I believe as I
understand it had Ottawa not happened
first you might not have realized that
is that fair well I I think that may
have come out very quickly to the extent
that it was mentioned to a member of the
media the course was corrected very
quickly thereafter and so we obviously
don't want to and certainly as the chair
of the police board did not want to do
anything that would jeopardize the
police operation or tip our hand in
terms of what additional resources might
be needed specifically right and that
was something I think the opp conveyed
to you as a result of Lessons Learned
From Ottawas all right yes
um and another thing I know um and we
don't need to turn it up unless you want
to see it is I I think another message
that was repeated by the city was for
counselors not to go on uh social media
uh to be very careful what they put on
social media correct correct
and um the blockade just finishing off
my last point the blockade I think we
said began on February 7th and we know
uh from your evidence this morning that
on February 4th I believe you wrote a
text message you sent a text message to
uh Minister Mendocino
yes so a couple days in advance and at
that time you were not considering
blocking all access to the bridge in
advance because that would involve many
many access points
it it would have been such a dramatic
action to take that step in advance of a
full blockade that I mean no one would
have understood that right and it would
require many more resources obviously
than would be available absolutely true
and I guess finally blocking all access
would disrupt residents and businesses
obviously
but it could also mean that if you did
that the trucks would spread out over a
larger part of Windsor as well is that
fair that was a concern especially is it
related to The Winds of Detroit tunnel
and that would disrupt even more people
absolutely true thank you very much I
have no additional questions
thank you uh Ontario Provincial Police
thank you commissioner this is Janine
kabersi I'm here for the Ontario
Provincial Police and I have no
questions thanks okay thank you
uh next are the Ottawa residence
coalition
thank you commissioner Christine Johnson
for the Ottawa residence and businesses
Coalition we also have no questions for
this Witness
National Police Federation
Pierce
coming in Via Zoom we also have no
questions for this Witness
thank you
Faith city of Windsor
good afternoon commissioner mayor
dilkins for the record I am Jennifer
King counsel to the city of Windsor I
only have a few questions remaining for
you most of my questions have already
been asked and answered could I ask you
to please look at win five zeros 992
while this is coming up mayor dillkins
this is a letter from yourself to The
Honorable Helena jasic Minister
responsible for the federal Economic
Development Agency for southern Ontario
do you recognize this letter yes I do
okay if you could scroll to the last
paragraph on the page
you'll see here you wrote Windsor Police
and their Partners in law enforcement
have done an exemplary job in quickly
clearing the illegal occupation and
maintaining the security of Huron Church
Road for over 400 million in goods that
travel this Crossing each day
unfortunately the price of that economic
security has meant a significant and
sustained loss for small and
medium-sized businesses who operate
along Huron Church Road in Windsor
if you could keep strolling down
and you'll see here that you ask or you
urge the minister to show the same level
of leadership and support the business
Community along Huron Church Road uh as
was showed to Ottawa businesses who
manage through the pandemic and now must
cope with police barricades designed to
protect our national economy from those
who would seek to disrupt it because
they oppose Canada's pandemic related
policies did you receive a response to
this letter in request yes I've received
a phone call from the minister and then
the the federal government provided
funding and business support for the
businesses affected by the blockade okay
and just to confirm that was it the
federal government or was the FED Dev
program
uh I'd have to double check but through
this Federal Minister the the funds
flowed to uh our invest Windsor Essex
organization who acted as the Clearing
House for
businesses affected to to make
application and receive payment okay and
they received those funds yes
I just have a question if you could pull
up please the clerk bring up win four
zeros two two four zero
well this is coming up mayor dilkins
it'll take a moment my friend commission
Council asked you questions if you'll
recall about your March letters to
minister Freeland and some others and
then also a second letter to former
solicitor general uh General Jones
and what you see here is this your
letter uh from date of March 17th to
minister Jones Minister Mendocino and
Minister Blair yes
okay and if you could just go to the
second page second to last paragraph
please
all right you'll see here mayor that uh
you wrote that the recent blockade
incident at the Ambassador Bridge
highlighted a vulnerability in our
governance model can I just ask you to
go slowly when you're reading for the
interpreters uh
thank you for the reminder the city of
Windsor is certainly responsible for
local infrastructure and the Windsor
Police Service is capable of providing
adequate and effective law enforcement
for our community
that said the need for broader
collaboration and support from
provincial and federal governments to
bolster the Safety and Security of our
borders appears obvious
can you tell the commissioner and and
give us some uh of your thoughts about
what role you think each of the three
levels of government Federal provincial
and municipal
should play in protecting the Ambassador
Bridge
well because of the the construct of the
roadways and the infrastructure that
exists going back 90 years it really is
imperative that we have
you know a three-pronged approach here
every level of government has a role to
play the city has to be an equal partner
and the city respectfully plays a
disproportionate role in trying to
resolve some of these issues like the
issue we're talking about in February
that we need to have these things
coordinated in advance have the
conversation worked out in advance so we
know who's doing what and who's
responsible to fund some of these costs
and so after the fact trying to to get
payment of over five million dollars is
it's it's frustrating to be honest but
you know we need to have these things
worked out and the response that we
provided during the let's say the week
of the primary week of activity all we
did is respond you know we responded we
we if Jersey barriers someone said
they're 1.3 million dollars how fast can
you get them here was the answer we
wanted to be as responsive as possible
but you know from a city perspective
there is a disproportionate burden uh
and so hosting an international Crossing
like this uh presents some opportunities
for the city from an economic
development perspective but it also puts
a disproportionate burden on the the
residents in the city of Windsor whether
it's noise and air pollution uh whether
it's you know traffic congestion on
Municipal roads and having to fund the
costs of some of these Municipal roads
that fund uh truck traffic to an
international Crossing all of these
things we really need to sit down on the
point of this letter was let's sit down
in advance this may may happen again it
may not happen again but it's probably
worth a few hours of discussion to
figure out how we're going to do this
moving forward so that it is it is you
know pull from the shelf and Implement
as opposed to trying to figure it out in
real time
thank you those are all my questions
[Applause]
thank you any re-examination
let's just very briefly Natalia
Rodriguez for the commission
uh mayor dilkins my friend for jccf had
asked about an annual Marathon I believe
that takes place that closes the bridge
in its entirety is that right that's
correct and
um I just wanted to better understand
how the closure of the bridge for that
purpose affects the just-in-time
delivery that you had spoken about in
your earlier testimony I I would submit
that it really has no impact because
this event has been happening for
decades it happens on a Sunday morning I
believe generally and the closure is
very early in the morning say seven
o'clock for a defined period of time and
so Runners will will start the race in
Detroit run across the Ambassador Bridge
run down Municipal streets in the city
of Windsor run back through the Winds of
Detroit tunnel back to the United States
and so everything is planned coordinated
organized and it's very time limited and
so it it with respect to local industry
they're able to adjust and adapt for
that very time limited period it is a
Time limited period more than 24 hours
oh no no we're talking the matter of
maybe two hours I see okay thank you
that that does help clarify
um and I just wanted to also clarify uh
the communications that you had with the
premier and solicitor general Jones over
this period of time my understanding is
that you had one phone call with each of
them is that correct
uh
no I think I had two phone calls
um but they were they were all quick you
know it was just everyone was busy I was
trying to give information so they had
situational awareness pass up the
information that I knew was coming you
know through other channels like the
number of officers and both the the
premier I think I've said this but the
premier the solicitor general Minister
Mendocino the Prime Minister all
extremely receptive understood the issue
we're well briefed and certainly you
know it was it was very good
communication from my perspective with
the two orders of government and with
respect to the premier specifically we
know you had a discussion with him on
February 9 it's in the institutional
report when would the second phone call
have taken place
I can't remember if it was just a text
or whether it was a quick phone call in
and around the time the injunction was
granted
and with solicitor general Jones my
understanding is that there was also one
phone call around the 7th or 8th of
February to discuss the resource request
is that correct that's correct okay and
aside from that the discussions would
have been over text message
fine
I I thought there was more than one call
with both but I just can't be sure and
it's it's it's a function of the volume
of what was happening they were very
quick touch points uh and it was just a
matter of sharing information very
quickly these were not long phone calls
uh it was in an effort for me to share
what I knew and you know the premiere
was excellent in terms of understanding
the impact on the business Community he
relayed that to me and both of them were
great to deal with
anything else that you can tell us about
the content of those discussions other
than what you've told us nothing else to
add and I understand you also had a
discussion with the Prime Minister on
February 10 is that right that's correct
and uh did he initiate that call or did
you
uh I I
can't remember who initiated it I mean
it was set up uh and I know our federal
member had asked and and you know there
was lots of things going on behind the
scenes uh but I was told the prime
minister is going to call at a certain
time on that date so
I was by the phone waiting for the phone
call and what can you tell us about the
content of that discussion uh we talked
about what was happening on the ground
in the city of Windsor we talked about
the battery Factory and and uh
you know the work that was being done
uh and the Prime Minister understood
very clearly what the impact was he
knows the city of Windsor he understood
what the impact was with that particular
closure as it related to the Ambassador
Bridge and the importance of the
Ambassador Bridge uh and he was very
supportive in conversation about trying
to find a resolution that got us all
past this particular point in time and
got things back to normal and was the
emergencies act discussed in that call
either by you or by him no not at all
the prime minister mentioned in that
call that you know there may be
something coming with respect to the
United States that would make folks who
participated in these types of
activities perhaps make them
inadmissible to enter the United States
uh and I think that was enunciated in
the in the readout of the call but no
discussion nor was the emergencies act
ever mentioned in that call okay thank
you
now with respect to my friend from the
city of Ottawa you told her that at some
point somebody did indicate to you that
the normal order of operations would be
to go to the opp or the province for
resources first and then to the RCMP or
the federal government can you tell us
who who indicated that to you and at
what point in time in terms of the the
resource request it came up in a
conversation with Minister Mendocino
but I didn't you know when when I mean I
I knew that there was that was the order
of operations he knew that was the order
of operations so we had a quick
discussion about that and I I relayed to
him that my primary concern was getting
the resources here on the ground so the
response could be provided I never felt
like the federal government was sitting
on their hands and not wanting to act uh
in any way I always got the sense that
they were very receptive and trying to
be a partner and trying to solve the
situation and to find resources that
would be helpful so there was no sense
that RCMP resources could be delayed as
a result of having gone to the opp first
for example I never felt that way no one
ever enunciated that and I I don't
believe that to be true okay thank you
um and finally my friend
um for I believe former Chief slowly
spoke to you about the in-camera board
meetings that you had I just want to I
want to clarify who requested that these
meetings be held in camera
uh I did you did I did and why was that
because I anticipated that police would
feel more comfortable to share
operational details that we would not
want to be in the public forum and I
also wanted the board members to feel
comfortable to ask any question of the
chief or the administration that they
felt needed to be asked and and so in
camera was the best place to do that and
I you know I thought it was right then
and I I think it's right now thank you
very much those are my questions
okay well uh mayor delegates thank you
very much for your uh your testimony uh
you're free to go and yes sir very
appreciated thank you
okay next uh Witness
I think you have a procedural uh matter
to deal with first yes uh commissioner
Eric bruso commission Council for the
record uh before we call the next
witness I just want to
um formally table the bulk entry list
from last week which some may have
noticed was not tabled the list being
entered today was first circulated on
October 24th we asked parties for their
objections by 5 PM on November 1st
commission Council received those
objections removed those doc IDs from
the list and the final list consists of
250 documents identified by commission
Council working on
the police aspect of the commission's
mandate as with the prior lists emails
plans a number of documents which we did
not have time to put to the witnesses
and as well there were 92 documents
identified by commission Council working
on the protester aspect of the
commission's mandate
largely documents produced by the the
Convoy organizers group but other
commission documents Ops jcf and a few
other parties so those now will be sort
of formally tagged and marked as
exhibits
and I also just want to speak very
briefly about the process for resolving
the objections which the parties were
advised of this morning going forward
commission Council will be using a
revised template to send out the doc IDs
each week
we will continue to give a week's sort
of notice and opportunity to review the
documents
by 5 PM the following Monday we will ask
for the parties to put their objections
in writing within that Excel spreadsheet
we will as commission Council put them
together and then try to deal with them
directly with the party who has objected
and if not
commission Council will embed their
their responses within that sheet which
will then be up to you commissioner to
sort of make a decision on the
admissibility the default will be that
it will be done in writing so parties
are being encouraged to put their
submissions as fulsomely as they'd like
in that Excel oral hearings will be sort
of exceptional subject to your
discretion this is the process which we
will use starting today for for this
week's bulk entry
and at some point we'll communicate a
timeline for dealing with all of the
objections which have accrued to date
so I just wanted to put that on the
record and now I'd like to call the
commission's next witness which is
Deputy Chief Crowley of the Windsor
Police Service
thank you
[Music]
deputy chief Crowley well you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm it's a Bible please
thank you
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Jason Crowley
j-a-s-o-n-c-r-o-w-l-e-y
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God I do so
swear thank you
good afternoon deputy chief Crowley good
afternoon
what is your current rank with the
Windsor Police Service I am the interim
Deputy Chief of operations
okay and
um that's not the same rank that you
held in January and February that's
correct sir I was uh superintendent of
Investigation Services at the time okay
um and I had asked the clerk to pull up
your witness statement which is
wts6017 you'll recall uh sitting for an
interview with commission Council this
this summer that's correct okay and you
reviewed this witness statement
um before it was finalized yes okay and
do you have any corrections uh that
you'd like to make to it uh there is one
uh small correction on page three okay
if we could go to that please
I think it's near the bottom
uh the very last paragraph it says
protesters block the lanes that lead to
the Ambassador Bridge they actually
protest or they actually block these
southbound Lanes away from the Bridge
originally that's the only correction
okay
thank you everything else remains
accurate to your knowledge yes yeah
um
and I'm also going to ask that the
Windsor Police Service institutional
report be pulled up that is
wps.ir dot 701
and you've reviewed this in uh in
preparing to attend today yes sir right
and uh does that remain accurate uh
there are a couple clarifications if I
could absolutely
um just you just let Mr clerk know which
page uh paragraph 23 sir please
more of a clarification it says the
public order units were were from the
opp and Waterloo service started to
arrive on the ninth I believe can you
scroll down just a little bit please
yes on the ninth yeah
um so they did it was like a slowly
through the night they they weren't
deployed that night uh they were just
slowly arriving uh amongst other uh
agencies as well but uh that was just a
clarification they all didn't show up on
the ninth okay
uh the other uh clarification is uh
paragraph 58
so essentially uh the public order unit
was uh moving southbound down here in
church uh this paragraph refers to that
and it talks about uh the uh more uh
other secondary group of officers
traveling Northbound if you could scroll
down please
uh to the southbound in the southbound
Lanes of Huron Church to move the crowd
eastbound onto Tecumseh Road so that was
the eventual movement once they hit
Tecumseh Road that was the movement
towards the on Tecumseh Road towards uh
the East
um it just those two roads intersect as
we know so I just want to clarify that
that's all okay thank you and that is it
and the rest remains accurate that's
correct okay
um now so in your role at the time as
superintendent of Investigation Services
what did that entail I oversaw the
entire division in investigations so
everything from the investigative side
of the house
which involved includes major crime and
uh property crime right over to the
support side of the investigations so
the drug units and
um you know I bent things like that so
that was my uh
designation at the time I also was the
uh
in charge of our critical incident
demand program
and I oversaw that as well okay and so
you're trained as a critical incident
Commander yes I am I understand you were
appointed as one of the two critical
incident commanders from WPS for this
incident that's correct
um and at the time of the convoys did
WPS have any public order unit trained
officers no we did not
how about uh police liaison team no we
did not we had critical Instinct uh
sorry we had uh critical negotiators
critical instant negotiators but not uh
PLT per se okay and and we heard mayor
dilkins this morning explaining to us a
little bit about
jurisdiction but perhaps you can just
sort of refresh us and help us in terms
of what WPS is responsible to police
versus the RCMP versus the opp in this
sort of Windsor area so the Windsor
Police
would be responsible for municipleicing
within the boundaries of Windsor uh
there is an opp uh presence on the
provincial highways that lead into
Windsor which I believe now
includes the Herbert Parkway which is
the extension of the 401 to the new
bridge
and the RCMP they do have a presence
that is more I believe customs and
excise things like that with when it
comes to International
um responsibilities but nothing as far
as Municipal policing goes at all okay
and so when an incident occurs on the
bridge
who responds
The Windsor Police do
I want to ask you a little bit about the
intelligence leading up to the blockade
now I understand there were a number of
slow roll protests that had come through
Windsor previously is that correct
that's correct
when did those start
I started months before the bridge uh
blockade months we we were dealing with
them on a weekly basis uh all over the
city uh but the ones uh pertain to the
bridge uh really we we were well like
made aware of them
um that weekend they were going to be
ramped up which would have been the uh
fourth fifth and sixth
okay so before that
um there had been slow rolls in the
Windsor area but nothing that targeted
the bridge that's perfectly
okay and how long had these slow rolls
lasted typically
um typically they would be you know last
two or three hours we would assign a
certain group of officers to basically
monitor it manage it uh they were never
any issues typically uh the the slow
rollers were um
typically they were cooperative and we
would work with them prior to the Slow
Roll we would reach out to them to
ensure that they
um you know if we could do something for
them essentially uh as in facilitate
their route
or things like that but we would try and
reach out to the organizers to
to maintain that uh communication piece
okay
um now you're familiar with the terms
project Hendon and the Hendon reports
yes I am
you were receiving those directly from
the opp uh yes
but I did have I I was not responsible
for monitoring Hendon I had an inspector
that was responsible inspector Carl
DeGraff who was on those calls daily or
or as much as they were happening
anyways and he was responsible for in
taking those Hendon reports and updating
me on any pertinent information okay did
you did you read them
when you receive them no I read them on
inspector graphs um
recommendation okay
would you have discussed most of the
Hendon reports with inspector DeGraff on
a daily basis yes and and particularly
when Windsor was
uh mentioned but that wasn't very often
at the very beginning of Hendon okay and
um did you
brief deputy chief Belair or chief
Mizuno on the reports yes anything I
thought they needed to be aware of I
would certainly bring that to their
attention Okay so I'd like to bring up
the Hendon report for January 31st which
is OPP
50819 and this if we can go to page
three
looking for Point 13
. this is an like I said from the 31st
so Point 13 says open source information
suggests that truck drivers from the
United States plan to block the American
side of the Ambassador Bridge in Windsor
to coincide with Canadian drivers
blocking the bridge in Windsor the
available information does not include a
date or time so do you recall seeing
that at the time I think I do yes okay
and
what uh what steps did the Windsor
Police take to prepare for that
possibility
um again these are this is our best
source of intelligence so uh we would
obviously
um meet and discuss potential blockages
but there was also reports saying that
numerous Bridges might be blocked so we
would basically just uh keep that
intelligence handy I was on the I still
am actually on the uh Ontario
Association of chiefs of police
emergency preparedness committee and
this is these are the things that were
discussed during almost a daily meeting
on those that committee
okay
um
would this information have gone to the
opp from Windsor Police or this is
coming to you through the Hendon report
and you're sort of learning of it for
the first time
um this was being learned about for the
first time essentially so there was if I
can take you back to that time you can
imagine uh Ottawa was uh you know just
starting to um
gain some traction and and the
protesters had just rolled in here we
were dealing with protests in Toronto as
a committee on the weekends at Queen's
Park so that a lot of the discussion
went there and this this intelligence
and this information uh wasn't really uh
at the Forefront at this time in that
um now a few days later sort of skipping
ahead to February 3rd I believe you told
us this Summer that
The Windsor Police learned through
monitoring social media that there was a
slow roll planned for the coming weekend
is that correct that's correct okay
um and at that point in time was there
an indication of a blockade on February
3rd
just what I had previously mentioned
about
um you know potential Bridge or border
crossing blockades but nothing that I
recall that was specific to February 3rd
okay and um
from what I understand at that point
perhaps it was a little bit more serious
and chief Mizuno actually sort of puts
you in charge of the Windsor Police
Services response to that intended Slow
Roll is that correct that's correct
okay and what did that response look
like
um at this point I uh I met with our
Patrol inspectors
I asked for an operational plan from
them regarding the slow rolls they seem
to have more traction and and be a
bigger uh
um a bigger entity than we have been
dealing with so I was asking for a an
operational plan
um I also and started to include members
of the bridge so cbsa the bridge company
was there contact so indirectly they
were involved
um our intelligence unit I
included them quite a bit so this is the
day that meetings really started about
um okay we're going to deal with these
slow rolls
but what if
this is where these conversations
started okay and what was the plan I
mean you mentioned what if what was the
plan if
the slow rolls just blocked the bridge
well this was the problem
um
so
I think it's been discussed prior to
this about the difference between
intelligence and information
intelligence was very was was limited in
my view at this point about
a confirmation of a blockade or a slow
roll that would bear hug the bridge to
me I was more information at this point
still didn't didn't explain how they
would do it how it would be done and
what we could do to to stop it uh I
think what we really we're thinking at
the time this bear hug idea if you can
recall the geography of the bridge
it's essentially the road is a circle
around the entire Bridge property and
they talked about the bear hug and if
that essentially if Vehicles went around
the bridge and stopped that would
essentially shut down the bridge
so that's kind of where we were thinking
that might happen
so we tried to put some
mitigating plans in place there for that
okay and if I could just stop you there
for a second
um because we've talked about slow rolls
and how the Windsor Police Service you
know took steps to facilitate those in
the weeks leading up to it
um
I mean
section 132 of the highway traffic act
prohibits unnecessarily slow driving and
so a slow roll in
depending on the speed would be contrary
to the highway traffic act correct
correct and so why was it that the
Windsor Police Service was
to use your words for facilitating those
protests
so we were of the mindset amongst other
police services in the in the province
we were trying to find that balance of
uh people's ability and and uh right
under the charter to protest
we felt it was better to work with
um the protesters to facilitate their
slow roles it maintained Public Safety
which is what we were concerned about
um and uh we did not certainly want to
escalating a situation and it was in the
model of way slow roles were being
policed
throughout the province
if we could pull up OPP
50825 I'm taking you to the Hendon
report dated February 4th
and Mr clerk if we go to page six
there's a section
entitled Ontario open source information
media and social media
and so this right there
the second Point commercial truck
drivers and supporters May conduct slow
rolls on roadways near the Ambassador
Bridge over the next three days and may
attempt to block the bridge on February
7th
I think this is the first time that
there's actually a kind of specific date
to a potential blockade is that right
that's correct okay and in light of this
information in this hand and Report uh
what steps were taken to to prepare
so
not on different to
um other slow roles we were in
communication with the organizer
very Cooperative worked with the police
supportive of our involvement we had no
issues with this slow roll group this
for that weekend
but as the weekend progressed this
intelligence became a little bit more
solid I would say uh and that's when
um by the Sunday which would have been
the sixth we started to gain more
information about
this date being legitimate of blocking
the bridge
again the the problem we ran into was
how how are we going how are they going
to block the bridge we had no
intelligence again the geography of the
bridge is very porous as critical
infrastructure in the in the middle of
our our west end with side streets and
access to the bridge exits to the bridge
it's it's uh it's not as easy as a
one-way in one way out so we were trying
to make considerations for numerous
plans but nothing was in stone because
we didn't know what we didn't know fair
enough I'd like to take you to the the
operational plan for dealing with the
slow roll now which is uh
wps401883 although it might actually be
five zeros I think WPS has used nine
digits
and so I think this is the operational
plan that you had asked be put together
on February 4th for the slow rolls
you'll you'll be able to tell me if
that's correct yes that's correct that's
it if we go down to page two on the
situation
um
in the middle of the paragraph
there's further mention of the ongoing
protests slash blockade situation at
Coots Alberta Port of Entry with
intention to mirror this type of
activity at in Windsor at The Ambassador
Bridge Port of Entry and if we can go
down to the execution on the same page
the fourth point
they will be utilizing this route for
three days and then consider Ambassador
Bridge blockade on February 7th 2022 and
so I I mean I think there was pretty
clear evidence as of the fourth that the
seventh was going to be the the day of a
blockade if one was going to occur is
that right that's correct okay
and so what kind of um
assistance did Windsor Police Service
seek at that point
so that weekend
um was very busy reaching out to
numerous uh Partners so locally it was
the chief of fire Windsor fire rescue
Steve Lafayette is also Bruce Crowder
from our emergency medical EMS
um
again I already said we spoke with cbsa
those kind of plans started logistically
again what if this happens what do we
need to do to help our our partners we
believed right from this point it was a
police response so we certainly were
trying to help out our partners as best
we can to plan for them as well as us
okay and I understand
um that Chief Mizuno spoke with
commissioner karik of the opp on
February 4th as well yes that's correct
and do you know I I don't I don't think
you're on that call but did Chief Mizuno
relate to you what was discussed uh I
think in the email there was there was
some discussion about
um I was not on that call sorry to
clarify that uh there was some
discussion about getting some local
assistance from the opp from uh the two
detachments within our area uh some for
some help uh also uh sending some public
liaison officers of PLT down to Windsor
to assist us on Monday those were the
discussions of potentially maybe having
35 officers or so come and help us and
at that point it was strictly to uh for
for Traffic Control intersection control
that kind of things to set up a
perimeter that we felt was manageable
Okay so
on the fourth the intention was to be
setting up a perimeter to try to prevent
the blockade
yes essentially like so to prevent the
blockade to manage a slow roll all these
things that again we didn't have
specifics where we could plan a specific
response to a specific action by by
protesters
but certainly we uh we were trying to do
um a very general response to be able to
react to something that could possibly
happen okay I take it you didn't have a
Time on the seventh you didn't know
anything more than something might
materialize on the seventh yes the
information I had was that
um the bridge would be blocked if they
didn't get what they want meaning relief
of vaccine mandates things like that
that was the only information
information I had about Monday
uh I'd like to take you to I think
probably one of the emails you just
mentioned which is wps501880
this is an email exchange between
yourself and someone named white tibb of
the opp who is Dwight tip Dwight FIB is
the chief superintendent of the region
so as a result of Chief mizuno's
conversation with the commissioner
um
I spoke to uh Dwight who you can see
here that she or that he uh
he put me in touch with Dana eerley who
was the superintendent of the region one
of the superintendents for the opp
basically saying if you need something
please don't hesitate and uh he's super
he's seen superintendent Dana yearly who
oversees their Emergency Response Team
and
he says in this email as discussed you
can continue to liaise with our Essex
Detachment command team yes should Intel
be received or action by demonstrators
taken to shut down the bridge don't
hesitate to reach out yes that original
discussion with the Essex Detachment
command team was
um more of an information sharing
session at that point and um they were
going to monitor the 401 for us but
exactly what uh what the intention there
was to continue just discussing with
them okay and at this point I guess what
I'm trying to understand even on the
fourth there is a a threat of a blockade
on the seventh and the response is at
the local OPP Detachment level nothing
that kind of was escalated above that
from a resource perspective that's
correct I would call those like informal
requests
okay
and I think you mentioned earlier that
there were 35 officers dispatched as
part of that approximately yes those
would have all come from the Essex
Detachment Essex and Lakeshore and and
anywhere that might be close to those
okay I'm assuming I can't say for sure
but I would assume
and your um your summary of our
interview this summer mentions that you
spoke with a cbsa officer and our CMP
officer at border Integrity officer on
that day as well what can you tell us
about that that's correct so my first
call was to
a chief superintendent RCMP officer in
London
who put me in touch with uh Kevin
McGonagall who is a border Integrity
officer I believe he's also out of
London but he was the closest contact
for for me as far as the RCMP goes as as
the Border uh it pertains to the Border
so I spoke with Kevin and um basically
said you know they their resources were
stretched then because of other
potential threats to other borders uh in
the province but certainly they had
people on call
that they would assist as needed or as
could be
okay neither of them were neither the
cbsa nor the RCMP were
taking steps to prepare for it like the
blockade uh not at that time in speaking
with cbsa I asked them if they had an
operational plan I believe on the Friday
the 4th and they didn't they were
referencing Coots as well because uh
the Coots blockade was not on the border
property it was down the road similar to
ours so they were they were just trying
to work with us in a response and help
us in any way they can
okay
um
I'd like to take you to another Hendon
report dated February 6th that's
opp401622
and on page six
um there's
again a reference to the a possible
attempt to block the Ambassador Bridge
so this is we're now February 6 is the
the Sunday
what steps were being taken that weekend
to prepare the fifth the sixth as the
the information still says yep Monday
There's likely to be a blockade so and
again we didn't know we didn't know uh
with with the the geography that
presents itself to us the bridge is very
difficult to to uh plan something solid
that we don't know what's going to
happen or how it's going to happen I
should say we did discuss
um as was suggested earlier about you
know potentially rerouting traffic off
401 closing
the 401 which just was not an option
coming into the city
um so there was all kinds of discussions
on how we might be able to do it
um but essentially we thought if we
could control that intersection around
the bridge
that again we were within the mindset of
this bear hug if we control the
intersection limited vehicle traffic
through it we would be able to
essentially control access to the bridge
okay and we'll um we'll talk about that
in a moment okay uh but that evening of
the sixth there was a slow roll protest
at McMac Park correct yes and what
happened there uh that was the first uh
noticeable difference in any of the slow
rules that we'd had uh there was a
little bit more aggression by the uh
protesters at mcmack Park there was a a
fair number of them
and uh that was the first time that like
officers had to actually disengage some
of the protesters because of the
aggression that they showed
disengage from the protesters yes okay
okay again we're trying not to escalate
things uh we're trying to plan you know
knowing what hap is going on in Ottawa
at the time and includes we're trying
not to escalate anything and work with
as all the previous other uh the
previous slow roles we're trying to work
with the protesters
um and also at this time we are also
planning for information we had received
was for the next morning uh a potential
gathering at a combo rest stop which is
about
25 minutes outside of Windsor off the
401 there's a truck stop
and we were potentially uh planning for
this Gathering so we had a plan for our
surveillance team to go out
as well as the opp they were going to be
there and try and engage the truckers to
see what their their plan was and their
intentions were that morning
um they mentioned
by this point you had seen what was
going on in Ottawa so you can just pause
there briefly and tell us what
up to the sixth uh what what lessons The
Windsor Police Service had taken away
from what had been going on in Ottawa
for
uh 10 days by then so I think um
like to be honest at this point we were
so
um involved in our in our planning and
what we've been doing I can't say that
uh there was a you know
a lot of takeaways at this point from
Ottawa but certainly we knew about
private property
uh
engaging our our partners and our our
business owners at this point about uh
who is willing to have protesters on
their property near their Bridge so we
didn't have to waste
any kind of valuable time in the in the
moment
um again dealing with uh protest
leadership was a was a big one and also
um we we knew a strong command team had
to be set up okay and those are all
you're saying those are all lessons you
had taken away from what had been going
on for 10 days yes so and part of it was
because of
um this emergency planning committee
that I sit on a lot of the uh other
police leaders were in Ottawa
um you know could see some of the issues
they were going through as it went to
planning and things like that so I I
realized that this was a a large piece
of what we needed to to accomplish
I'd like to pull up WPS I think it's
five six zeros two two one
these are some emails early in the
morning between
um deputy chief Belair and chief Mizzou
now I will ask you about them
we're still on the on the seventh
uh Chief Mizuno emails deputy chief
Belair if we know uh when they are
coming and where from any thought to
stopping the Convoy and negotiating some
terms before they reach the bridge
sounds like they want the transports to
lead the Convoy with everyone following
so there may be an opportunity to try to
control it and then deputy chief Belair
says yes talking to JC about that exact
thing I assume JC is
so what can you tell us about these
attempts at negotiation the morning that
the Convoy is descending upon Windsor so
this was one of the major
um
uh differences from Ottawa again we
assumed a lot seeing what we had seen
here this is not so at Comber that
morning there was some trucks which
there always are going to be trucks at
the truck stop but there was more
pedestrian cars than we expected we had
information again that there was convoys
sitting in concession roads off the 401
hiding waiting to to to join the the
the trip down the 401 which never
materialized but it was something we
thought okay the information that's what
that's what's happening
um but the main difference was it wasn't
all semis it was a lot of pedestrian
Vehicles pickup trucks with Flags uh and
at this point when when we were there we
don't know who a protester is
uh at that point other than you know
people with flags for instance so it was
very difficult to even determine who is
a protester and who's just driving down
the 401 essentially so stopping a convoy
uh just wasn't as easy as it sounded
okay and
I understand that ultimately there were
sort of multiple groups of protesters
that set up in Windsor was that
parent at this stage the morning of
February 7th
um I wouldn't say it was as obvious as
it became
at this point like I said we had very
good relationship with the organizer of
the slow rolls
and that was the first that Sunday group
was that first different group that we
said okay there's
a different leadership faction here and
in fact if the original Slow Roll
organizer
um actually uh
pleaded with the other group not to
block the bridge so he we had to develop
that relationship with him to on our
behalf try and plead with him not to do
it so that's the first but it wasn't as
obvious down down the road and did that
that original Slow Roll organizer
ultimately participate in the blockade
of the bridge
I don't believe he did I just can't say
for sure but I don't believe he did yeah
I'd like to go to wps60266
these are emails between yourself
somebody at the RCMP
and
Go Down Kevin McGonagall I think is the
the name that you yes gave us before
so he is writing to you in the morning
of the seventh wanted to check in to see
how things are going in Windsor this
morning as you are aware we are being
requested to support Ottawa with the
situation there we will have to balance
operational response in all of our
border points especially Windsor Sarnia
Erie Etc evaluating what is going on in
those locations will assist with their
decisions so I guess my first question
is what sort of
free February 7th assistance was the
RCMP making available or had they made
available to the Windsor Police Service
at that point it was just a connection
that was made with Kevin and offering if
there's anything they could do let them
know
it was more of an intelligence thing I
think at that point we didn't really
utilize Kevin McGonagall services at
this point
and there's sort of a reference needing
to balance operational response now I'm
just talking about the Convoy protests
in general did that
to that play out in the sense did you
see a an inability or a reticence or
were you told we can only send you X
number of officers because we've got a
police a whole bunch of different
protests the police resources were
spread very thin throughout the province
it was very clear to me
being as a part of the emergency
planning committee it was quite clear
that resources were in high demand
um so yes I saw that quite clearly I
think you told us this summer and it's
in your statement that you attended a
meeting of the Ontario Association of
chiefs of police
committee that that day on the seventh
and you were told effectively the same
thing there's there's a limit to the
number of resources that we have for
Windsor that's correct
and how about
when it came to the OPP at this stage on
the seventh were you being told the same
thing there's you know we can only give
you X number of officers vehicles uh yes
at this point uh the bridge had not been
blocked
so we were
um you know we were okay with uh just
having boots on the ground providing
traffic uh you know
um resources at that point but I had
sent uh Dana yearly an email I believe
the night before or maybe maybe this on
the seventh asking hey if things go A
bit sideways here
how available is is any Pou resources so
that was really my first again informal
ask just to to get an understanding if
we need to look that way what does it
look like for you and what was the
response
um I know I'd have to see the email
exactly what the response was but at
this point Dana was working with us from
London still basically trying to put
resources together I think the response
essentially was uh if you need something
we're going to supply it for you okay
and I think I've got the email you'll
tell me if I'm wrong if we could pull up
WPS 60374
this is an email from February 8th this
may not be the one that you're looking
for but
you reach out to superintendent early
and say hi Dana I received direction
from Aurelia to contact you if our
blockade occurred and began to get to a
point where extra resources may be
required It's relatively manageable
I know your people are very spread out
but I ask at this point is if we were to
need Pou or PLT down here what would
availability be this is the email this
is this correct yep
and again what I don't know that we have
uh her response not in this thread but
what was the response in terms of
availability again I think it was uh you
if you know let us know what you need
and we will try and make arrangements
essentially
in what kind of coordination occurred
with the cbsa at this point once the the
blockade started
um so at the very beginning of it we
were managing the uh the blockade from
our Windsor Police Headquarters in a
project room uh to later in the day we
moved to the EOS EOC and stood it up at
that point
is when I expanded the command team and
invited cbsa to be a part of the command
team so they supplied uh Personnel at
that point to be that direct link uh
with with us to cbsa and they were
providing intelligence and any
information they had along with the
resource at that point
which other organizations were part of
the command team
at this point uh I would say cbsa was
the only external partner that was in
the EOC with us we had expanded our
internal resources to include major
crime at this point we expanded to
include more Intelligence Officers along
with the sergeant that was already in
the command team
and some more resources for Logistics
because we it was growing we needed we
needed some help
if we could pull up wps600235
this is an email with Glenn Miller of
the opp about the availability of the
OPP's PLT for Windsor to Windsor Police
go down to the email at
yeah there sorry uh as the last
paragraph as we speak Brad is reaching
out to Sergeant Mike Acton PLT if he
could have his resources immediately
deployed
to Comber as it's anticipated those in
attendance will be leaving at 1000 hours
so what were the opp PLT
able to reach the uh the protesters
before they set up the blockade
um you know that's a really good
question I don't recall if they did or
not I had never heard of PLT until this
weekend okay uh unbelievably uh and
um I don't recall if they made it or if
it was just regular OPP officers
I'm discussing uh intentions with the
Comber people
ultimately there were OPP PLT deployed
to Windsor yes and I think you told us
this Summer that they had some success
yes that's correct you expand upon that
or elaborate on that uh so in those
first few days when uh we we were really
relying on just essentially you know
mostly Windsor Police resources
we had some difficulty in negotiating
ourselves with with all the protesters
again we talked about the fractured
leadership and different groups
um The BLT how it was explained to me
through local OPP resources where you
know they have relationships with a lot
of people through different protests
across the province they that's their
essentially that's their role to
maintain these relationships and because
of that trust is built and they are able
to
um you know basically fulfill their
mandate with the negotiations with with
uh any kind of demonstration in this
case they were able to and again it was
so Dynamic over the first four or five
days with Lanes closing Lanes opening I
can't tell you times or days but there
was numerous times where lanes were open
and closed but essentially it was PLT
doing that for us they had also brought
in a couple of my minor tactics with
printed pieces of paper for officers in
their notebook for common messaging
handouts for the for the protesters so
it was all about education and
communication with them and they did a
fantastic job
do you know why when they succeeded in
opening a lane or a couple of lanes
those Lanes would then subsequently
re-close or be blockaded again yes so
um
we had the uh
we were monitoring many open source
sources for intelligence we actually
heard a lot of the conversation from the
protesters about their their
conversations about the police on Zello
app
and
um so that was part of it we we could
hear the infighting so somebody would
negotiate a lane open and someone else
would step up and say no way we're
giving not giving this to the police and
their people would come and clog it up
and and then we would hear that right on
ground as well so it was quite obvious
that the leadership was not there's no
solidarity there for sure
uh now I want to move ahead to the
evening of February 7th and there's an
event that happens on the property of
Assumption High School
it's correct can you describe that for
us
um so if I just back up uh to the MonDay
one of my first questions was again when
it comes down to lessons from Ottawa
knowing that the tow truck companies did
not want to participate with the Ottawa
Police or help them that was one of my
first questions are we have a contract
with the company in Windsor and Mike to
inspector Crosby I remember asking her
are they on board and she said she
already asked that question and they
were
so that was good news to us and that
first night
um again the we were trying to keep
protesters off of
private property and Assumption High
School is as the mayor said right in the
protest area on here in church
between Tecumseh and College
we started seeing protest Vehicles go
into the school property parking lot
and we went over there to discuss with
them to you know you're not welcome here
we've already talked to the board you're
not welcome it's time to go and we kind
of gave them an ultimatum saying listen
you have 10 15 minutes to move we're
going to tow you
so we held the tow trucks back out of
sight as best we could again not wanting
to escalate things
um you know and somebody spotted one of
the tow trucks and we had some
altercations or sorry not altercations
um
some of the protesters came out of their
cars with Tire irons and we were at
times not only on this occasion but
almost outnumbered and getting swarmed a
little bit and again having our officers
have to
disengage to not escalate so then they
end up moving after some negotiation but
that was the Assumption High School
incident okay and just
jumping ahead a bunch in the story but
you mentioned wanting to keep protesters
off private property as something that
you had learned from the experience in
Ottawa yes and once the blockade was
cleared my understanding is there was a
decision made within the Windsor Police
Service not to
set up an alternative protest site on on
private property or sort of away from
Huron Church Road and that that was also
a sort of lesson drawn from Ottawa
that's correct so can you tell us what
what that lesson is and why that
decision was made
um so under the trespass the property
Act
uh we cannot remove someone from private
property without uh we we act as an
agent for the owner if they are not uh
if they're willing to have someone go to
their property uh and not be removed
then the police are uh have no Authority
there to remove them so we did not want
to give any kind of
you know spot for the protesters to to
basically uh congregate
um essentially right there at Tecumseh
Road we have a very large parking lots
there's a grocery store and and numerous
a strip mall essentially so it's a very
big parking lot so that could have
really led to some
some um you know another protest area
essentially uh plus we had smaller
businesses uh the cab company all these
places that we just did not want to
interfere with business any more than we
already had and keep things under
control
okay so there was no
um
there was no option to continue
protesting in the way that had been the
case once the the blockade was cleared
that's correct
sort of going back in time to the
establishment of the blockade can you
tell us
how that unfolded the evening of the
seventh
so we had carried through with the plan
that we had talked about with trying to
control the intersection of college and
here in church which is the first
intersection south of the entrance to
the bridge
and what we did we established control
of it with um
traffic officers our traffic enforcement
officers by basically just letting two
or three cars go at a time and if they
went on the bridge and crossed then we'd
let another two or three so that's how
we controlled it for quite a while
actually
same with coming off the bridge we would
try and do that best we can we could and
then
um I think doing that for some time it
was frustrating the protesters again
we're listening to open source media
and they were getting frustrated with us
uh so I think the comment was one of
them basically said I wonder what
happens if I just stop my truck right
here in the southbound Lanes
and that's what happened uh best truck
stopped a pickup truck stopped
I would say to 300 meters south of
college another one stopped and another
one stopped and next thing you know all
three lanes were blocked and that's how
it started so from there
the traffic started to block up or clog
up very quickly and within probably 20
minutes there was a line of semi trucks
that were just regular commuters for
industry uh
creating a line of trucks miles into
Detroit and Michigan
so that's how it started
and I understand early in the blockade a
number of trucks sort of stranded on the
bridge is that right how were they
cleared how and why
so the why would be uh you know people
were stuck on this bridge for hours the
the bridge is almost 100 years old so we
were worried about structural Integrity
of the bridge uh we were worried about
Commerce we were worried about people
having no
um you know food water uh you know
washrooms being up on the bridge we want
to get that bridge cleared off
um so the the how was very difficult so
again the geography of the bridge
there's one main entrance that comes out
onto Huron Church Road which is
Southbound
there's a secondary entrance or exit
sorry if I said entrance the first time
I'm in exit there's a secondary exit
that turns to the West
and goes up a small Road part of Huron
church beside the bridge towards
Wyandotte and then the only other access
to the bridge is uh off of Wyandotte
Street it's an entrance
so at that point again very Dynamic
there was blockages at all three at
times so we were some at points we were
using an entrance on the north side of
the bridge for exiting we were trying to
get out that secondary exit which was
impossible because cars and trucks had
clog that small section of of Huron
church just west of the bridge almost
instantly
there was a decision made at one point
by myself to allow
trucks access to college westbound which
I didn't want to do because that was our
our emergency route for fire because
they their their fire station is just
east of Huron church and if protesters
clogged College we're in a bad way but
there was no there was just no other
decision to make at that point we
literally had to do what we could to
clear that bridge
so and again with negotiations through
all that to allow us to essentially you
know open this part open that part to
eventually clear the bridge and I think
the bridge was cleared of traffic by
about 10 20 at night
so they were up there a while
I want to pull up WPS six zeros three
five six this is an email
from February 7th and it's regarding the
Ambassador Bridge Corporation
in the the president of the corporation
so you're not you're not on it
um but Gary Williams sent an email to uh
looks like
um Murphy I don't know if you know who
that is Mark Murphy is an inspector our
petroleum
um and it's essentially relaying a
conversation that Gary Williams has had
with the president of the Ambassador
Bridge Corp and Mark says I will forward
to the graph and Crowley to deal with
thanks for the heads up so first of all
did you get that email and sort of deal
with it I don't know if I got this email
but I definitely got a message either
directly from Murphy or from our
communication Center or 911 Center that
this call was coming into them as well
uh the bridge company wasn't happy with
us I think they thought we were blocking
the bridge
and we were just trying to tell them we
are doing the best we can and my
question to them was have you stopped
lighting trucks on the bridge
uh because that just wouldn't help us to
continue to let trucks on the bridge so
at some point they started routing
traffic to the Blue Water Bridge which
at this point had no issues there so do
you know why they thought Windsor Police
was blocking the bridge I don't have a
clue
and how uh what was this your only sort
of com contact with the company or did
the Ambassador Bridge Corporation
you know weigh in or or sort of get in
touch with Windsor Police throughout
that week yeah I can't say I I didn't
have any more conversation or contact
with the bridge company at that point I
was my only
my only contact with them okay do you
know if anyone uh do you know if Chief
Mizuno or deputy chief Belair did no I
don't no and how about just again
generally speaking other interests
unions uh there was some evidence this
morning about stalantis this this new EV
battery manufacturer I think but what
was the sort of economic pressure like
from the businesses in Windsor
um so being in the EOC uh I mean we were
approximately 10 kilometers away from
the bridge
so like I was getting reports but to be
all honesty the pressure that we felt
just knowing the impact of of what was
going on in the EOC was was enormous
pressure we we felt that we we wanted to
do more but we were so uh handcuffed at
this point with what was going on uh but
certainly
um
um you know just reports in in
mainstream media and the economic uh uh
impacts we knew it was was humongous it
was just Giant
so is it fair to say I mean you were
aware from reading the news that this
was having an impact but
you weren't personally aware of pressure
being exerted on the Windsor Police
Service today no that was not in my in
my realm at that point but growing up in
Windsor I grew up my whole life I
understand the the the essence of of
what how important that bridge is to our
our community and our country to be
honest so it's not lost on me the the
impact that that would have
okay I'd like to go to
wps609 so move ahead to Wednesday
February 9th
this is an email from you to Jen Crosby
and inspector to Graf
saying I was asked by Jay to put
something together together to present
to the opp for a request for a hundred
officers to assist and include how why
what Etc
further down that paragraph the 100
officer request does not include Pou and
so the attachment which is the next
number 610
and I so I assume when you say I was
asked by Jay that's um deputy chief
Belair
uh no I think that was me
sorry I think you were writing that if
we can just pull that back oh sorry you
were writing that you sent that email
okay sorry then that would be WG player
at the time yes
and So you you're the one who
spearheaded kind of putting together
okay here's the numbers we're going to
request and here's how they're going to
be used is that right uh the background
of that uh actually was before the sorry
that was on the ninth before that I had
uh received a call on the 8th uh at
about 6 30 in the morning from
superintendent Mike mcdonell from the
opp who I was a colleague with on the
emergency preparedness committee
and he obviously had seen on the news
what was going on and he asked me uh
what we needed
and I just told him we need some bodies
so his his ask to me was uh and this was
over time this was not on that first
conversation he said he would talk to
the commissioner but again informal
request here right this is a
superintendent asking another
superintendent uh it's in a formal
request
um he is so within time he gets back to
me and says I I need a plan
uh what you're going to do with hundred
officers and I understood that uh just
to ask for 100 officers so I put
together a very generic plan uh
considering there was two you know
24-hour coverage two 12-hour shifts
essentially
um and we are also policing a very busy
City uh with our own resources
and resources for the bridge so that was
really my ask and and I put together
this uh very generic plan for them okay
and
and just so I want to make sure I
understood correctly it was MacDonald
who suggested the hundred officer figure
to you no he he asked me what we needed
and you know just just literally doing
the quick math kind of right there I
said I could probably use 100 officers
and he asked me for a plan well I need
to know what you need 100 officers for I
said no problem okay and so this
document that we're looking at on the
screen is was the plan for how you're
going to use the 100 officers yeah I
think so yep if we could just scroll
down just so you see all of it yeah I
would say it is yep
and if this is being put together with
not knowing anything about the OPP's
Collective agreements what shifts they
work what you know I came to found out
over find out over time
how this is very normal for them and
they all expect deployments like this
and you know this is very normal so but
this is at a time where I you know I'm
trying not to step on another
organization's collective bargaining
agreement and to try and you know
satisfy our needs as well so
we saw in the covering email that this
doesn't include Pou units why would you
have left those out of this request
um I think this was still fairly early
in this in sense of this conversation
happened essentially less than 24 hours
after the bridge was blocked
um so again our plan at the time was to
negotiate we had set up a perimeter and
to negotiate with them and at the time
uh this is we we thought hopefully we
could get there at the end of it through
negotiation
again not trying to escalate anything
see but that's why you know my my
background told me three days before to
ask Dana hey if it goes this way
um what are we looking at
but but that was not in the plan yet
and again knowing what was going on here
and in Toronto so
and so this
um exchange is between this this arises
as a result of your discussion with
superintendent Mack DaNell but you're
aware on the same day Chief Mizuno sent
letters to uh Minister Jones the
solicitor general in Ontario and to Bill
Blair Minister Blair correct I was not
aware of that at that time okay I I in
preparing for this I found that out and
I'm assuming that that ask was the
formal ask because of this
but I can't confirm that I don't know so
and again just so we understand on
February 9th uh
Chief Mizuno did not consult you or make
you aware that she was writing to those
two politicians asking for a hundred uh
officers I don't recall that she did
though okay
now if we could pull up um wps600827
and so apart from seeing the letters do
you remember any discussion with Chief
Mizuno or deputy chief Belair at the
time about those that correspondence to
uh to Sylvia Jones or Bill Blair no I
don't recall that at all I there I was
sending situation reports to them
regularly
um and there there may have been
conversations back and forth but I don't
recall them to be honest
so I'm showing you an email and again
you're not on this email um
but it's it's an email in which
commissioner Creek of the opp is writing
to commissioner lucky of the RCMP
and it's subsequent to Chief mizuno's
emails and letters to the ministers says
Chief Pam Mizuno and I had an
opportunity to discuss the attached
correspondence
currently Windsor Police does not
require the deployment of additional
police officers from the opp or the RCMP
and so I what I'm trying to understand
is do you know why the about face I mean
that morning Chief Mizuno had said we
need 100 officers sent the letters
directly to the ministers and then that
evening it's according to commissioner
karik's email it's
everything's fine yeah I can't explain
this I did not know about this when it
happened I mean if you look at the time
it's 11 20 at night on the 9th
um I was working straight midnight at
that point
um and if I would have known this at the
time I you know I I understand there was
mass confusion to a situation that we've
never dealt with
so I can't explain this email I did not
know about at the time
and we heard this morning
for mayor dilkens that there might have
been some some issue or confusion over
going to the opp and the RCMP and that
the proper channel is to go to the opp
first was that something that you were
made aware of around this time
um no but the the
um the police services Act of Ontario is
quite clear that if we can't provide our
own
for instance in this case public order
unit
we need to go to the opp and our
directive our policy says that as well
so
and Q deputy chief commissioner as I
believe you know the balance of the
examination will be completed by my
colleague Guillaume
um I don't uh we're sort of 15 minutes
prior to the break I don't know if you'd
like uh
you know to start now
or take the break early
yeah this might be a good time to take
the break then if you're going to change
counseling so we'll take the afternoon
break for 15 minutes
thank you deputy chief
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
you know
um
order a lot
the commission is reconvened the
commissioner Brown
good afternoon I'm Yom so welcome
Mission Council
um
I will be reading you from the events of
February 10th
um uh in the morning of February 10th
this is when superintendent data early
from the opp arrived in Windsor that's
correct
um I would like to pull up WTS .00022
while it's being pulled up I'll
just summarize what's mentioned that's
done at earliest Windows summary
at page three
um
second paragraph at the top
she mentioned that
upon arriving in Windsor
Dana superintendent early engage in
discussions with the Windsor Police
command team including David
and that during those discussions the
deputy chief Belair told her that WPS
will come OPP's assistance understood
that OPP and more experienced policing
blockades and and protesting with WPS
and understood that all operational
decisions needed to come true
superintendent early
is that what you're present during these
discussions I was not uh present during
these sessions I was working midnights
at this point uh Carl DeGraff was uh the
ins are our critical incident commander
on days but I was not present during
this no and were you informed about the
content of these discussions afterwards
or
uh no I mean
so Dana uh yearly came with an uh
numerous resources
um it was clear that the Windsor Police
to all of our admission had no
experience in public order
so it was my understanding right from
the beginning that Dana and her team was
was in charge of the public order
um response as well as uh numerous OPP
resources so that would just my my
um uh understanding was we would be
forming a unified command team
and was this understood prior to
superintendent early's arrival or once
she arrived
uh I would say before she arrived that
was the intention uh we did not have
that experience and uh we were asking
for help essentially
so it was just just to make sure I
understand correctly it was OPP um sorry
WPS command's position that OPP should
take over the the event in Windsor no
that's that was not my understanding I
was never told that my understanding was
unified command okay which again so in
my my experience uh before I was a
critical incident commander and as a
critical incident Commander when you
have multi-jurisdictional
um command and unified command in that
multi-jurisdictional command there are
times to step forward as a critical
instant commander and there are times to
step back
and that's what unified command is we
learned through this process that
superintendent yearly's command was
she was in command of public order
response was in command of Opp resources
those were the times she stepped forward
then there was operational times when
the Windsor Police would step forward be
it myself or inspector Carl DeGraff
so so you would say that OPP was in
charge of the POU response
and PLT perhaps and WPS maintained
control of the overall
operation it was again this unified
command I can't say anyone was in charge
of the overall operation unified command
there is
um
consultation that goes on like for
instance even the POU plan where
superintendent yearly was
clearly in charge of the POU plan
she consulted us on it after that it was
done she would consult us any any issues
any logistical issues any Windsor issues
so that's that is the true meaning of
that unified command so uh this uh I I
was not part of those discussions so
that was not my understanding okay
um so in the same paragraph we see that
um that superintendent under early later
called Craig Abrams and informed him
that Windsor has told us being us being
OPP this is now ours
um and superintendent early under
explained that she meant that OPP was in
charge and that WPS we will be working
alongside OPP that's not your
understanding of how it took place well
I I agree with the working alongside yes
oh it's uh 100 I agree with that uh I I
don't know um about uh this I was never
informed of this
um I would say that yes we worked
alongside each other and again that that
um concept of stepping forward and
stepping back in in a unified command
was present right from the immediate
arrival of of superintendent earlier in
her team uh and uh I would also say that
Windsor Police was always the police of
jurisdiction we never we're not the
police for jurisdiction through this
this event
um
I think
we can come back to to the witness
summary later on but I would like to
pull up WPS
00702 at page 27.
because I I think I just want to
understand
um who was taking decisions and
who was giving advice and so on in in
the comment structure
um
because
I understand that the idea of coming
forward and giving some space to the
other command but I just want to make
sure I understand properly how this
works in practice okay
um in that this is a document that the
debrief do do you recognize this yes I
do this is something that we prepared
it's not my document no okay but it was
prepared after the freedom Convoy events
to
make a debrief of the events and have
recommendations moving forward that's
correct and if we can go at page
um 27 please
um
on the right table it's the it's 0.4
it says under cic takeaway cic
understand is critical incident command
um we see at point four needed WPS to be
more engaged with calibrating on
operational plans with WPS members have
best idea of the idea and implications
of decisions and should be embedded in
decision making Matrix
so this document was there's a lot of
opinion in this document the way it was
prepared uh the superintendent that was
in charge of this document of preparing
it essentially sent out opinion papers
to all our subject matter experts within
our service uh and this I don't know
where that came from
um it didn't come from me but uh
certainly I that was just a part of a
recommendation that somebody felt that
you know
was was legitimate
okay
um I
um maybe we can talk a little bit about
the comment table that was formed by
superintendent early do you recall that
comment table yes very well
um can you just explain how it worked
and who from the WPS was on the command
table what was their role and so on
so prior to the opp command team
arriving we had our Command table
uh superintendent yearly came with her a
command table which essentially in the
positions kind of mirrored ours but
so her team arrived on the 10th and
immediately that team was inserted in
our Command table
effortlessly and seamlessly so she had
[Music]
um
she had ascribed as I had a scribe she
had another inspector in involved in
logistics she had a boards person that
is in charge of all the the white boards
with all the information on it that we
that you know is changing throughout the
event essentially it was this very same
setup or very similar setup than we had
but the day they came in they had some
recommendations on the actual layout of
our EOC which were taken into
consideration immediately
um things like more boards you know
things like that so those were taken
care right away but after that uh
they hit the ground running with us and
there was uh it was a seamless
transition to be honest uh so it's fair
to say that your your initial equipment
table just merged with theirs yes that's
what I would say okay
um more on the same topic but more
narrowed on the critical incident
command questions we can remove that
PowerPoint by the way
um just specifically on the critical
incident command structure and
how it works
we understood from previous testimony
that the cic's purpose was to give
autonomy to
the CICS to take decisions under on the
go and to have their own autonomy and so
on I'm wondering how
how did it work with Dana early
superintendent early being a critical
incident Commander for the same incident
that you and
you were
so
um again that that shared or unified
command in stepping forward and stepping
back so for instance a perfect example
is the poe response
superintendent early put that plan
together with her team
consulted us after
there were other times for instance uh
and I don't want to jump ahead too often
or too much but on the Saturday night
for instance there was a bomb threat it
was a tactical call I stepped up and
took the lead on that so those are the
kind of things uh you know and again
even though if I'm making decisions at
that that bomb threat
Dana was right next to me and we're
talking about decisions as they're made
you know because that's that shared
command so that's kind of the dynamic if
if that helps
um but that's the model yes this
provides a lot of clarity thank you
um maybe we can jump to February 11th
um
about the approval of the operational
plan
um we can pull out the their operational
plan just to refresh your memory it's
wps1440 page two
um that's not the the operational plan
itself but it's an email that presents
the operational plan
um
I'm wondering
it says that uh
it's inspector yunan who was who was in
the planning team under inspector uh
under superintendent and early any
emails or about
the plan and he says please reply all
with your approval of the plan so that
our Municipal Partners have the recorded
approval I just want to understand why
it was necessary to have the approval
recorded for your purposes so the the
part of Dana early's team was the public
order commanders so that would be Jason
Union inspector Union and uh Angela
Ferguson the two inspectors were in
charge of their OPP public order units
they would come up with a plan because
they're the subject matter experts just
like in any critical incident
that's what a critical instant Commander
relies upon their subject matter experts
to come up with a plan and then within
the framework of critical critical
incident command the commander will
either approve it
or not approve it may have questions
about it may have
um you know may suggest things that may
be added or deleted but essentially they
have questions uh or they'll be able to
approve or not approve that plan so it
wasn't it's as a critical instant
Commander it's not superintendent
early's job or even maybe not even her
subject matter expertise
to physically make that plan so that's
why it has to be approved by the
critical Institute Commander because the
cic is is essentially in charge of of
every decision that's being made in that
command team
and that that's why you had to have her
approval for your records yes because
the and in that planning team though
there was other pous involved we had
other other municipalities in that
public order unit so the public order
commanders have come up with this plan
they sent it to superintendent yearly
because that's who's in charge of the
suit of the public Order Plan
and then uh it she approves it and in
that process of approval she consults
with spectrograph myself
whoever was there and you know is there
any concerns
excellent okay can we pull out now
opp04557
um I understand this is the overall
Ambassador Bridge operational plan
just have a few questions on it
um
I'm wondering
um it took only two days in fact to come
up with that plan do you don't have any
insight as to why it was so quick well
this is why you rely on your subject
matter experts so uh you know this
planning informally starts with those
first few phone calls and emails to
superintendent yearly you know hey we
might need some public order help so the
situational reports were going to her
and her team before they even came to
Windsor so they knew the geography they
knew what was going on with us they knew
what was happening with the protesters
so when they get their uh subject matter
experts can work very quickly to come up
with a plan to um
to essentially clear the bridge
and that's what happened
and on February 11th as well not only
the plans were approved but the province
declared a state of emergency under the
emcpa and there was a civilian Junction
that went into effect that's correct um
it was quite a busy day
I said it was a very busy day actually
um did edit of those
um either the Declaration of emergency
or the injunction have any effect on on
the plan or the operation itself
um I would say the the uh the injunction
uh was was impactful for us
um it allowed uh
obviously just another tool for us uh
during the whole planning of everything
but it allowed us to to Really uh focus
on uh exterior or perimeter roads as
opposed to just here in church so if
there was parking and and you know and
that came into play later but towing
cars off of side streets that was the
injunction was very helpful for things
like that it was another tool plus of
course it was another charge that we
would be able to lay uh if we had
arrested anybody the emergency for the
uh under the empca uh really uh I don't
think was much of a consideration for us
for this plan
foreign
so I understand that charges were laid
under the
breaking of court order
criminal offense under the criminal code
um you know if they were these charges
were laid during the operations or
afterwards
well the the rest were majoring public
order action on the 12th and 13th and
the subsequent charges were laid after
that like you know the the investigators
then take the files and and lay the
information subsequent to the arrests
but prior to the injunction we already
had reasonable grounds for criminal
mischief uh like I said the injunction
was simply another charge that we were
would be able to lay on on the
protesters upon arrest
and I would like to move to the
operation itself
I think we can remove that
plan
um you you explain in in your witness
summary that there was perhaps
um seven around
730 officers that participated in the
operation and approximately 500 OPP
officers that were present is that those
were estimations I think at my at my
point I was never involved in the
scheduling I was involved in some
discussions with the officers we had
scheduling out of our training Branch it
was hectic we had people reporting
um that we didn't know were reporting
and I mean you can imagine the
logistical uh it was you know it was
very difficult for our schedulers so
those were estimations uh judging by
what we knew the opp had sent and other
municipalities had had sent us
and do you have any understanding or
insight about why so many officer
officers were sent in the end
despite the fact that only 100 officers
were asked at the beginning
um I I really don't have that
information I think that's probably
better directed at the opp but I would
say like if from my point of view the
100 was the original ask of 100 officers
was simply
um an initial response to the beginnings
of the blockade the blockade grew
enormously throughout the week and it
really peaked on the Saturday night uh
to really and I call it the highest
point of incivility that I've seen in a
long time
so that would say that's probably why
the number of officers that the the
conditions we were working in it was
cold the snow public order had done
their thing that morning on the Saturday
uh they started their action so I would
say just uh and then they were they were
I I wouldn't say that there were 700
officers at one point I would say there
was probably in and out because there
was officers going from Windsor to
Ottawa and to Toronto and all these
other things they were in and out and
almost interchangeable at times from my
understanding anyways and what was WPS
role during the operation itself you
mentioned the bomb threat um was there
any any other things well we were side
by side with OPP and RCMP and and you
know other Municipal officers so we
would have uh say like for instance it
came up earlier about swearing uh our
CMP officers in so before we could swear
the RCMP officers in for provincial
legislation we would have to pair them
with a municipal officer or an opp
officer to ensure that they would have
those abilities to enact provincial
offenses
um so we had uh at times we had an opp
cruiser with two wins or police officers
in it like it was just it was shared
resources uh for for perimeter control
for uh any um
any kind of Uprising that we might need
like the bomb collar we had a an
abandoned house fire at one point uh in
the area so these are the kind of things
that we were trying to manage that
perimeter with uh the boots on the
ground those initial officers other than
Pou
okay and the operation lasted from the
February 12th to the 13th that's correct
and did would you consider the operation
a success yes I would consider it a a
very successful
we had eventually I think we charged 44
people I think that was the number we
had no injuries no property damage
um and we were able to clear that bridge
relatively quickly in my book anyways
and now moving on from the operation I
am on February 13 I understand that
WPS The Windsor Police and the opp both
adopted a joint traffic plan that's
correct
um we can pull up the plan if possible
it's a wps000711
at page two
so the goal of that plan was to prevent
a further blockade that's correct
and if we go at page two there's that
mission statement which
it's basically the same of the February
9th operation operational plan about
maintaining establishing and maintaining
a safe flow of traffic respecting
individuals Charter rights
um
if we move yeah it's it's here as well
the image immediate action plan it says
what you mentioned that uh
if members observe it in a minute
Highway blockade and form reasonable
grounds of an offense is about to be
committed officers will intervene to
prevent a blockade if it is safe to do
so
um I'm just curious as to how both
interact preventing a blockade and
respecting individuals Charter rights
and freedom
so at this point when we had
um basically control of the area through
Jersey barriers and police presence uh
we had no problems with with protesters
that were still in in the area on
sidewalks and there was there wasn't
very many of them but there were a
handful mostly up at the Tecumseh Road
area at here in church uh and that was
okay so that's that was still respecting
people's right to come out and protest
on the sidewalk we don't watch you to
block critical infrastructure and then
relying again on the OPP's experience in
these long drawn out uh protracted
demonstrations
we we adopted this plan that that mostly
was from their experience and so we were
able to control that area from
essentially UC Royal Expressway
to the bridge through Jersey barriers
and if there was protesters out on the
sidewalks or even in uh on foot in some
of the parking lots we just allowed it
so the the limit so to stay so to say is
blocking an infrastructure or Highway
that that was a no-go but as long as it
solved the highways on but at this point
we were dealing with
like probably under 10 protesters again
I'm still working midnights at this
point so the crowds at night were you
know four or five in the morning people
were sleeping so you might have five or
six seven protesters on the corner of
Tecumseh and here in church that was
okay we weren't going to remove them
they were off the road they weren't you
know in any danger and they were allowed
to protest
understood
um so you briefly mentioned the plan
itself underground consisted of
establishing Jersey barriers all along
urine Church Road I think mayor Dil Kens
explained it as a this morning as a
pipeline to allow the trucks to go
directly from the 4-1 to the Ambassador
Bridge is that correct that's correct we
had left
um a safety out in case somebody
accidentally got up and tied up in the
at Tecumseh Road but we didn't advertise
that if somebody came across and said
hey I really don't want to go on the
bridge I'm just here on accident there
wasn't out for them but essentially it
was a tunnel of Jersey barriers from the
expressway to
um to the bridge yes and members of the
public were not allowed to just
to just go on the highway without a
lawful reason or justification on your
interest Church Road no the bridge was
open if members of the public wanted to
go over to the states they could have
used that but once they would have to
enter at the expressway which was very
you know a few kilometers south of the
of the bridge
okay but they they had to to move
forward and go towards Ambassador Bridge
or else they they could not just hang on
here in Church Road no no yeah they
could not stop and know that we but we
didn't have that problem uh we didn't
not to my recollection at this point
anyways we had anybody stop and try and
block that but there was numerous uh
threats of it uh and that's why we would
reevaluate every single day
to where the traffic plan was and when
can we start demobilization of that
traffic plan there was very measured and
very uh conscious of what you know what
the intelligence was and what the
Potential Threat of protesters coming
back to block the bridge
um again open sources were we were
hearing people asking other um
protesters from Ottawa Toronto to come
down to Windsor we're going to come at
them again we're going to block the
bridge again this was daily so we would
reevaluate with our intelligence our
information every day
and um and then act accordingly from
there
so
so there were were there any situations
where the traffic management plan was
helpful in preventing any blockades it
was helpful every day yeah
um I know it was a uh a major
inconvenience for the citizens of
Windsor
and I think the mayor explained it well
people on the West End trying to get to
uh the other side of the east side of
Huron church was very difficult I would
hear it on the radio myself of of uh our
local radio stations and um you know the
frustration of the people because that
was closed or not closed but that was uh
we were controlling those roadways for a
considerable amount of time so we
understood that the frustration but we
just that's why we we would reevaluate
every day we really understood that the
importance of maintaining that uh
posture there by the bridge to ensure
that we we wouldn't lose it again
I am just moving on to February 14th uh
the data there was a declaration of
emergencies by the federal government
um
I'm wondering if it if you had any
because of the injunction was in force
the amcpa wasn't was in place you had a
traffic management plan
um
is there anything that the emergencies
act added
um to to to to to to the situation or L2
in any ways and preventing further
blockades I can't say operationally that
we didn't use the emergencies act after
that but
um I I can't imagine it didn't dissuade
people from coming back but I that's
just a speculation we did not use the
emergencies act at all
so you would say it it may have it may
have had a distress effect but it was
not used on the ground that's correct
um
and
moving further down the timeline and
just to wrap up the Windsor story we
the WPS and OPP adapted the mobilization
plan as well which
it lasted until March 13 to fully
demobilize I think OPP
um
it seems a bit long do you do would you
agree
um well yeah if I'm a citizen of Windsor
trying to cross yes it seemed long but
we really felt it was necessary and
again we're relying on the experience of
the Ontario Provincial Police in these
matters so we would take their advice we
did in the demobilization we did uh
modify the plan
uh more than once because of those
reevaluations daily of hey are we at a
spot where we can
um open up a little more than the plan
says and we did that probably three or
four times throughout those weeks and um
but it was very important to us
especially when we got up to Tecumseh
Road
to take a very measured approach on
reopening
um we were we were very paranoid about
it happening again was there any any
threats any intelligence about a
possible blockade happening just on open
source so
um I don't recall any uh credible
intelligence or information from law
enforcement but I I that's just my
recollection right now I could be wrong
saying to be corrected on that but
certainly
um on the uh on Open Source on on all
the social media
we had heard numerous pleas and numerous
threats that it was going to happen
again
um
not at the Windsor story is complete I
just want to to go to Lessons Learned
concluding questions for uh just a few
questions I'm really possible to pull up
wps0002 and the same documents that we
viewed earlier about the debriefing by
WPS about the freedom Convoy event
um if you can go
on page 19 please
there's a mention about
it it's areas to improve about the
initial petrol petrol response which I
understand is before the blockade
happened or before OPP arrived
um it mentions areas to improve issues
with the operational plan is is that in
reference to the February 4th plan
um I I can't answer that at that point
it's that's not my document I don't know
what that's referencing I would assume
um that that's what it's referencing
um
but again we were
um a medium-sized service trying to
police a city and deal with this at the
same time so uh and and just because
everyone didn't know about an
operational plan and the ins and outs of
an operational plan
um you know some of these opinions may
come from that right like they didn't
know what the you know we weren't
communicating with the operational plan
is to everyone in the organization
um in your witness summary you mentioned
that if WPS had a public order unit at
the time it would have been able to come
up with a better plan in responding to
the initial stages of the blockade we
may have um it was a very
um even I think the the protesters were
disorganized at the very beginning
probably at the height of of because we
talked about this fractured leadership
that they had they were they were
probably as disorganized at the
beginning as throughout the whole
protest so if we would have had a public
order unit in place and the experience
and the subject matter experts I would
think that we might have been able to
act uh accordingly because of the um
of the uh just the state of that initial
few hours but again that's an assumption
by me I don't know I don't have that
experience in public order
um and it says also on on that same
slide
um
on the second point on the left side
extremely resource and intensive only a
fraction of Patrol officers remained to
take calls
um patrol Personnel were totally burned
out so it was not just a Pou issue it
was a resource issue as well it was an
enormous resource issue we again this is
an opinion that someone had but uh
certainly we we had nowhere else to draw
from other than our regular Patrol and
and investigative Personnel to to police
the bridge so we're we're our Patrol
Personnel uh very tired and we're
getting very burned out I imagine they
were as were the opp and all the other
Municipal officers that came into town
for sure
um I would like to pull up com0000822
it's the Antigua C and effectiveness of
police services regulation
um which I assume you're from Europe
with so I didn't quite hear what
regulation is there it's the adequacy
and effectiveness of police services
regulation it's under the police
services act yes
okay and um under Section 18 it mentions
that police forces shall have a public
order unit
um despite sexual subsection 2 says
despite subsection one
um aboard my intern to enter into an
agreement to provide the services
through another police force
are you aware of any agreement with
another police force to have a public
order unit dispatched in case of a
public order event
we do not have a formal agreement with
another police force I think what in in
our policy is mirroring that mirrors
this this adequacy standard and this
this legislation
um essentially what our policy says that
we'll ship we shall enter into an
agreement
in the event we need one
um like for instance the London Police
had one right away when we asked for
help and we signed it uh well the mayor
signed it I think uh so it certainly no
one asked us to do that but certainly we
are ready to
um upon requirement we would enter into
an agreement for sure I think I I have
the pause here mentioning can can we
pull up wps0001877
um
I think that's a policy about
public order units deployment
um
and the possibility of entering into an
agreement
that's correct
do you recognize yeah that's correct
that's the one you were mentioning
exactly okay
um
is this the version that was enforced
during the freedom Convoy events uh yes
I'm assuming it is yes okay
and we go at Point D on page two please
as you mentioned it says that the pull
the service shall provide a service of a
public or unit through the provisions of
an agreement with the opp
that's correct
I'm I'm just not sure I understand why
such an agreement was not entered upon
prior to the freedom Convoy events and
so that's that's very as explainable
um so the OBP provides many services to
many uh Municipal Services throughout
the province uh for instance we don't
have a dive team we don't have an
agreement to use the dive team when we
need to use the divers we have a formal
request Chief to the commissioner
we would like to use your dime dive team
for this uh this investigation no
problem they get sent down there's no
agreement we need a um a technical
expert in say uh in vehicles with uh
extracting information from the
computers the opp have those
informal request goes to our chief to
the commissioner comes back no problem
here you go so there's no there's no
agreement for any of that it's it's a
chief to Chief request
um and certainly this is no different if
the commissioner would have come and
said hey we have an agreement would you
please sign it I'm pretty sure our board
would have signed it immediately
but this offer from the commissioner
never came to no we never we never as
far as I know we never received any
agreement except from the London Police
Service
um and you mentioned formal versus
informal requests for assistance I just
want to make sure I understand what's
the difference between the two
especially as as it relates to public
order units or assistance at large to a
public order event
um
in your what's the difference between a
formal or informal okay so perfect
example of informal request was this
emergency preparedness committee that I
sit on for the oacp
again we're meeting at least two three
times a week by by uh on Zoom or teams
or whatever it was
and the discussion
at this time before our blockade was
focusing on Ottawa and the Toronto uh
weekend protests that were happening
every weekend
so amongst police leaders at our ranks
and superintendent inspector
those were the requests saying okay who
can send people to Ottawa it necessarily
wasn't Pou specific but it was who could
spare some bodies for Ottawa or who can
send people to Toronto so after our
blockade was concluded months went by
Ottawa had two other pretty robust
protests Rolling Thunder and there was
another one I don't remember the name of
it but we sent people from Windsor
because they needed people on ground we
don't have public order but we set
resources because
you know that was the right thing to do
and we felt that we really had a debt to
actually pay uh for a lot of uh the
other services so that's just an example
of an informal request they would
eventually be in or formalized through
the Chiefs
which again is covered in the police act
Chief makes a request to the
commissioner and that's one you know one
one of the um ways that those INF or
those formal requests are made I I can't
see that a superintendent is going to
authorize these requests without the
chief knowing so and on February 4th we
know that Chief Mizuno had a call with
commissioner karik asking for assistance
would that but I think you mentioned it
was not a formal request process since
do you know why no I can't really
comment because I didn't know about that
uh directly like I wasn't involved in
that conversation uh what I did get what
I think my testimony was that Chief
Mizuno asked me to contact Chief
superintendent FIB because those were
that was a small request and that wasn't
a Pou request that was a a local request
to get local resources from the local
detachments and I don't think that is
something that necessarily the
commissioner was was concerned with a
local request to the local detachments
and however your request when you reach
out to do I tip on the same day would
that be considered a formal request
under the police services act yes I
would think that just a formal request
of of uh resources locally and the
commissioner knew about it through the
conversation with the chief and um but
that that's what that was my direction I
was told to call it uh Chief
superintendent uh fib and that was my
direction and that's what I did
and under under the police services act
I'm sure you're familiar it's not
necessary to pull it up but the
commissioner of Opp has to provide the
resources it deems he deems or she deems
necessary
in response to a formal request for
assistance I'm wondering
there was no request provided on
February 4th
I'm wondering do you have any idea why
is that
I I don't know
I don't
I think at the beginning of that process
we just we didn't uh have a as big of an
event on our hands
perfect I have no further questions
thank you thank you commissioner
thank you
okay so uh first up is the city of
Windsor
so many of our questions oh this is
Jennifer king Council for the city of
Windsor most of our questions have
already been canvassed I do have a
series of questions on one topic The
Windsor Detroit Marathon
um Deputy
um Chief you are a long time resident of
Windsor Essex that's correct my whole
life then I would expect you're familiar
with the Windsor Detroit Marathon I am
and you're familiar with the road
closures and restrictions during the
marathon yes
uh mayor dilkins was asked some
questions about the closure of the
Ambassador Bridge during the marathon
this summer
yes and you were here for his testimony
I was
you'll agree with me that generally
during the marathon traffic is only
restricted on the bridge not entirely
closed
well that's a good question I don't know
that
um I've never run the marathon so I
don't know
I would like to but no I don't know if
it's restricted or completely closed but
either way it's for a very small period
of time okay so that's generally early
in the morning on a Sunday it's always
on a Sunday I've worked it it's always
on a Sunday it's usually very early six
seven in the morning yes for maybe a
couple hours okay well it is it's our
understanding that generally it's only
entirely closed this year it was only
entirely closed this year because there
was construction at the same time do you
were you aware that there was
construction on the bridge this year yes
okay thank you thank you those are all
of my questions
okay thank you next is the government of
Canada
good afternoon deputy chief good
afternoon commissioner my name is Andrew
Gibbs and I'm one of the council with
the government of Canada
just briefly touching on some of the
testimony you've given already you
mentioned that the leadership was quite
divided and used the word faction
uh fractured fractured yes that's how I
would describe it that was my opinion
okay and so there were in fact multiple
leaders and made it very difficult to
determine who was in charge that's
correct that's what it seemed like
you also described the situation as
dynamic
would you say it was fluid yes
unpredictable yes volatile yes and
aggressive yes at times at times
on February 10th uh were there threats
made to block or blockade The Windsor
Police Services headquarters yes
and why would that have been a concern
to you
um well I mean it impacts our daily
operations uh greatly we uh our fleet
vehicles are parked in the basement
I would imagine uh exiting and
Engineering the building if it's blocked
would be very difficult it would impact
our employees coming in and out of work
I would imagine it would just impact
every every uh piece of our operating
um you know uh
our operations every day and for those
of us who are not police officers that
would mean you couldn't come and help
people if they called 9-1-1 that's
exactly right
were there also threats to block the
Windsor Detroit tunnel yes there were
and the Windsor airport yes sir and
those threats did not materialize no but
you couldn't ignore them no we we had to
deploy resources to all three of those
places that you mentioned
um as well as uh very concerning that
whole Corridor where our headquarters is
it has hospitals and essential services
that if that area got blocked it would
have caused enormous problems for us and
not mentioning the tunnel with what the
mayor said was thousands of people going
over there to work
you also mentioned
um just in terms of a general public
safety and uh officer safety concerns
there was a bomb threat at the mayor's
house yes that also took resources I
believe he mentioned two to three police
cars were there for a week or two yes
that's correct uh there was a bomb
threat behind the police lines on
February 12th is that correct that's
correct and it turned out to be uh not
credible that's correct but the threat
was made that we had to deal with yes it
put resources to it investigate it and
yes
was there also a drone flying over a
protester drone flying over the police
enforcement operation on February 12th I
imagine there was I don't know for sure
but I imagine there was all kinds of
live footage that we were watching in
the EOC
um that was open source and that was
that was part of it okay thank you and
you mentioned that it was cold and there
was snow the officers were putting in a
lot of overtime yes we canceled I
canceled the days off uh from I think
it's
I'd have to check the dates but uh I
canceled a week of rest Days of our own
officers uh let alone the the uh the ask
from the opp and the municipal Municipal
forces to be away from home and and
cancel their days off as well so yes it
was it was a long long days so there was
a lot of tension absolutely and I think
you said people were burnt out yeah yes
there is also mention of children being
involved I believe the mayor mentioned
that children were involved at the
protest and particularly when the police
enforcement action was scheduled to take
place on February 12th yes
what impact does the presence of
children in a mass protest have on
police operations
well the unpredictability of any crowd
Gathering is is a enormous consideration
for us but in something like that we had
to make um plans with Children's Aid
Society on arrest plans we had resources
dedicated to just
Children's Aid
obviously there's a huge safety concern
there's there there was talk on
um open
um
Source Communications that they were
going to use children as human Shields
at one point
so there was all kinds of considerations
for us to keep the welfare of children
you know very you know safe Mr clerk can
we please turn up OPP four zeros4539
and uh go to page 41.
on this point
so Carl de Graf
um
we you know who this is yes sir and this
is an email from Carl DeGraff to Dana
early
um the opp joint Commander the unified
command you mentioned earlier yes uh FYI
regarding using children as a defensive
tactic and this is sent on February 11th
if you'll scroll down please Clerk
this appears to be a uh an exchange of
tweets
um thank you as more children are with
us as less option to power for police
children is our best weapon against them
and someone responds essentially that
this is an evil strategy children are
not weapons or human Shields if this man
wants to bring his family to a protest
he can do his research and should be
aware of people who speak like you going
down to the last tweet
it is a war they prepare for us with
guns cold water and gas
is that consistent with the information
that you were receiving with respect to
children being used as what you said
human Shields that's correct thank you
um
we only have a few minutes left so
I understand in summary you've answered
a lot of these questions already but I
think you'd mentioned that they were
burnt out the officers were burnt out I
think you believe I believe you said
they were spread very thin across the
province
is that correct that's my opinion that
that police resources across the
province were getting spread thin yes so
that would involve all police resources
um certainly because of the asks on the
EPC committee and the public order being
spread thin and for sure and so you
there are a series of documents I won't
go through them but
um
you were taken at one point to the to
the justification for the 100 officers
um and if that Mr clerk is at WPS uh six
Zero's six ten
and um
commission Council took you to some of
the the basic numbers I'd like to go to
page two
uh where you mentioned that
um
scroll down a bit I think it there
should be a reference that says that
currently officers are being outnumbered
and surrounded by protesters when
confronted or approached is that an
accurate description absolutely I
watched it myself on open source YouTube
channels and you mentioned that you were
trying to continue the regular winds or
policing at that time that's correct
because regular City Life involves all
sorts of things that
sometimes we require police assistance
yes we have a very busy Police Service
yes and would you think it would be fair
to say that every city in the province
of Ontario would involve that type of uh
requirements for their Police Services
absolutely and they were also being
stretched in yes and you mentioned that
this would happen essentially across the
country would it not
it's my opinion yes for sure
and so
turning lastly to the Resurgence you've
mentioned that you were quite concerned
or the Windsor Police Force were quite
concerned as was the mayor that this
they could return the protesters could
return that's correct and in fact
um
interim Chief Belair submitted an
affidavit in support of the Windsor city
um motion to extend the injunction
indefinitely is that correct that's
correct and uh I won't pull it up but um
interim Chief Belair swore an affidavit
which is found at WPS
6049 and in particular at paragraphs 44
to 54.
he states that based on and I'm
paraphrasing but based on monitoring of
social media demonstrators are asking
more locals to join more vehicles are
traveling to the area
social media indicating further action
from protesters expected quote it's not
over quote regroup quote we are not done
quote Slow Roll is next and finally
quote Civil War time
anti-police comments are also observed
and the February February 15th Convoy of
several transport trucks from Ottawa on
route to Windsor was intercepted by
police that's correct
and in fact Justice morowicz based on
that evidence and other evidence granted
the interim injection
um indefinitely that's correct
now you stated that you did not use the
emergencies act sir but is it fair to
say that that's because this resurgent
did not materialize uh that's what yes
that's a fair fair to say for sure so in
fact we don't know if it would have been
needed absolutely
and finally with all of these local
protests in all of the cities that you'd
mentioned including Sarnia Toronto
Ottawa Cornwall
Quebec City Emerson Coots and Surrey
British Columbia and others
um
when the location and duration of a
blockade is unpredictable
and when police resources are stretched
thin
and the officers are exhausted
would you agree that this list this
leads to an increased risk of Safety and
Security for the officers and the
general public certainly could and that
would exist wherever those protests May
pop up that's correct those are my
questions thank you very much sir
thank you
next is the Democracy fund
and citizens for freedom
and Mr commissioner and deputy chief
we're the 10 minutes allotted here and
brief as possible
I'm sure registered can we pull off
wps60102
again deputy chief it's Antoine Dai
Council of assistance for freedom
there's just a limited time if you could
answer yes or no where where possible
um is it your understanding that there's
CCTV cameras posted along the various
intersections on here on Church Road yes
traffic cameras yes and those here on uh
those cameras include at EC Rowan here
on Church which is about four kilometers
away from the mouth of the bridge not
aware of these hero could be uh how
about here on church at Tecumseh about
one kilometer from the bridge yes and
then here on church at College which is
about 50 meters from the foot of the
bridge is that correct that's correct
and this photo here uh is this from a
CCTV camera
I'm going to say that's probably a drone
picture that one's from a drone uh was
somebody monitoring the CCTV cameras
during the Denver demonstration
uh yes they were actively being
monitored and and was this happening at
the EOC
uh yes and is it your understanding that
live CCTV footage or at least you know
freaking screenshots are normally
available to the public online
of some of the CCTV cameras correct and
was there ever a decision made by
Windsor Police Service to restrict
access of uh these these cameras to the
public no
to be honest we didn't that this this
CTV camera was not very helpful and the
one at College was old and we had to put
up our own camera to be honest
okay
um but there was no decision to
deliberately restrict access understood
um
this looks like the beginnings of what
what made form of blockade and it looks
like the police of vehicles there
um is this the Tecumseh and Huron Church
intersection that's correct and so this
is about a kilometer away from the foot
of the bridge is that correct
approximately and do you have any idea
of when this particular photo was taken
no idea
this was a dynamic uh intersection as
well it would be like this it would be
50 cars there it was Dynamic well would
it be fair to say this would be closer
to the beginning of the protest activity
on on here on church I don't know okay
okay
um you spoke earlier about this this
bear hug strategy and indicating that
there's almost like this Plaza around
the the mouth of the bridge is it fair
to say that there's two Ingress points
and two egress points from the the uh
the Border itself I'm only aware of one
egress or sorry one no wait uh two
egress and two and yes sorry you're
correct right and so so you've got the
the Northbound and southbound Lanes
coming with that main entrance and then
two ancillary roads coming out to remind
us trees that correct yes and
we heard earlier in terms of of the
police establishing a circle of control
or a perimeter would it be fair to say
that that perimeter would be then set
out around those those points of Ingress
and egress that was part of it but it
was expanded to you know the
intersections on here in church and you
know expanded that way but for sure
those would be part of it and and do you
have any indication when that initial
circle of control was established no I
don't
is it your understanding that that uh
on February 10th a plan had already been
put in place for Windsor Police Service
to remove the protesters on Saturday
February 12th
there was discussions amongst the POU
plan to of what day it would it would be
actioned but I don't know exactly when
it was but that was that was one of the
initial plans in the initial days uh Mr
registrar could we pull up
wps7042 and page two of that document
please
I understand these are notes by
superintendent Carl DeGraff
um we're unable to see who this email
was sent to or from did you ever have a
chance to see this email or the contents
of Mr uh inspector graphs update I
probably saw this at some point but I
don't recall it and so is it fair to
assume that this was indeed produced uh
February 10th that inspector to graph
reports there's no significant issues
with managing the protesting and the
numbers have remained consistent
compared to the last three days uh it
could be so inspector Graf worked mainly
days and at at night I put myself on
nights because of this in my experience
in these kind of situations
that's when it ramps up understanding
can we scroll down a little bit further
here to the sixth point
right and so on February 10th so this is
before the city or the ampa apply for
their injunction there's already an
arrest plan in place there's already an
idea that removal is going to begin on
Saturday and there's already indications
that Children's Aid will be involved is
that correct it's probably in the
development of the plan that's correct
and you had indicated that at some point
right around February 10th there was a
shift to this joint command with OPP are
you aware whether or not this plan was
produced before or after joint command
was established well this would have
been after because uh OPP was in charge
of the POU plan of develop developing it
understood
we pull up cff 50106
so deputy chief you spent some time in
the the EOC and and had a good visual in
terms of what was going on during the
during the throughout the week 21 days
all right and so is this an accurate uh
depiction I suppose of the protest and
the police on February 12th being the
Saturday
uh that looks accurate yeah
and can you identify which intersection
this is at
would that be here on Church in college
it looks like to college to be with the
berm on the top left there uh looks the
the university property but I can't say
for sure but that's what it looks like
and it does look like they're then on
the Northbound Lanes there's a number of
police cars in the in those four or
three or four Northbound Lanes there and
behind the police line there's a number
of uh police vehicles there as well is
that correct that's correct and it
appears there may be a small number of
protester vehicles in the southbound
Lanes both in front and behind that
police line is that correct that's
correct and would you agree with me that
uh the the police reports that were
produced indicated that A Towing plan
was successfully executed on February
12th and 13th
yes that's correct and earlier you
mentioned multiple threats that were
made or received do you agree with me
that although resources are required to
investigate and respond not all threats
and social media posts are credible
yes for sure and would you also agree
with me that the threats whether to the
airport or the police station or these
bomb threats by and large did not
materialize no but credible or not we
still have to understand resources have
to be done for sure
um if I could pull up two multimedia
database videos you had indicated
earlier that police were in general
respectful of protesting on the sidewalk
and that you understood that this was
part of the injunction that that lawful
protest was still allowed as long as
you're not impeding traffic is that
correct uh yes that's correct and so if
we could put this first video up again
that's cff six zeros one five
it's a 30 second video here
I mean
are currently with
this morning Pou is going to come arrest
everybody for Mischief if you do not
leave you need to get past the traffic
points down
you guys told us to come here
right now
we're giving you the chance you're
putting your foot in your mouth
you told us if that's fine you can stay
here and get arrested that is fine
okay and then if we could pull up one
more video as well cff seven Zero's four
and while that video is coming up uh
deputy chief would you agree with me
that the records indicate that there was
at least 44 arrests
and that the majority of people that
were arrested were charged with both
mischief and for disobeying a court
order that's correct let's watch this
video here
[Applause]
all right
will be arrested
would you agree with me that it appears
that there's a woman sitting peacefully
on the grass they're being arrested yes
but the roadway here under legislation
is fence line defense line okay I guess
we're trying to establish a perimeter in
a controlled area that's what we're
doing but the sidewalk and the grass are
both on the interior of the fence lines
that you're alluding to yes do we agree
that she's not impeding uh vehicular
traffic from her location there I can
agree with that but we're trying to
clear out an area so that's why she is
getting arrested understood
and would you agree with me that both of
the videos we just saw are in police
enforcement probably on the weekend
either the 12th or the 13th of February
yes I would agree with that thank you
and just quickly in terms of the past
protests I understand police were in
charge of monitoring they went back as
far as June 24th 2020 do you recall
about 100 protesters outside of the
Windsor Essex County Health Unit when
the first mask section 22 order was was
implemented yes I do and you also recall
hundreds of protesters in front of City
Hall when the city implemented a more
restrictive Mass mandate than the health
unit did yeah I believe so and more than
100 protesters in January of 2021
marching down owlette one of the main
streets in Windsor on the road towards
the health unit with concerns about
serious adverse reactions to a segment
of the population from these vaccination
mandates I don't recall that that's why
but I recall the walking in Outlet yes
and you recall thousands of people or at
least a thousand people at the flag
August 28 2020 one with concerns about
risks of serious bodily injury talking
about myocarditis and pericarditis
issues with vaccination I don't recall
ever being a protest of a thousand
people but weekly there was protests at
the flag yes okay what about September
29th do you agree that there was reports
that there was hundreds of people
protesting across the street from
Windsor Regional hospital because the
termination of nurses doctors and other
Frontline hospital staff yes I recall
that and you also recall a silent
protest with at least a thousand people
at the flag on September 18 2021 in
response to the termination of First
Responders and city employees by the
city of Windsor
again the reason I don't know but yes
protests were happening weekly and and
do you also recall that instead of
placing employees on a leave of absence
until the end of the covid-19 period is
provided for in the employment standards
acts and the Infectious Disease
emergency leave that the city of Windsor
made a choice an intimidating Choice
threatening the economic security of
many of its employees that they would be
terminated rather than on a leave of
absence if they refused to accept the
government's medicine into their body I
remember a vaccine policy but I don't
know anything about that had nothing to
do with that
are you aware of any Windsor police
officers that no longer have a job
because of their medical decisions
no I don't think so no further questions
thank you
okay next is the opp
a
commissioner good afternoon
and good afternoon deputy chief I'm
Janine cabersi here representing the
Ontario Provincial Police today so we've
heard
your evidence further to questions from
commission Council regarding
intelligence that the Windsor Police
Service you and your colleagues were
aware of and receiving in late January
and early February you recall discussing
that that's correct
and and so it seems to me it's uh
accepted or well established at least
that uh as far as
um you're concerned at the Windsor
Police Service that the communication
flow uh the receipt of the intelligence
information prepared by the intelligence
Bureau at the opp was uh it was an
effective communication system the the
distribution for the Hendon reports yes
I would say it's very effective yes and
so in addition to that intelligence that
you were receiving from the Ontario
Provincial Police I understand that
Windsor Police Service also had some of
its own intelligence and information
that was being locally gathered that's
correct right and
oh
would it be also fair to say that with
all of that intelligence and the benefit
of that information it was still not
entirely clear or certain what was going
to happen as these slow roles proceeded
in the area of Windsor yes I agree with
that completely right
and so Windsor Police Service planned
based on the information that you had
correct is that fair and also you were
in regular communication with a number
of your OPP colleagues at different
levels across the organization that's
correct right
and so can we say that there was
effective uh communication information
sharing and cooperation that was taking
place between the opp and the Windsor
Police Service throughout this time
period yes I could say that okay
I'd like to ask
you a bit about the discussions uh that
we've heard took place at the emergency
committee I'm not sure if that's the
preparedness committee yes emergency
preparedness committee at the uh
oacp I understand yes and you're a
participant in that committee and we
heard that there was some discussion
about what was happening in the region
um
and in particular uh
were were you familiar with what was
happening uh in the area of the Blue
Water Bridge
um a little bit are you talking you're
referring to right before ours started
or right in that same time period right
around that same time period I believe a
document was pulled up earlier today
indicating that on around February 6
there was some activity around the Blue
Water Bridge and that the opp had
restricted or blocked parts of Highway
402 yes I recall you're familiar with
that
um
[Music]
I expect we may hear a bit more evidence
about that from
superintendent Dana early from the opp
who will be appearing here tomorrow
but from your
um awareness of the situation
um I'd just like to ask you
is it
possible or was it considered as an
option in Windsor to try to execute
something similar to what was done in
the area of the Blue Water Bridge or are
there simply differences in the
situation that
you know lead to different decisions
about planning certainly yes we had
those conversations uh so it's my
understanding of the Blue Water Bridge
uh I'm well aware of the 402 coming off
the 401 it's a one exit when you're
going westbound
um and there was farm equipment from my
recollection uh trying to block that
area police took a proactive uh stance
there the opp and and stopped that one
road coming off the 401 and like any
Highway there's exits and entrances
along the way but limited so a little
bit more manageable from an emergency
preparedness an emergency management you
know lens
where our infrastructure is kilometers
long side streets everywhere so we did
discuss blocking access to here in
church
that leads to blocking access to the
other where the 401 splits here in
church goes to Dougal well Dougal goes
right to our tunnel and the hospital and
all these other things that we wanted to
keep the traffic away from we did not
want to put any any focus on the tunnel
because that was our main
access for for our citizens that work in
in Detroit and in Michigan plus the
hospital was a very big concern for us
as well so uh in those initial
discussions we just we could not we did
not have the resources we couldn't it
was just
um logistically there was no way we
could block all those intersections and
shut down Windsor essentially from
incoming traffic like they did at 402.
so
from what you're describing uh even
those of us who who don't know the
geography of Windsor as well as you do
it seems clear that just the geography
and the nature of the approach to the
Ambassador Bridge just gives rise to a
lot more complications with any effort
to uh stop the flow of traffic in that
direction absolutely so I understand
that a plan was developed uh
on around February 7th I understand to
focus on the intersection right at the
entrance to the bridge that's correct uh
and
would it be fair to say that based on
the information that you knew at that
point that seemed to be a reasonable
approach it was reasonable and and
really we other than the fact that we
didn't know what what the tactic might
be that was the most reasonable uh
tactic that we could use right and so
ultimately that
that plan didn't prove to be successful
in in uh dealing with the blockade
entirely and then as we've heard in the
evidence things started to develop very
quickly and conversations were happening
uh at different levels within the opp
regarding the provision of resources to
assist Windsor in dealing with this
developing blockade yes that's correct
right and we heard that a team of PLT
officers was among the the first of the
officers that were deployed to Windsor
to assist and lend their expertise
that's correct and then in addition to
that there's been some discussion of the
request for 100 officers so I I just
like you to make uh clear for us when
um we're referring to those 100 officers
uh is it correct that you're referring
to Front Line uniform officers
who might be described as officers who
could take on General duties that's
controlling monitoring intersections
that's exactly what those sorts of
Duties so that that number of officers
certainly doesn't include the number of
officers that might be required for a
public order unit operation absolutely
not right and those determinations came
later
after the
shared command or unified command as
it's also been referred to was
established starting on around February
10th when superintendent early arrived
correct okay
um
commission Council just go moving to
that time period commission Council
referred you to an email
wps1440
that was the email
that was sent to superintendent early
seeking her approval for a public order
unit plan
oh thank you for pulling that up
uh and you just reviewed this uh
document with commission Council but I'd
like to just pull up
um what I believe to be the attachment
to this email which is
wps1441
clerk if you could please pull that up
as well just so that we can see that
attachment
and deputy chief I'd like to to just
take a a quick look at it to confirm
that this is the public order deployment
plan it's dated February 12th yes that's
it so this was developed by the planners
that arrived with superintendent Dana
early and we're working with you that's
correct like yeah they developed the
plan for sure right so so there was when
you speak of the the shared command or
the unified command
um
it it appears that an effective way of
putting that into operation was to play
to the strengths of the different
organizations exactly right right and
since the opp had Pou experience and
then some other uh planning experience
uh that was taken care of by the OPP
team
absolutely 100 that was that was the the
again with especially with my background
that that was the ask that was the ask
for them to come in and provided us
their experience and that's what they
did abnormally
and uh given your local expertise in the
city of Windsor and policing in the city
of Windsor obviously your focus might
have been on issues that require that
kind of expertise that's right is that
also Fair okay but that being said a lot
of consultation went you know afterwards
of both ways so
of course
um I'd also just like to refer as well
to OPP
4560 and ask you deputy chief were you
um also uh or I expect you also had the
opportunity to review the full set of
plans that was prepared by by the team
that's correct uh so this uh is a
package of documents
um that were prepared by the OPP but if
if you scroll down uh clerk I just want
to bring this document to attention if
you could scroll down further please
several pages
it also will include a copy of that
public Order Plan
as well as some other supporting
documents
that supported the planning process
okay we can we can leave that for now I
expect we'll look at that in more detail
with superintendent early
um I'm mindful of uh the time
commissioner so I I would like to also
ask you
um deputy chief uh so as as the plan uh
was then
you know ready to be implemented uh as
determined by the command team
and then this happened fairly quickly as
I understand it that's correct you know
some might be surprised to see that uh a
plan uh containing all the required
elements was produced within a matter of
days but that is the reality well that's
a testament to the experience that they
bring okay
um and we've heard some reference to the
uh
effectiveness of the opp PLT officers
who came onto the scene to support the
the work that some of the Windsor Police
Service liaison officers uh had also
been working towards in developing
rapport and communication with the
protesters yes that's correct
um
I I take it you became aware that on uh
the 11th of February there was a an
effort to come to some kind of
resolution with the protesters who had
indicated
through a PLT officer that the
protesters would like to speak to
someone from the provincial government
and they were asking for a letter
essentially to that effect yes that's
correct you're familiar with that so I'd
just like to pull up uh that document Mr
clerk it's
wps1454 I believe my friend uh Mr Curry
I think alluded to this earlier but I
just like to pull it up on the screen
and
um deputy chief have you take a look at
it
right so if if we scroll down a little
bit we see that this is uh February 11th
it's addressed to commissioner Parikh
and if we continue to scroll down it's
from Sylvia Jones
uh and it says the government of Ontario
is proposing that a meeting occur within
an agreeable time period with the select
group of protest leadership and so on so
you're familiar with this resolution
attempt yes it was undertaken
um I understand uh that this letter was
delivered to the protesters on the
evening of February 11th
yes that's correct I'll wear that you
know but but ultimately uh it
unfortunately did not lead to a
resolution of the blockade that's
correct of the bridge
and in that regard what I mean is the
the bridge continued to be blocked
that's correct okay
um
I might just have one moment
um
deputy chief
you were taken to uh a debrief document
by by commission Council that had a
number of comments about the
um
experience that had taken place
throughout the protest and the blockade
and then the the resolution of the
blockade and you you noted that you
thought it was you know expressing
opinions of particular individuals that
were present there I I just like to ask
you
um what in your view uh if if you were
asked to debrief what would you say were
the Lessons Learned uh the
um things that worked or things that
that didn't work I I think that a lot of
the document is is true like uh you know
this this document is all about
transparency for us we're trying to
improve we're trying to develop policy
and procedure that can maybe at one day
mirror the experience of the opp uh so
these kind of things like internal
communication was a big one improving
that improving who is actually in the
EOC not at the command table but in the
EOC for like safer finance and for
um maybe the uh the executive officer
the chief should have been there for a
better communication for internal
communication these are the things that
you know we we right away realize that
you know we're learning and uh certainly
there was there would be some changes
but the things that worked were when the
opp came into town we were completely
welcoming and that that seamless
integration of superintendent early's
team with our team everybody was pulling
the rope in the same direction and that
was what helped us that that was our
success
okay those are all my questions thank
you very much
okay
next is uh former Chief slowlease
Council
thank you commissioner
deputy chief Tom Curry for former Chief
slowly
few minutes and just a few questions
okay
um
just to get your help as a person who's
been
in policing
as long as you have been and help
holding the roles that you are pulling
the positions and ranks that you have
held
you mentioned
um the the
limitations on this service's ability to
act on information as opposed to
intelligence do you recall that
I don't no I don't like if that's what I
said I don't know if we had an inability
to act on information it was
the inability or maybe the the um
the desire to act on information at
times that was not
legitimate or confirmed or things like
that that's maybe what happened maybe
I'll maybe I can ask you about this your
colleague
um
uh who's who's in the role now of of
Chief
um
Chief Bel Air yes he gave a statement to
the commission Council I'm not going to
turn it up but can I just read you this
um he isn't going to testify so I'm just
going to get you to see whether he has
captured the idea that you have that I
understood you were
expressing and this is in relation to
the February 6th information about the
slow roll and the possibility that
protesters had threatened to block the
Ambassador Bridge you recall that on the
sixth learning that yes sir what Chief
Belair said it said and this is just for
reference on page two
of his statement
he said however he stated that he was
reluctant to interfere with the flow of
traffic to and from the bridge
in the absence of compelling
intelligence
because of the importance of the bridge
to international trade
okay is that a sentiment that you you
agree with
um as a critical instant Commander I
mean I can't disagree with it but I
certainly uh was not willing to
interject in that point to escalate the
situation right in other words not you
weren't going to be on the basis of what
you had heard of a threat you weren't
going to go closing roads all over town
we were going to disrupt things and I
don't know how when you say earlier that
you were following the events in Ottawa
you understood that that was a much
larger much more significant and complex
protest than the one that you were
dealing with I would agree the number of
vehicles that actually blocked this
critical infrastructure
strikes me as a very small number do you
agree
well compared to what Ottawa was dealing
with I would say yes but I mean we got
times we were estimating up to 150
Vehicles 150 and as in the low end for
the commissioner's purposes sometimes I
saw numbers that were below 50 even as
they came and went I'd have to trust on
that I don't okay no that's don't we'll
my my intelligence was going by drone
shots and things like that I'm 10
kilometers away right very hard to get
actual information about it tell the
commissioner if you would please where
were these plates where were these
vehicles coming from what do you got on
the plate
um Ontario I would most of them there
were some locals as we ran place the
officers on grounds running plates
um
you know there was different areas of
the province right I would say mostly
Ontario though and and were there any
from outside of Ontario I don't recall
sorry I really don't okay
um and therefore we wouldn't know you
wouldn't have any good intelligence as
to whether any of them had originated at
the protest in Ottawa and then come down
to Windsor no
um a couple of then just uh very quick
things resources if I understand what
you were telling us you when resources
were required and it was obvious that
first of all that the Windsor Police
Service was overwhelmed by this couldn't
handle it itself yes
um the the main goal is to get the get
the resources in town and you can
formalize the requests afterwards you I
think you talked about inspector to
inspector and then having a more formal
request go from the chief to the chief
as needed is that fair uh yeah that's
fair and they you were asked by my
friends from the commission about
whether you knew about the fact that the
chief that is your Chief had sent a
letter to the minister to minister Jones
and to or solicitor general Jones and
Minister Mendocino on February 9th and
you indicated you did not know that at
the time
yeah I I don't think I did I mean I was
working midnights at the time well and
it reflects doesn't it what what might
be euphemistically referred to as the
fog of War there was a lot going on yes
sir and the the environment was very
complex and complicated it was you
couldn't be expected to know every
single thing that was going on in the
service no I mean we all had our roles
my role was critical incident command I
was either working or sleeping at that
point
probably very little of the very little
of the Sleep Last yes
um and then finally can I just ask you a
question about critical incident command
certainly um
first of all you remained the police of
jurisdiction you've told us that that's
correct that it superintendent early's
she's coming here but uh superintendent
early described in her statement and I
anticipate she will say that there was a
delay
in the in undertaking the operation
uh as a consequence of the letter that
my uh that you've heard about and that
you saw okay were you aware of that no
and did you know that the decision to
delay the operation
was reviewed by commissioner karik and a
Deputy Commissioner Deputy Commissioner
Harkins
who
I'm going to use the language overruled
or at least Express The View that
commissioner that superintendent early
should not pause the enforcement out of
concern about the potential impact of
that letter from the solicitor general
are you aware of any of that I I
wouldn't know I was not aware of that I
was aware of a possible date change but
I was not aware when it went back to the
12th and did you know that what what
superintendent early was was concerned
with was that if a letter was going to
go to Windsor protesters from the
solicitor general that it might have an
impact up in Ottawa and that maybe we
better maybe she thought we better get
that letter up to Ottawa which she did
were you aware of any of that no not at
the time and then finally am I am I
right that you became aware that in
terms of the chain of command and who
needs to approve what that
before an opp public order unit
operation is rolled out that that it is
not just up to the critical incident
Commander but rather a Deputy
Commissioner has to authorize that that
is I don't know that that may be an opp
policy but I that certainly wasn't the
Windsor okay right understood okay we
can ask superintendent early thank you
for your help thank you sir thank you
okay next is uh the Ottawa Police
Service
good afternoon deputy chief Crowley my
name is David mitchikovsky I'm counsel
for the Ottawa Police Service bye for
now
um you served as the critical incident
Commander during the day shift is that
correct or during the uh night shift
correct yes and in that regard am I
correct that you had operational
autonomy to make necessary decisions
under the incident command system that's
correct and so you would be operating at
the operational level that's correct and
the level above you uh would be the
chief at the Strategic level that's
correct uh but there's only one level
above you correct that's correct and so
unlike in Ottawa where we had an
Incident Commander an event commander
and a major Incident Commander and then
a chief that wasn't uh comparable to the
situation in Windsor was it no that's
you're correct in saying that and chief
Mizuno and um Deputy uh Bel Air
respected your autonomy and didn't
interfere with your operational
decisions completely respected it yes
and that's an important aspect of how
the incident command system is supposed
to work am I correct you're correct
and um you shared command with the opp
but that's because the Windsor Police
Service recognized that in an operation
of this nature the opp obviously had
much more experience and expertise than
the um Windsor Police Service that's
correct yes
um lessons learned from Ottawa I believe
you learned a number of lessons based on
what had happened in Ottawa and these
are things that you would not otherwise
have known is that fair that's fair and
so in uh fact
um in I won't call up the document but I
believe in one of the documents you
talked about benefiting from the
hindsight of ottawa's experience of
enjoying the benefits of the hindsight
from ottawa's experience and that uh
impacted how Windsor decided to proceed
correct on certain things the things
that I talked about earlier
um certainly but not not everything I
mean like for instance when when the opp
came down and we you know started to
share command and and work as a team
that was that was just the way I it went
like that was just that was an accepted
practice in my book that's how I want it
to work sure and and I'm sure super
superintendent early will say the same
thing or can should say the same thing
because that's it just work that way and
um another example of learning from
Ottawa was I believe we saw in one of
the documents again I won't turn it up
when it came to looking at the message
to be given to demonstrators I think it
was a bit of a cut and paste uh from
what Ottawa had done correct I can't I
can't confirm that sorry
um I can call up the document if that'll
help it's a
wps40 10 17.
and so you'll see uh this is a simply a
prepared statement if required for
future use it very much mirrors what
Ottawa Police put out and I may very few
uh changes to what they had and then
underneath if you scroll down you'll see
that was the message given to
demonstrators okay so just judging by
the time I was not at work yet I was
still on midnights of the email but I I
certainly can't disagree that maybe it
is the same thank you very much you can
take that down thank you
um from the outset as I understand it
Windsor Police Service tried their very
best to respect the right to Peaceful
assembly
correct keeping lines of communication
open that's correct and very importantly
using police discretion that's correct
and using police discretion means
sometimes officers need to retreat when
crowds get aggressive in fact I think
you told us an example in which you
witnessed that correct that's part of
their use of force model yes
and um it just um I want to just uh
briefly uh conclude by talking about the
intelligence and I understand that the
first tendon report that has a possible
reference to a blockade in Windsor was
January 31st but there wasn't a lot of
information about it correct no numbers
he didn't uh no dates
and although I understand
um after that then on February 4th I
gather there was some social media
reports suggesting a possible blockade
but again not a lot of information
that's correct sir yes and I understand
that although you had some Advanced
information then about a possible
blockade on January 31st February 4th
the specific operational plan wasn't in
place when the bridge initially shut
down on the seventh correct you're
talking about the public Order Plan yes
yes that was not in place no and it's
not always possible to be completely
prepared in advance is that fair it is
fair yes and so I believe on February
8th there was a general request uh we
heard to the opp for officers and that
was followed on February 9th with that
letter that we saw earlier for the
hundred officers which gave some
information but that didn't provide a
complete plan was it no it was not a
complete plan at all
and ultimately what was required
um was a Pou operation was necessary to
end the matter yes sir and that means
there's going to be arrests there's
going to be criminal charges and it's an
escalation that's correct that's correct
it is an escalation for sure thank you
very much I have no further questions
next are the is the national uh police
Federation
uh
hi there this is Lauren Pierce for the
National Police Federation
um our questions have been asked already
we have no further questions
thank you
thank you
next are the Convoy organizers
good evening for the record Brendan
Miller appearing as Council for Freedom
Corp which represents the protesters
that were in the city
of February uh sir if we could first uh
Master Clark had just the document that
my friend referred to uh OPP uh ending
bunch of zeros four five three nine
could we bring that up and go to the
page that he was on page 42 where that
tweet is
foreign
that my friend put to you earlier fair
fair right and can we scroll down with
uh
the commentary
okay
who is that individual do you know who
posted that I have no idea I don't even
know if I ever saw this uh you don't
know if they even were at the Windsor
bridge
I don't know right you don't even know
if that's a real account I don't know
okay
um can you agree with me I just want to
put sort of as I understand and these
are not my words I'm about to put to you
but I want to know if you agree with the
following with respect to online uh
social media and spaces so
the anonymity of an online space allows
individuals to post commentary that they
would not normally say in public many
posts in this space are best articulated
and again this is not my words as [ __ ]
posting
confirmation bias strategic analysis
must be driven by direct evidence
collection and assessment as opposed to
Reliance on social media posting as it
lacks context and where the posters bias
may not be considered would you agree
with that
uh potentially yes but I can say that
like I said I don't even think I saw
this but when it talks about real
evidence when I heard the protesters
themselves on the open chat talking
about human Shields children as human
Shields and seeing a picture with
children holding hands across the
intersection at here in church in
college in the early stages that's hard
evidence for me okay and of course you
followed up on investigating that and
making sure that you know that wasn't an
issue our special investigations unit
was definitely involved and they they in
view the um they deal with the children
the crimes against children along with
Cas for sure okay can we scroll down to
page 44 please
okay and so this is your uh an opp
intelligence assessment of Windsor can
we scroll down
and you want to take a minute to read
that
what's the date on this sir
it's off okay thank you four in the
morning
and you can agree there that the report
there from the 12 from Opp says no
purses were observed outside
uh there was no children were observed
but believed to be inside a camper
if we can scroll down
only Canadian flags observed
that's it so you can agree based on that
report
as of the 12th according to the opp uh
that wasn't really an issue not at this
time for sure and again we
you agree possibly with what I said to
you with respect uh to
essentially the validity of relying on
social media alone right
we did not rely on the loan but I would
agree with that you cannot rely on a
loan yes thank you thank you
okay next to the Ottawa residents
coalition
hi there Christine Johnson from the
Ottawa residents and businesses we have
no questions for this witness thank you
okay next is the city of Ottawa
good evening deputy chief my name is
Anne hardif I'm one of the lawyers
representing the city of Ottawa
um Mr clerk if we could put up
wps600216.
all right and if we could go to page
eight well actually let's just identify
the document first oh
there we go
um
deputy chief these are the Scribe notes
for the critical incident commanders
During the period in question is that
correct these are the Windsor scribe
notes yes
sorry the WPS scribe notes right for the
winner yes there's WPS scribe notes for
the yes I may not have said it it's it's
late in the day so thank you for that
um and so these would have been scribe
notes for you during what we're calling
the midnight shifts and inspector
DeGraff during the day shift there
that's correct yes okay and uh we've
heard some evidence uh from uh the mayor
this morning about uh he's being
reminded or advised at some point that
he perhaps should not have made the uh
the concerns about making uh specific
requests for additional resources public
and I just wanted uh to go to page eight
of this document first
just to situate Us in time do you see
the date there uh deputy chief February
9th yes and if we could scroll down to
page 11 it'll be still February 9th but
just to situate us
at time chat timestamp of 11 35 Please
Mr clerk we could scroll down do you see
there it says cic
superintendent Mike MacDonald and he's a
superintendent with the opp correct
that's correct and then it says comms
OPP liaison via phone
cic relay message from him being a
superintendent McDonald to Chief and
also to Mayor not discuss any requests
for additional resources goes against
slash contrary messaging from Opp and
our CMP prompts protesters to gather
strength and in intensity that should
perhaps be intensify presence you see
that yes so I take it that
superintendent MacDonald from the opp
was asking the Windsor cic to relate to
the chief of police and to the mayor
their advice or their request that any
uh request for additional resources not
be discussed publicly is that fair
that's fair and if we scroll to the 11
35 timestamp that message I guess was
was relayed correct I'm assuming I I was
this was a day shift so I wasn't there
for this but I'm assuming it was relayed
yes if it's in describe now it's fair to
assume that it was in fact relayed yes
thank you very much those are my
questions
okay uh next to call on the government
of Alberta
good evening can you hear me
all right thank you my name is Stephanie
Bose appearing on behalf of the
government of Alberta I just have a
couple of questions today
um you've already been taken to the
letter that was sent by Chief Mizuno to
both Minister Blair and Minister Jones I
don't intend to call that up again but I
understand from your responses to
commission council's questions earlier
that you were not aware of that letter
is that correct that's correct
and um in the one of the requests within
that letter was a request for tow trucks
including heavy tow trucks for large
transport Vehicles is it fair to say
that you were not aware of this request
for tow trucks as well
it could be I don't recall to be honest
I I know that we were in need of those
kind of services we only had the one uh
contracted service in Windsor but I
can't say that if I knew that or not
do you recall if you received any um
assistance in the form of tow trucks
um at the the POU action day we did
receive uh help from the state of
Michigan
they ended up sending a handful of
trucks tow trucks over
to Windsor they were staged at McMac
Park which is approximately four
kilometers from the bridge but we did
not use them
okay and were you are you aware if there
was any response ever received by The
Windsor Police Service to those requests
from minister to minister Blair or
Minister Jones I'm not aware of any
all right thank you those are all my
questions today
thank you
okay next uh call on the Windsor uh
Police Service
uh thank you Mr commissioner I am Tom
McRae for Windsor Police Service
can I ask you to go please to a document
that was shown to you earlier WPS
five zeros one four four one
please
could you uh please tell us whose
flashes are on that uh
first page that would be the Ontario
Provincial Police The Windsor Police the
London Police and the Flash of the RCMP
in addition to those Police Services who
else assisted Windsor Police Service in
its operations at The Ambassador Bridge
we had assistance from the Hamilton
Police Service from the Waterloo Police
Service
um
off the top of my head that may be it
thank you
could I ask Mr clerk that you call up a
witness statement of Catherine deodati
it's six euros 62.
for uh context Ms Dio daddy is a
protester who is president Windsor I
understand the commission does not
intend to call her but intends to submit
her witness statement in evidence
could you go please to the third page
about halfway down
a little more uh that's perfect that's
perfect
it says
um
at 7 pm the injunction came into effect
Ms diodati said that by 7 30 PM a young
police officer was handing out sheets of
paper which explained the terms of the
injunction and the potential
consequences for failing to comply with
it including fines and confiscation of
property can you assist the commission
deputy chief by advising us as to the
best of your knowledge what other
efforts were made to inform the public
of the terms of the injunction and
generally uh the legal consequences of
the protest
certainly so we utilized mainstream
media
we utilized social media we printed the
documents put them on telephone poles
Jersey barriers anywhere we could we
handed Flyers out to the protesters we
made every effort we could with every
source of media that we could to to
educate people on the existence of it
and the consequences would be of course
charge of a criminal charge of
disobeying a court order
thank you
the statement continues Ms deodadi said
she asked the officer what does this
mean in terms of legality of protests
will someone arrest us
she observed that the officer was
shaking which surprised her she said
that she thought that the officer must
have heard that the protesters were
violent so she told the officer you're
safe it's okay none of us have ever been
violent was there violence during the
context of or during this placate of the
Ambassador Bridge yes
the next paragraph it says on Saturday
February 12th Ms deodati went to Huron
Church Road near College Road
Ms diodati said the area was barricaded
by police and the intersection looked
like a war zone which did not fit with
the joyful atmosphere
Miss diodati recall that she also spoke
to a police officer from the East Coast
she said look at these heavy armored
vehicles and Firearms what are you
planning to do with us
um on the 12th were there uh armored
vehicles in the neighborhood of the
Ambassador Bridge yes sir what was their
purpose
um well they potentially have numerous
purposes they can be used to block
intersections to assist us in that uh
that capacity uh in this state on the
12th they were they were there to um you
know like you can imagine the
unpredictability of of a an event of
this kind at this point so
um in critical incident command there's
a saying that uh I'd rather be looking
at it than asking for it so
um typically those those are are held
for a Higher Ground
an officer can be at the top of it's a
very high vehicle I can see the crowd
from a better perspective uh and also uh
it is essentially sat back
um in case we need it for um crowd
control or or anything worse
other than these policing purposes you
described is there any was there any
other purpose
for these uh Vehicles no not at all
um you you told my friend Mr majikovski
for the Ottawa Police that uh the chief
and the deputy chief did not um
get involved in your critical incident
command was there any political
involvement in any of your decisions
with respect to the Ambassador Bridge
blockade zero
thank you those are my questions
thank you
any uh re-examination
non-commissioner
okay I I haven't gotten much I I just
one thing I'm confused about and uh that
uh arises from the videos uh that the uh
were shown
um
by citizens for freedom and you saw and
the the arrest of the person who was on
on the ground
how does that fit in I thought you
testified that there were they could
continue to protest on the sidewalk and
this person doesn't seem to have been on
the street and I'm trying to understand
exactly maybe I don't know the geography
yes sorry sir so there let me explain
when I said that about the protesters on
the sidewalk that was outside of the
area of control that we had tried to
establish so once after the 13th we
established basically from the bridge to
Tecumseh Road and a little bit to the
east so there's a Canadian Tire for
instance right on that Northwest
northeast corner if they're on that
sidewalk outside of our Jersey barriers
we had no problem with that if they're
inside the area of control that we were
trying to establish they were they were
asked to leave and if they weren't they
were arrested so that arrested in that
video that we were shown that is in that
area of control and here in church north
of Tecumseh Road between the Tecumseh
Road and the bridge that is the area
that public order was clearing of
vehicles and of of
of pedestrians essentially so again once
that area of control was was uh
determined and established
anyone outside of it could stay on the
sidewalk no problem that video was not
in that area that I'm talking about on
the sidewalk can you just remind me then
again and I've I've lost the map from my
mind uh the
the area of control if you call it is
was from the bridge
Tecumseh Road is that that was the area
that Pou cleared
but south of Tecumseh Road was part of
the traffic playing with the Jersey
barriers but that was another area of of
protesters if they were on the sidewalk
in that that area which they weren't if
they were no problem they were out of
that area of control south of Tecumseh
Road so that's yes from Tecumseh to the
bridge was the area that we were trying
to maintain no cross tattoos and
how far is it from Tecumseh to the
to the expressway
uh two kilometers or so so the and so
the bridge to Tecumseh would be about a
kilometer uh I'd say two or three maybe
yeah two
so about half of
of the uh Huron
Church Road would be if you like not
available on the sidewalks for
protesters but the other half would be
that's correct
based on their areas of protest
for that week because they had areas at
Tecumseh Road
at the south side of the bridge and the
north side of the bridge that was the
area we were trying to clear
okay and uh the uh at
you talked about uh being at the
emergency preparedness Committee of the
chiefs of police and discussion there
yes were there meetings of that group
during this period in uh early February
when the protests were going on
yes sir there were and I assume oh so
you weren't a party to those meetings
um I wasn't personally because again I
was on Midnight's inspector De Graff
would have tuned into those
um but when I flipped over to days about
halfway through I would be on those
meetings when they were scheduled yes
okay and were there discussions at those
meetings about the available resources
for Pou units across the province that's
correct that's correct there's a Pou Hub
that's how we try and uh work it uh
within the province of Distributing
necessary resources in these cases yes
so there was those discussions at those
meetings
and we're those discussions that they
include what was needed for Ottawa
and were there enough Pou units to deal
with the Ottawa situation in Ontario yes
in my opinion and being a part of that
committee it seemed like there was
and so
were you part of those discussions
um I was on those meetings but because
Windsor didn't have Pou officers to uh
to offer because we don't have a Pou you
know I was just a part of it I wasn't an
active part of it because I had nothing
to offer at that point
okay thank you
uh so I think that completes the
evidence thank you for your attendance
and your evidence
and we will adjourn uh till tomorrow
morning at 9 30.
the commission is adjourned that
Commission